AHEAD AND GET STARTED WITH
TODAY'S HEARING ON I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES WERE HERE. WITH US.
BEFORE WE BEGAN I HAVE BEEN
ASKED TO READ SOME DIRECTIONS
REGARDING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
IN TODAY'S HEARING. TO HELP
ENSURE THE SAFETY. OF EVERYONE
HERE WHILE ALLOWING FOR FULL
PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION
. TWO THEY WERE HAVING AN IN
PERSON HEARING IN THE STATE
CAPITOL ROOM FOUR THIRTY SEVEN.
THE PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA ARE
APPEARING REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY. FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
WE WILL BEGIN WITH THOSE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM FOLLOWED BY PHONE
TESTIMONY. EACH PERSON WILL HAVE
ONE MINUTE JUST ONE MINUTES TO
SPEAK. THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD ALSO BE ON
THE SCREEN OF YOUR STREAMING
THIS HEARING. THE NUMBER JUST IN
CASE IS THE PUBLIC TOLL FREE
NUMBER EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
AND THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. EVEN COUNTER ANY PROBLEMS
PLEASE CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO
NINE NINE AND A STAFF MEMBER
WILL ASSIST YOU. WE WILL NOT BE
TAKING ANY VOTES TODAY. NO TODAY
WE'LL BE DISCUSSING THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND THE BOARD OF
STATE AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
FOR EACH ITEM THE SPEAKERS ARE
LISTED IN THE SPEAKING ORDER IN
THE AGENDA. I WANT TO ALSO TAKE
A MINUTE TO BE A WELCOME THE
CHAIR OF BUDGET HERE TODAY MR
TANG. AT ISSUE NUMBER ONE IS
GOING TO BE OUR STATEWIDE
CORRECTIONAL VIDEO SURVEILLANCE
SYSTEM. IN OUR OF OUR PALACE ARE
READY THEY CAN BEGIN. CAPITAL
HERE IN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS MARIAN'S BERMAN I'M
AN ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTION REHABILITATION. THIS
REQUEST IS TO CONTINUE THE STATE
WIDE CORRECTIONAL VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE ROLLOUT. WHICH
INCLUDES FUNDING IN POSITION TO
DEPLOY SIX CAMERAS CAN
ADDITIONAL PRISONS. AND BODY
WORN CAMERAS AT FOR ADDITIONAL
PRISONS. IT'S REQUEST ALSO
PROVIDES FUNDING TO MANAGE TO
MAINTAIN A RECORDED VIDEO. FIX
THE BODY WORN
. I'M BUDGET
ACT INCLUDED RE SOURCES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT ALSO DEPLOY SIX
CAMERAS AT FOUR PRISONS. SO THAT
CONCLUDES MY INTRODUCTION NOW
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS. DO WE
HAVE A DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I
THINK HE WOULD DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO SPECIFIC COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME BUT AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE- YES OKAY THANK YOU AND I
DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
STORAGE OF. THE FOOTAGE- RIGHT
NOW THE PLAN IS THE
RECOMMENDATION THAT HAS COME
FORWARD WITH. A NINETY DAY.
STORAGE AND TO WONDER WHAT THE
COFFEE FOR NINETY BASIS VERSUS
FOR A WHOLE YEAR. AND I'M ASKING
THIS QUESTION BECAUSE FOR THE
TENTH COMPLAINTS THE COMPLAINTS
SYSTEM TAKES A LITTLE BIT LONGER
THAN NINETY DAYS. AND WORRIED
ABOUT EVIDENCE THAT WE MIGHT
LOSE TO HELP IN THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS. WE HAVEN'T HI
I'M TAMMY IRWIN I'M FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION AND ENTERPRISE
INFORMATION. SERVICES AND WE
HAVE NOT. CONDUCTED A COMPLETE
ANALYSIS OF THE- COSTA VIDEO ANY
LONGER THAN. NINETY DAYS BECAUSE
IT WAS DEEMED AT RISK.
RESPONSIBLE REASONABLE THAT-
NINETY DAYS WAS A SUFFICIENT I'M
AND MY HERE- EIGHTY THREE MEN.
WILL BE ABLE TO SPEAK MORE TO
THAT- BUT WE CAN IF NECESSARY TO
GET YOU A- A COST FOR THAT. HOW
HOW IS THAT DECIDED THE NINETY
DAYS WAS RESPONSIBLE AND
REASONABLE. WILTEL WISHLIST SIDE
IT WAS AS IT RELATES TO RULES
VIOLATION REPORTS THAT PROCESS
TAKES FORTY FIVE DAYS. ALSO IF
THERE IS A USE OF FORCE ON A CAR
TRIP PERSON THE INSTITUTION
EXECUTIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE WHAT
READ THE HAS TO REVIEW THAT
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF THE
INCIDENT. AND ALSO WITH OUR
GRIEVANCE PROCESS THE
INCARCERATED PERSONS THEY CAN
SUBMIT GRIEVANCE WITHIN SIXTY
DAYS OF THE EVENT. SO WE LOOKED
AT FACTORS AS FAR AS YOU KNOW
TIME BETWEEN INCIDENCES AND
GRIEVANCES BEING FILED BUT IT'S
CONSISTENT ALSO WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND
OFFENDER EDUCATION THE POLICY.
IMPLEMENTATION OF A ROBUST LIST
OF ITEMS THAT RESULTED VIDEO
FOOTAGE TO TRANSFERRED TO LONG
TERM STORAGE. AND ALSO LIKE I
COULD MENTION THE OFFENDER
POPULATION WASN'T VERY WELL
EDUCATED AND FOR THE MOST PART
WE SEE THAT DATE. WHEN A FILE
GRIEVANCES IS WELL WITHIN NINETY
DAYS. SO I UNDERSTAND THE
POLICIES THAT YOU JUST DESCRIBED
BUT IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THEIR SON YOU PROPOSED PROCESS
THAT WOULD ELIMINATE THE TIME
LIMIT FOR STAFF COMPLAINTS FOR
EXAMPLE AND FOR THE NINETY DAYS
. WHEN A LONGER KIND OF MAKES
SENSE FOR THOSE. THE. I'M NOT
CLEAR ON THAT A. B. IT IS A NEW
POLICY YOU SAY THAT AGAIN YES
YES THAT'S ANOTHER THING YOU
POLICY OUT THERE ARE YOU
PROPOSAL FOR A NEW POLICY. THAT
WOULD ELIMINATE THE TIME LIMIT.
FOR STAFF COMPLAINTS. OKAY WELL
ANY ARE QUITE WILL SAY IS IF
SOMEONE FILES A GRIEVANCE OR
COMPLAINT AGAINST. AN EMPLOYEE.
IF THEY DEAL WITH A NINETY DAY
PERIOD WE HAVE THE FOOTAGE THAT
THEY CAN REQUEST A PLACE TO BE
YOU KNOW RECORDER CAN BE
BOOKMARKED AND SAVED. IF IT WAS
THE FALLOUT FOUR VIDEO
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM WE WOULD STILL
THOROUGHLY LOOK INTO THE
INVESTIGATION SO IF SOMEONE
REPORTED A YEAR LATER FOR THE
REPORTED SIX MONTHS LATER AND
THE FOOTAGE WASN'T FAIR WE WOULD
STILL LOOK INTO A COMPLAINT. AND
I LIKE TO KIND OF MENTION THAT
YOU KNOW VIDEO FOOTAGE AND
RECORDINGS IN EVIDENCE IT'S ONLY
ONE TOOL THAT WE USE OUR TOOL
BOX TO THOROUGHLY INVESTIGATE
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF MISCONDUCT
OR PRISON RAPE ELIMINATION
ALLEGATIONS OR ANY OTHER REASONS
SET. A COURSE FOR A PERSON WITH
FILE- THE FIRE. THE IT'S JUST
TOLD IT'S A PRETTY. TOOL IT'S A
TOOL THAT THE COURTS HAVE ASKED
THIS TO IMPLEMENTED MORE
PRESENTS. OUT THERE AND SO I
THINK WHEN THE NINETY THE
PROPOSAL WAS CREATED AROUND THE
PREVIOUS ROLES AND MADE SENSE. I
WOULD THINK NOW THAT WE THE
RULES ARE CHANGING IN FOR SAP
COMPLAINTS AND THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE. A AND AN INDEFINITE PERIOD
OF TIME I THINK IT WOULD MAKE
SENSE FOR US TO AT LEAST LOOK AT
THE POTENTIAL FOR LONGER STORAGE
AND WHAT THAT WOULD MEAN AS FAR
AS PRICING AND- FAITH AND I KNOW
THAT THERE'S ALSO CLOUT ISSUES
OR SO FORTH BUT I DO THINK GIVEN
THAN YOUR POLICY. MAYBE WE NEED
TO RETHINK OF NINETY DAYS STILL
ADEQUATE FOR WHERE THAT EVIDENCE
. OKAY IF I MAY THIS IS
BATTLING. UP DIRECTOR. OF THE
SCHOOL SERVE. WHICH WANTED TO
NOTE THAT. EVEN THOUGH THE
POLICY IS CHANGING TO. ELIMINATE
THE TIME CONSTRAINTS FOR FOLKS
TO FILE- AND CLAIM. ON AVERAGE
ALL OF THE MOST CLAIMS WERE
FILED WITHIN THE TIME PERIOD I
97% OF CLAIMS WERE FILED WITHIN
THE TIME PERIODS SO WE- JUST
BEAUSE WE HAVE ARE HAVING A
CHANGE IN THAT PROCESS IT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT. WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THAT THEY WILL NOT.
THEY WILL NOT FILE WITHIN A
TIMELY MANNER AS WELL- THAT'S
ALSO BASED ON THE FACT THAT WE
HAD THIS. THAT A FACT NEW THERE
ARE THESE ALL ROLES IN THIS
SHORTER TIME WHEN THOUGH. I'M
NOT SURE OF THE HERE IS GOING TO
CHANGE AS FAR AS REPORTING IS
CONCERNED NOW THAT WE HAVE A
LONGER. TIME WINDOW. FOR PEOPLE
TO COME FORWARD- AND SO I'M NOT
SURE. I'M NOT SURE OF THE NINETY
BASIS ADEQUATE. MAYBE IT IS BUT
I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE YOU TO
LOOK INTO- PRINT DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR US WITH MORE TIME
FOR STORAGE FOR THESE VIDEOS
SINCE. THESE VIDEOS ARE A
POWERFUL PART OF THE PROCESS.
THE MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS MISTER
CHANG. WITH OFF UP IN THE FAMED
LINE OF QUESTIONING SO QUESTION
TO THE DEPARTMENT. HAS THERE
BEEN THE CASE WERE ON. ANY ANY
DELETED FOOTAGE WAS ACTUALLY
NEEDED FOR A CASE BUT IT WAS
ACTUALLY DELETED. THIS IS
MISTRESS BERMAN RESTRICTING AS
FAR AS MY KNOWLEDGE TO KNOW THAT
I HAVEN'T HEARD ANY FOOTAGE
BEING DELETED. THAT WAS NEEDED
FOR. SOME TYPE OF INVESTIGATION
. WHERE'S MY MONEY OFF HERE SO
WHAT HAPPENS AFTER THE NINETY
DAYS. MY DEFERRED AT INSIDE HOW
HAVE MRS ERRING KIND EXPLAINED
THAT VIDEO MANAGEMENT SYSTEM THE
PROCESS VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
ONCE HI THIS IS JAMIE ALLEN I'M
ONCE VIDEO THERE IS A TRIGGERING
EVENT IDENTIFIED THEN THE VIDEO
IS THEN- TRANSITIONED TO LONGER
TERM STORAGE- BUT WHERE IT HAS-
SET PROTOCOLS. FOR STORAGE SO
LIMITED ACCESS- READ ONLY TO
THOSE WHO- NEED TO VIEW OR HAVE
ACCESS TO THE VIDEO. GOT A GOT A
FOR THE FOR THE FOOTAGES IS
RETAINED ITS JUST NOT. AS
IMMEDIATELY ACCESSIBLE. IT IS
IMMEDIATELY ACCESSIBLE BUT ONLY
TO THOSE WHO- HAVE PERMISSION IN
ORDER TO ACCESS AND THEIR ROLE
IS- SET ACCORDINGLY- WHICH ONLY-
AND ADMINISTRATOR WOULD HAVE
FULL CONTROL OVER THAT- ACCESS
WHICH IS VERY LIMITED. I'M SO
PEOPLE THAT- AT VIEW VIDEO OR
ARE INVOLVED IN AN INCIDENT- I
WOULD HAVE ONLY READ ONLY
ACCESS. AND JUST JUST ARM JUST
AFTER THING QUESTION TO YOU IS
DUE TO. THE OTHER GENTLEMAN ON
HAVE THE BEEN SITUATIONS WHERE
THE FOOTAGE HAD BEEN REQUESTED
PASSED THAT NINETY DAY WINDOW.
I'M I AM NOT I'M ON THE
TECHNICAL SIDE AND NOT ON THE
OPERATIONAL SIDE TO MY
KNOWLEDGE- THAT HAS NOT. BEEN
THE CASE- BUT I CAN'T SPEAK TO
THAT. OKAY ANYONE ELSE BESIDES
MR SPEARMAN WHO CAN SPEAK.
DEFINITIVELY TO THE. WE WILL
WORK WITH OUR OPERATIONS FOLKS
GET BACK WITH YOU BUT- A CORE
PART OF YOUR QUESTION I THINK IS
YES AFTER NINETY DAYS OF A
TRIGGERING EVENT HASN'T OCCURRED
OR- OF CLAIMS BEEN FILED THE
FOOTAGE IS DELETED- BUT WE WILL
GO BACK AND LOOK TO SEE IF AFTER
THAT NINETY DAY PERIOD THERE
WERE CASES WHERE- FOOTAGE WOULD
HAVE ASSISTED WITH THE
INVESTIGATION I THINK THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE A CORE OF WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET CORRECT
THAT THAT THAT IS BUT I GUESS
I'M GOING TO ANSWER SOME OF
THESE THE FOOTAGE DELETED OR NOT
DELETED BECAUSE MY UNDERSTANDING
WAS. FROM YOUR TERM TECHNICAL
PERSON THAT THE FOOTAGE WAS-
STORED SOMEWHERE ELSE. IF ENTRY
. A ORACLE. A COMPLAINT WAS BY.
OKAY SO THERE'S NO CLAIM FILED
THAN THAT BECAUSE TO LIVE OAK.
WHAT GOT IT SO I THINK I THINK
IT'S VERY QUICK VERY IMPORTANT
FOR US TO KNOW WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S BEEN A CLAIM. THAT DOES
COME IN THE PAST AND THEN TO THE
WINDOW. AGAIN IT BASED ON OUR-
PREVIOUS LOOK AT THE DATA. FOR
THE LAST YEAR. ONLY 3% OF.
ISSUES CAME OUT WHERE IT WAS
AFTER THE FACT AFTER THAT NINETY
DAY STORAGE. SO WHAT HAPPENED IN
THE 3% THIS IS A- I WOULD HAVE
TO WORK WITH OUR LEGAL TEAM AND
OPERATIONS TEAM TO GET SPECIFICS
ON THAT. WHERE THOSE CASES THAT
YOU LOOKED AT ALL BEFORE THIS
NEW YEAR THIS INCLUDE CASES
AFTER THE NEW YEAR SAYS THIS IS
A POLICY THAT WENT INTO EFFECT.
WITH THE NEW YEAR. I BELIEVE IS
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE FISCAL
YEAR. RIGHT FOR MAKING AN
ASSUMPTION ON. THE PROCESS THAT
IS DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE HAVE
AND I WILL BE INFORMED. AND SO
WOULD BE INTERESTING TO SEE IF
THE- IF PEOPLE ARE TAKING LONGER
KNOWING THAT THEY HAVE MORE TIME
ENOUGH TO ISSUE THOSE
COMPLAINTS. THAT'S MY ONLY
CONCERN THAT BEHAVIOR MIGHT BE
CHANGING GIVEN THE NEW POLICY
UNTIL NINETY DAYS MIGHT OR MIGHT
NOT BE ADEQUATE AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE. ADEQUATE
DATA GIVEN THEN YOU'RE THEN
YOU'RE PROCESS WE HAVE. WHICH IS
NOT NECESSARILY YOUR FAULT YOU
CAN'T YOU DON'T IN A PLAN THAT
HAS A VERY ENOUGH TIME OUT THERE
BUT I DO THINK WE NEED TO BE
MINDFUL OF THAT FOR MAKING
DECISIONS. THIS IS A
THUNDERSTORM I'M SORRY LITTLE
PLEASED HAD PLEASE PLEASE. I WAS
JUST GONNA OF REITERATE
SOMETHING THAT MR SPEARMAN
POINTED OUT THAT IS WE HAVE BEEN
DOING A LOT OF OFFENDER
EDUCATION ON THIS NEW PROCESS TO
MAKE THEM ALL VERY AWARE OF HOW
WHAT THE CHANGES ARE HOW AND HOW
THEY WILL IMPACT THEM SO WE
THINK THAT- OFFENDER EDUCATION
PLUS RELAPSE NEW PROCESS THE
NINETY DAYS THE SUFFICIENT WHAT
. MEMBERS OKAY I GUESS I THINK
WE ARE HERE FROM MARCH IS JUST
CONCERN ON EVEN AND TODAY WHAT
WE HEAR CONSTANTLY AS HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OR BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS EXPENDITURES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT THAT THIS MAY BE A
MEANWHILE WHILE WE REALLY AFFECT
THE DEPARTMENT FOR TRYING TO BE
RESOURCEFUL THIS SEEMS TO BE A
SITUATION WHERE YOU'RE BEING
PENNY WISE POUND FOOLISH AND
THAT- THIS IS A VERY CRITICAL
VIDEO FOOTAGE I MYSELF HAD A
CHANCE TO. ON WITNESS IT WHEN-
I'VE OF WITNESSING BODY CAMERA
FOOTAGE WHEN I WENT TO CORCORAN-
AND THE FACT THAT I THINK IT'S
THERE ON THE OFFICERS I THINK
IT'S VERY- COMPELLING BECAUSE
IT'S GOOD TO HAVE THAT VIDEO
EVIDENCE RATHER THAN HAVING TO.
HOW WHAT I WITNESSED RECOUNT
DIFFERENCE WHICH- I THINK IT'S
VERY CRITICAL INFORMATION TO.
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE IMPROPER
TRANSPARENCY AND THAT- SINCE WE
HAVE THE- HE VIDEO FOOTAGE
ANYWAYS I THINK IT WOULD BE A
SHAME TO ACTUALLY DELETE IT OR
TO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO IT- FIFTY
FORTY PAY FOR RECORDED AND
STORED IT ON YOU KNOW IF OTHER
CRIMES WERE COMMITTED AND FROM
THE SPECIALLY LIKE YOU AND SAID
THE 3% THE CASES THEY CAME AFTER
THE VIDEO FOOTAGE HAS ALREADY
BEEN- EITHER DELETED OR STORED
AND I'M NOT I'M NOT REALLY CLEAR
WHICH ONE. BUT IT SEEMS.
IMPORTERS WE WILL BE PAID FOR
THIS IT'S ALREADY A SUNK COST-
THE DISCIPLINE TO BE ANY. A VERY
GOOD REASON WHY THAT STORE THAT
VIDEO INFORMATION ISN'T STORED.
YOU KNOW AT LEAST ON A BOND ON A
ON A LONGER BASIS. RATHER THAN-
YOU KNOW GETTING RID OF IT SINCE
WE'VE ALREADY PAID FOR IT
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE- ANY. ANY
SIGNIFICANT COST SAVINGS
ESPECIALLY WHEN I LOOK AT ALL
YOUR OTHER PCPS WHICH ARE. TENS
OF MILLIONS HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS HERE. AND WE HAVEN'T
EVEN STARTED TALKING ABOUT YOUR
YOUR YOUR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BCPS. SO AGAIN JUST SOMETHING WE
WOULD- JETER TAKE A HARD LOOK AT
TO RECONSIDER AND- PERHAPS-
BRING SOMETHING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WE WILL GIVE
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE ANYONE ELSE HAVE ANY MORE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ON ISSUE
ONE. OKAY NOW WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND CLOSE OFFICE YOU WANT
TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE TO- IT WHICH
IS OUR INTEGRATED SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT PROGRAM AND
OF OUR PANELISTS ARE READY THEY
CAN BEGIN. YEAH THE RECORD
REGISTRATIONS THAT. EXECUTIVE
CAN YOU GET CLOSER TO THE
MICROPHONE MAYBE SPEAK LOUDER WE
COULD BARELY HEAR YOU. YES IT
DEFINITELY SOME HEIGHTS DIRECTOR
LEGISLATION PRODIGAL ANY LOUDER. GIVE US ONE SECOND. IS THIS-
MATH SCIENCES ON THE TRAIN SPEAK
RIGHT NOW. IS THIS A LOT AS YOU
SPEAK REFINES. ALL. OKAY THAT'S
MUCH BETTER. IF YOU HELP ME
CAMINO NOW. CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW
YES. THAT'S GREAT. CAN YOU HEAR
ME I'M READY. GOOD AFTERNOON
RESIGNS DIRECTOR LEGISLATION TO
BETTER PRODUCTS AND THE PROJECT
EXECUTIVE FOR THE INTEGRATED
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER TREATMENT
PROGRAM. I WANT TO THANK THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY FOR ITS SUPPORT
OF THE ICT PROGRAMME IN THE
DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS TO
SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGE THE
TREATMENT OF SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS WITHIN OUR
INSTITUTIONS. SINCE JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED I ISSUE NEEDS. FOR
PERSONS AND HAVE PROVIDED
TREATMENT TO NEARLY THIRTY
THOUSAND PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS.
IT WILL BE A CRISIS IS CAUSING
SIGNIFICANT ADDICTION AND LOSS
OF LIFE THROUGHOUT OUR COMMUNITY
IT CONTRIBUTES TO HOMELESSNESS
AND CO WORKER HEALTH AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DISORDERS AND
IS KNOWN TO DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS. THE FIRST. I'M SORRY IN THE
LINE OF HER AT THE ONE MORE TIME
SINCE THE PROGRAM. WE'RE HAVING
A HARD TIME MAYBE RETURN AFTER
VIDEO WE ARE ABLE IT WILL HAVE
BETTER INTERNET CONNECTION.
LET'S TRY THAT. CAN YOU HEAR ME
NOW YES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WE APPRECIATE IT WE
KNOW THAT TECHNOLOGY IS AND
ALWAYS OUR FRIEND CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU CAN YOU
START OVER FROM THE BEGINNING.
SURE GOOD AFTERNOON LISA HINES
ATTACKS AND THE PROJECT
EXECUTIVE FOR THE INTEGRATED
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER TREATMENT
PROGRAM I WANT TO THANK THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY FOR ITS SUPPORT
OF THE ICT PROGRAM AND THE
DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS TO
SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGE THE
TREATMENT OF SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS WITHIN OUR INSTITUTION
SINCE JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY
WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED ICT AT ALL
THIRTY FOUR PRISON AND HAVE
PROVIDED TREATMENT TO NEARLY
THIRTY THOUSAND PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS. THE OPIATE CRISIS
IS CAUSING SIGNIFICANT ADDICTION
AND LOSS OF LIFE THROUGHOUT OUR
COMMUNITIES IT CONTRIBUTES TO
HOMELESSNESS AND CO OCCURRING
HEALTH AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DISORDERS AND IS KNOWN TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS BETWEEN
TWENTY FIVE AND 30% OF
INCARCERATED POPULATIONS ARE
KNOWN TO HAVE AN OPIATE USE
DISORDER THE I. ACT PROGRAM
CONTINUES TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS TOWARDS IDENTIFYING
ASSESSING AND TREATING IT EASIER
AS MOST VULNERABLE POPULATION.
SUFFERING WITH AND SHOOTING.
SINCE PER AND- I SHOULD BE
TEASED STATEWIDE. I HAVE.
SCREENED OVER SIXTY TWO THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS FOR SGD UTILIZING
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE ON DRUG
ABUSE QUICK'S GRANA MODIFY THIS
IS A PROCESS NEARLY TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS FOR S. U.
D. UTILIZING THE NIGHT A
MODIFIED ASSIST IN THE AMERICAN
SOCIETY OF ADDICTION MEDICINE
ARE A SAM SUITE OF TOOLS HAVE
EVALUATED NEARLY TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS FOR
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT. I
PROVIDE I DO NOT TO OVER TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS AND
IT PROVIDED CVR AIRCARD HERO
INTERVENTIONS. TO OVER FOURTEEN
THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS. THIS
PROPOSED ON FIND TO THE
DEPARTMENT TO SERVE MORE
INDIVIDUALS SUFFERING WITH THE
S. T. MAKING AVAILABLE ALL
PROGRAM ELEMENTS INCLUDING
COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL INNER
ENGINES. MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
PROVIDE I DIDN'T ENHANCE FOR A
RELEASE IN TRANSITION SERVICES
CONTINUING THE PROVISION OF
NALOXONE UPON RELEASE AND
WORKING WITH OUR COUNTY AND
COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO SUPPORT.
CANADIAN LINKAGES TO SERVICES
UPON RELEASE WHEN INDIVIDUALS
SUFFERING WITH. CITY ARE MOST AT
RISK OF OVERDOSE DEATHS. I AM
HAPPY TO ANSWER NY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT THE PROPOSAL
AND HAVE SEVERAL OF THE PROGRAM
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AS- WELL. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE OUR NEXT SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME'S OUR SENSES
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE FIND THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
AND MODIFY THE INTEGRATED
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER TREATMENT
PROGRAM OR ICTP HAS MERIT
HOWEVER BASED ON OUR ASSESSMENT
WE HAVE THREE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WOULD MODIFY THE PROPOSAL.
WE ARE FIRST RECOMMENDING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE DIRECT THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE A REVISED
PROPOSAL AT THE MAY REVISION.
THAT IS ADJUSTED TO REFLECT THE
UPDATED PROJECTIONS. BECAUSE THE
OVERALL LEVEL OF FUNDING BEING
REQUESTED FOR THE PROGRAM IS
CLOSELY CONNECTED AT THE SIZE OF
THE INMATE POPULATION. THE
PROPOSAL WILL LIKELY NEED TO BE
ADJUSTED FOR THE POSSIBILITY
THAT THE INMATE POPULATION MAY
BE LOWER THAN CURRENTLY
PROJECTED AS DISCUSSED IN THE
LAST HEARING. OUR SECOND
RECOMMENDATION IS TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CHOOSES TO
APPROVE ADDITIONAL FUNDING. FOR
THE PROGRAM WE RECOMMEND
APPROVAL OF PROVISIONAL BUDGET
LANGUAGE REQUIRING THAT ANY
BUDGET FUNDS NOT SPENT ON THE
PROGRAM. REVERT TO THE GENERAL
FUND AND WE WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
FACTORS THAT COULD LIMIT THAT
DEPARTMENTS ABILITY TO EXPAND AS
PROPOSED. THESE LIMITATIONS
WOULD RESULT IN THE DEPARTMENT
NOT USING THE FULL BUDGET AMOUNT
. FOR EXAMPLE IT COULD TAKE
LONGER THAN ANTICIPATED TO FILL
THE REQUESTED THREE HUNDRED AND
TEN POSITIONS. ALSO IT IS
QUESTIONABLE WHETHER THE
DEPARTMENT WILL HAVE SUFFICIENT
SPACE TO ACCOMMODATE THE LEVEL
NECESSARY FOR THE EXPANSION.
GIVEN THAT LAST YEAR THE
DEPARTMENT NOTED SUFFICIENT
CLASSROOM SPACE AT THE PRISONS
AS A CHALLENGE. THE LAST THING.
WE ARE RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PROVIDE THE
RESULTS OF THE EVALUATION THAT
THEY ARE CONTRACTING WITH SO
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN
DETERMINE. WHETHER THE PROGRAM
IS EFFECTIVELY ACHIEVING ITS
GOALS. OR THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE PROGRAM IS NOT YET CLEAR.
INITIAL DATA SHOW THAT SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER RELATED DEATHS AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS HAVE GONE DOWN
SINCE THE PROGRAM BEGAN. THE
DEPARTMENT INTENDS TO CONTRACT
WITH THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
THAT WE- VARIOUS ASPECTS OF THE
PROGRAM. AND THINKING I'D BE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE I'D BE HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS. DO WE HAVE ON
OUR SPEAKER. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR FRANKLY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
ADMINISTRATION KNOWS THAT THE
CURRENT FLUCTUATIONS IN THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION ARE
ANTICIPATED TO IMPACT THE NEAR
TERM EGGS ARE NOT ANTICIPATED TO
IMPACT THE NEAR TERM EXPANSION
OF PROTECTED IN THIS PROPOSAL A
REVIEW OF MEDICATED THAT
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
PARTICIPANTS FIGURES INDICATES
THAT THE PROGRAM REMAINS ON
TARGET TO REACH APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND. MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT PARTICIPANTS
BY THE END OF JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AND ROUGHLY TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THE
ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZES
SERVICE- THE POTENTIAL FOR
INCREMENTAL CHANGES IN THE
PROGRAM PARTICIPANT POPULATION
FROM YEAR TO YEAR ACCORDINGLY
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL-
ASSUMES THAT THE SPECIFIC LEVEL
POPULATION DRIVEN RESOURCES FOR
THE INTEGRATED SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT PROGRAM WILL
BE ADJUSTED EACH YEAR STARTING.
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY. TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AS PART
OF THE ANNUAL CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION POPULATION JUST
PROCESS WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE BUT THAT THE
POPULATION DRIVEN METHODOLOGY
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
LIKELY MITIGATES THE NEED FOR
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE A SUGGESTED
BY THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- THE ADMINISTRATION NOTES
THAT THIS IS INVESTMENT TO
EXPAND THE- INTEGRATED SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER TREATMENT PROGRAM.
WILL PROVIDE A BETTER HEALTH- IN
PROVIDE FOR BETTER CRIMINAL
JUSTICE OUTCOMES AND REDUCE THE
NEGATIVE SOCIAL IMPACTS
ASSOCIATED WITH SUBSTANCE USE
pCOLLEAGUES HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM. MANILA
MISTER TANGO. JUST MISTER CARTER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE CAN YOU
WALK US THROUGH THE- THE
POPULATION BASED METHODOLOGY
PROPOSAL. CERTAINLY THE I'M
COMING NEED SOME HELP WITH-
BEFORE WITH MY COLLEAGUES AT A
COMPANY CORRECTIONAL HEALTHCARE
SERVICES BUT FOR THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR IT'S ANTICIPATED TO
INCREASE- EACH MONTH BY
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED AND-
EIGHTY OF PER MONTH AND THEN THE
SUBSEQUENT OF FISCAL STARTING IN
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY TWO IT'S
GOING TO IT THE POPULATION WILL
INCREASE BY APPROXIMATELY SIX
HUNDRED FORTY. WHAT HAPPENED TO
THE POPULATION DECREASES. LET'S
SAY WHAT HAPPENS I'M GOING TO BE
OPTIMISTIC WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THE
POPULATION DECREASES WHICH IS
WHAT'S BEEN PROJECTED. DO YOU
WANT TO DO YOU WANT TO CONTINUE
TO INCREASE THE NUMBER. HI THIS
IS ALLISON HULETT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. ULTIMATELY WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING IS THAT WE WOULD
ADJUST THE AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
FOR THE PROGRAM FOR CERTAIN
SPECIFIC ELEMENTS FOR EXAMPLE
THE PHARMACEUTICALS AND THAT BOB
CAN CAN IF BOB THAT NOT
PROGRAMMER THE MEDICALLY
ASSISTED TREATMENT PROGRAM
CONSISTS OF THAT WE WOULD
ACTUALLY ADJUST THOSE FROM YEAR
TO YEAR BASED ON THE POPULATION
AND SO TO THE EXTENT THAT THOSE
INCREASE OR DECREASE WE WOULD
ANTICIPATE THAT OUR- ADJUSTMENT
METHODOLOGY WOULD REFLECT THAT.
WE HAVE NOT- DETERMINE WHAT THE
PRECISE METHODOLOGY WE BELIEVE I
THAT'S FAIRLY CONSISTENT- WENT
WITH THAT THE WAY THAT WE TREAT
POPULATION DIFFERENT
METHODOLOGIES BUT WE ANTICIPATE
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO BRING
INFORMATION FORWARD IN THE NEXT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET GIVEN AT. THE
CONSISTENCY WITH THE POPULATION
ADJUSTMENT PROCESS FOR CDC ARE
OKAY SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT WE
CAN. HOLD IT UP UNTIL NEXT
JANUARY. I KNOW I. WE WOULD IN
JUST TO KIND OF REAL BASED ON
THE DATA THAT WAS THERE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FAIRLY
CONFIDENT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
ACHIEVE THEIR VALUES ADDS THAT
THE TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND THAT'S
A THEIR BASED ON CURRENT
PROJECTIONS AND THAT'S KIND OF
YOUR RESPECTIVE OF THE DROP IN
POPULATION NOT- IT MAY BE THEME
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ON TARGET
BASED ON CURRENT TRENDS COULD BE
RESPECTED OF THE POPULATION
COULD YOU ANSWER THE QUESTION I
HAVE MISTER COATING WALKING
THROUGH METHODOLOGY PLEASE. BUT
WE DON'T HAVE A METHODOLOGY YOU
ARE PREPARED YET WE WOULD
ANTICIPATE THAT THAT WOULD COME
FORWARD AS A PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. WE WHERE
WE'RE PUTTING. A REVISION OF THE
JANUARY BUDGET. IN THE IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET BECAUSE WE
WOULDN'T BE ADJUSTING THAT'S
WHAT ARE YOU ASKING THE- FOR
THIS JUNE. I'LL BE FINE FUNDING
BASED ON THE TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND. INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUAL ESTIMATES WERE
WORKING FROM. AND IF THE
POPULATION GOES DOWN WE HAVE NO
IDEA HOW YOU WOULD ADJUST THE
BASELINE FUNDING AS OF TODAY. I
MEAN GENERALLY SPEAKING WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TAKING KIND OF
THOSE THINGS THAT ARE DRIVEN BY
THE POPULATION LIKE THE
PHARMACEUTICAL COSTS FOR EXAMPLE
AND WE WOULD ASSUME THAT WE
WOULD ADJUST THAT BASED ON SOME
TYPE OF- ADJUSTMENT THAT
REFLECTS BOTH THE COST OF THOSE
PRODUCTS AND THAT. NUMBER OF
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS THAT
CITY STARTS PROTECTING TO SERVE
THAT'S FAIRLY CONSISTENT WITH
THE OVERALL CITY FAIR PROCESS
I'M AND WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION WE JUST HAVEN'T
DETERMINE THE PRECISE
METHODOLOGY YEAH. I'M NOT THAT
WOULD BE FINE UNLESS YOU WANT TO
DO WOULD YOU LIKE A GENERAL
NUMBER OR PRECISE NUMBER IN THE
BUDGET NEXT THIS YEAR. IT'S NOT
CLEAR TO ME. SORRY AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAM WORKS. ABOUT JUST IN
THE- FOR TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR AND FORWARD. WE'RE STILL
ANTICIPATING TED HIT AS AS MY
COLLEAGUE DESCRIBED PURSUANT TO
SUBPOENA HIT THAT TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND BY JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. AND IF
MADE. BY BY THE END OF JUNE OF.
THIS YEAR AT THE DEPARTMENT
CONTRACT TO HAVE APPROXIMATELY
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
AND SEVENTEEN PARTICIPANTS- BY
THE END OF THIS FISCAL YEAR AND
- THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR IS WHEN
THE REAL. BILL UNTIL TO PAY AN
ADDITIONAL SIX HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE I'M A PATIENT PATIENTS PER
MONTH TO BE ADDED. I SEE THE
LEADING UP TO TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND. AND THEN HOW MANY
POSITIONS DO YOU NEED FOR PER
PERSON PER FOR. I WERE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH ADD THAT I'M TEACHER
AND PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION TO
YOU I IT'S NOT THE STOPPING
THAT'S GOING TO BE ADJUSTED. AND
THIS GOES BACK TO KIND OF IN THE
DISCUSSIONS BOB OF WHAT THAT
ACTUAL METHODOLOGY MIGHT CONSIST
OF WHICH IS STILL NOT BEEN
DETERMINED BUT STAFFING WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY BE ONE OF THOSE
ELEMENTS WE'RE TALKING LARGELY
ABOUT THE PHARMACEUTICAL COSTS
AND SOME OTHER SPECIFIC THINGS
THAT ARE DRIVEN BY THE NUMBER OF
PATIENTS THAT YOU'RE SERVING.
BUT I GUESS HOW DID YOU COME UP
WITH THIS HUNDRED AT THIS VERY
SPECIFIC HUNDRED TWENTY SIX
MILLION NUMBER. IN THE THREE
HUNDRED AND TEN POSITION NUMBER. MY LIFE BY ON THE WRONG ITEM.
YEAH I ACTUALLY DIFFERENT OF MY
COLLEAGUES I'M FROM CITY START
TO HELP US ROUTE ME TO A LITTLE
BIT AND THEN WE CAN HOP BACK IN
WHERE NEEDED. AND REMEMBER THIS
IS LEAVE BEHIND. IF I MAY I'D
LIKE TO DEFERRED CUTE DR DUNLOP
AND PRIDES METHODOLOGY TO THAT
PERFECT THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M LOOKING INTO YOUR
HEART SACRAMENTO COMMUNICATE. WE
GO HERE YOU GO AHEAD OKAY GREAT-
SO THERE'S DIFFERENT COMPONENTS
THAT REALLY- WENT INTO-
IDENTIFYING THE APPROXIMATE
THREE HUNDRED STAFF SO- THERE
ARE NURSING POSITIONS THAT WINS
ARE BASED OFF OF THE MEDICATION
MINISTRATIONS THEY WERE PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDER POSITIONS THAT
WENT TO. HOW MANY OF THE
PATIENTS COULD BE SEEN- BY A
SPECIFIC NUMBER PROVIDERS
BECAUSE THERE ARE THE CIVIC
LIMITATIONS TO THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT NAY ANYONE POSITION
CAN SEE WHO ARE ON MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT. HOLDEN ARE
THERE'S QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ABOUT
SPECIFICS YEAH I DO THANK YOU
FOR ASKING. I'M GLAD SOMEONE CAN
ANSWER MY QUESTION YEAH HOW MANY
POSITIONS FROM. POSITIONS PER
PATIENT ARE YOU ESTIMATING
ROUGHLY NEEDING. SO WHAT WHAT
WHAT POSITION TYPE. YOU COULD
WALK THROUGH ALL OF THEM H I
CAN DO WE CAN TO DO TO GO
THROUGH ALL FOR UNDER TEN IF
YOU'D LIKE. I HAVE NOTHING I
MUST READ MY SCHEDULE'S BEEN
CLEAR TO THE. SO I THINK IT
WOULD PROBABLY BE A BETTER USE
OF TIME TO PROVIDE SOMETHING IN
WRITING TO YOU- NO READING ON
RIGHT HERE ON MILLER DO YOU WHAT
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING- DID YOU
COME TO THIS HEARING PREPARED TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS. I'M JUST
ASKING BECAUSE YOU'RE PRETTY
YOU'RE ASKING FOR A HUNDRED
TWENTY SIX MILLION. FOR THREE
HUNDRED TEN POSITIONS I'M ASKING
YOU FOR MORE DETAILED BREAKDOWN
OF THE THREE- TEMPTATIONS WHICH
IS WHAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR. AND
YOU DON'T SEEM TO BE ABLE TO
GIVE US ANY MORE DETAIL. AND NO
ONE ON THIS NO ONE ON THE
ASSEMBLY. BUT IF I COULD FINISH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU'RE A HUNDRED
TWENTY SIX MILLION YOU HAVEN'T
THIRD THERE. THE THING TO BE ANY
JUSTIFICATION OR METHODOLOGY
THAT YOU CAN PERFORMED AS TO HOW
YOU GOT THIS RANDOM POSITIONS. I
THINK WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE YOU THAT METHODOLOGY IN
WRITING. WHAT AND WHY IS THIS
NOT WHERE YOU'RE NOT READY TO DO
IT. IN IN A PUBLIC HEARING. TO
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS WITH THIS
IS WHEN THE TIME IS HERE FOR
WHEN. I IT WOULD BE A VERY LONG
AND EXHAUSTIVE PROCESS BUT IF
YOU GIVE ME A MOMENT I WILL PULL
UP- DOCUMENTS SEVENTY CAN GO
THROUGH. AFTER THAT WOULD BE
GREAT WE COULD WE COULD JUST
START I THINK WE HAVE TO GO
THROUGH ALL OF THEM BUT I THINK
IF YOU COULD WALK THROUGH SOME
OF THEM JUST TO GIVE US A SENSE
OF. WHAT YOU'RE THINKING WHAT
WE'D REALLY APPRECIATE IT. GIVE
ME ONE MOMENT PERFECT.
IT MAY BE
ARE BECAUSE YOU'RE DOING THAT
MAYBE MISS HINES CAN TALK ABOUT
THE- EFFICACY OF THE PROGRAM AND
JUST FRONT OF THAT ANSWERS ARE
GOING TO I THINK IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO HAVE- YOU
KNOW SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT I
THINK IT IS EXTRAORDINARILY
IMPORTANT. IF YOU COULD JUST
WALK THROUGH THE OF ANY METRICS
YOU COULD TALK ABOUT ABOUT THE
EFFICACY OF THE PROGRAM. SURE
ACTUALLY I'M FOR THAT I'LL DEFER
TO YOU AND DOCTOR KEENAN. AT
RENE KANE AND WHAT IS PREPARED
TO TALK ABOUT THAT INTEREST YOU
CAN DEPART ANY SELLING. THE
POSITIONS AND THAT DOCTOR THEM
UP THE CONNECT EACH OF OUR BATCH
OF PETITIONS THERE FOR THAT WERE
IN FACT A TO RATIO. AND EACH OF
THOSE RACES WERE TOUGH- TIED TO
ACTUAL NUMBERS THAT WE ARE SR.
I MEAN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND OR
AND- THOSE THAT ARE PROJECTED TO
BE SERVICE TO THE POSITIONS I
THINK TO GET TO THE ROOT OF YOUR
QUESTION IF WE TIE THIS TO
POPULATION WITH. THE RATHER
POSITIONS ALSO BE. AT TIED TO
POPULATION AGAIN. RIGHT BUT IT'S
PARTNERS HAVE NOT AND COME UP
WITH THAT THOROUGH METHODOLOGY
BUT IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING. THAT
BECAUSE ONLY THOSE RESOURCES
TIED TO RATIOS MAY BE NEEDED FOR
EACH. BATCH OF. POPULATION
WHETHER THAT'S OUR NURSING
POPULATION. ARE AOD COUNSELORS
THAT PROVIDE SERVICES. AND
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS AND OUR
OUR PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS. I
HOPE THAT'S A LITTLE HELPFUL BUT
WE. WILL GET YOU WHATEVER YOU
NEED IN WRITING. DR CANNON. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE I'M A
LITTLE SCARED TO PUT MY VIDEO ON
BUT I CAN TRY- IF IT DOESN'T
WORK WE'LL JUST DO OF THE AUDIO
. SO HOPEFULLY GUYS CAN SEEMING
I'M ON A CANE I'M DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR MEDICAL SERVICES.
AND- JUST A REMINDER AS YOU AS
YOU KNOW THIS PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED AS A AS A HEALTH
CARE PROGRAM- WITH PARTNERS
ACROSS THE ORGANIZATION. I AND
IT WAS A CREATED THAT WAY
BECAUSE WE KNOWLEDGE SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER IS A CHRONIC
DISEASE- WE HAVE A LOT OF
PATIECE IN OUR SYSTEM WHO NEED
TREATMENT UNFORTUNATELY
TREATMENT IS VERY EFFECTIVE. I
IN THE TWO YEARS SINCE WE'VE
IMPLEMENTED THIS PROGRAM- WHICH
IS FAIRLY EARLY ON- WE HAVE SEEN
A SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS IN
OVERDOSE DEATHS AGAIN THAT WAS A
PRIMARY OUTCOME- THAT WE WERE
LOOKING FOR SINCE THIS IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH AND HEALTH CARE.
RELATED ENDEAVOR. AND SO ABOUT
6060% REDUCTION. IN DEATHS
COMPARED TO- BEFORE THIS PROGRAM
WAS IMPLEMENTED- WE ARE
CONTINUING TO SEE. OF THE
REDUCTIONS IN OVERDOSE DEATHS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- ALTHOUGH
THAT'S PRELIMINARY DATA. DESPITE
SOME OF OUR OPERATIONS OPENING
BACK UP WE CONTINUE TO SEE
OVERDOSE DEATHS. SIGNIFICANTLY
DOWN. WE ALSO HAVE SEEN OVERDOSE
. HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE REDUCED I
BELIEVE WE HAD SOME NUMBERS IN
THE B. C. D. AND LISA HINES
OUTLINED THEM BUT- ABOUT 227%
IT'S PROBABLY A LITTLE BIT MORE
NOW ABOUT A THIRD. REDUCTION IN
HOSPITALIZATIONS RELATED TO
OVERDOSE. WE ARE ALSO SEEN- A
LOT OF OTHER- SORT OF EARLY
POSITIVE OUTCOMES ARE RELATED TO
THIS PROGRAM. AND BESIDE THE
REDUCTIONS IN OVERDOSE DEATHS
AND HOSPITALIZATIONS UP IN THE
FIRST TIME IN MY CAREER. I AM
RECEIVING LETTERS OF GRATITUDE
FROM PATIENTS AS OPPOSED TO
LETTERS OF GRIEVANCES ON I THINK
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT OUTCOME WE
ALSO ACTUALLY HAVE LETTERS FROM
OUR CLINICIANS AS WELL WHO FIND
THIS- WORK VERY REWARDING. IT'S
TOO EARLY TO DO SOME OUTCOMES TO
LOOK AT OUTCOMES OF POST RELEASE
BUT BUT THAT IS ALSO ARE PLANNED
TO LOOK AT THOSE OUTCOMES AS
WELL. THANK YOU I THINK THAT'S
GREAT I THINK THAT THE PROGRAM'S
DEPARTMENT SHOULD BE APPLAUDED
FOR THAT SIXTY FOUR PERCENT. THE
CLIENT AS WELL AS THE 27%
DECLINE FOR THE OVERDOSE RELATED
DEATH CAN YOU JUST WALK. WALK ME
THROUGH THE NUMBERS JUST JUST TO
GIVE ME GIVE ME A SENSE OF WHAT.
IT WAS HARD WITH A PERCENTAGE IS
KIND OF ARE WE TALKING. WHAT
WHAT THE NUMBERS ARE AND ALSO
THE HOSPITALIZATION NUMBERS.
SURE SO WHAT I WAS REFERRING TO
IN TERMS OF THE OVERDOSE DEATHS
WE WERE COMPARING- RATES- PRIOR
TO THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PROGRAM SO TWENTY NINETEEN.
COMPARED TO TWENTY TWENTY. AND
SO- I BELIEVE DOCTOR DOWN THE
HAVE- HIS STAFF- COLLECT THEM
YOU DON'T REPORT ON THIS
INFORMATION BUT IT WAS IN THE
MID SIXTIES- THE NUMBER OF
PATIENTS WHO WHO DIED. FROM
OVERDOSE IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND
WE WENT DOWN TO ABOUT- IN THE
LOW TWENTIES GROUP. AND WE'RE
CONTINUING TO SEE THAT PATTERN
AGAIN LISA HINES STRESSED- IN
HER OPENING STATEMENT THAT
OVERDOSE DEATHS FROM OPIOIDS
CONTINUE TO RISE. AT AN
ASTONISHING RATE IN THIS COUNTRY
AND IN CALIFORNIA SO WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IN THE DEPARTMENT OF IS
TRULY SIGNIFICANT PARTICULARLY
IN THAT CONTEXT. IN TERMS OF
POSSIBLE. COULD COULD FILL BOTH
SIDES CONTINUE THAT WHEN I WAS
COMPOSED THANK YOU. NOW IN TERMS
OF HOSPITAL. I CAN GET YOU THE-
YOU KNOW THE EXACT NUMBERS I
BELIEVE WE HAVE THEM IN THE IN
THE B. C. P. BUT AGAIN IT'S
ABOUT I THINK WE SAID A 27%
REDUCTION- AND WE ARE CONTINUING
TO SEE YOU KNOW THOSE DECLINES.
CREEK. COULD COULD WE GO BACK TO
THE THREE OTHER TEMPTATIONS
EVERYBODY TO HAVE A LITTLE- MY
BACKGROUND ON THAT INFORMATION.
SURE I AM READY WONDERFUL. OKAY
SO WE ARE ASKING FOR A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT POSITIONS THAT
SERVE DIFFICULT SO WE HAVE ON
MEDICAL SERVICES THAT ARE SAYING
SERVICES POSITIONS THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS FOR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT FOR PERFORMANCE
EVALUATION PURPOSE OUR
PERFORMANCE MANAGEMENT UNIT- OUR
OUR I. T. SERVICES HR AD THE
OUR DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATIVE
SERVICES PROGRAMS AND
COMMUNICATIONS. ARE THERE
SPECIFIC THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TOUCH UPON. YES I'M INTERESTED
IN WHAT PERCENT OF THE THREE
HUNDRED TEMPERATE JUST GIVEN
WHAT YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT-
ACTUALLY SERVING DIRECT FLIGHTS
. IT'S ALL A LOT OF. I AM NOT
CURIOUS WHY YOU NEED A
COMMUNICATIONS PERSON TO TALK.
ABOUT OKAY SO THOSE THAT ARE
WORKING DIRECTLY WITH PATIENS-
LOOKS LIKE FOR THE FIRST YEAR
WERE ASKING FOR FOURTEEN
ADDITION CERTAIN POSITIONS- THAT
ARE GOING TO BE UP THE
INSTITUTIONS AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
POSITIONS. THAT WILL BE WORKING
- THROUGH- SIR TELL SERVICES
LOCATED ACT MOST LIKELY
HEADQUARTERS FOR IT BETTER
ADDICTION SPECIALISTS. WE HAVE A
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS- BAD
LARRY ONLINE TO THIRTY SIX
POSITIONS SEVEN TENTHS TREATIES
ARE ABOUT WILL BE ONE KERR
INSTITUTE JANET WITH- LOOKS LIKE
A LITTLE BIT OF ADDITIONAL-
JUDICIAL POSITIONS THERE. THAT
CAME UP AND POSTULATING DOCTOR
CAN I SPEAK TO THIS COULD BE
EITHER DEDICATED TO ARE HEAVIER-
SERVER OPERATED ICTP OUR
POPULATIONS OF THE INSTITUTIONS
WERE COULD BE- OF GRATITUDE
HEADQUARTERS FOR TELESERVICES
TELESERVICES. WE'RE LOOKING AT-
SOME PSYCHIATRY SOCIAL WORKER A
SUPERVISORS WERE LOOKING AT-
EIGHTEEN PHARMACIES PHARMACISTS
ONE POSITIONS. ARM AT THIRTY
FARM TECHNICIANS. LABORATORY
ASSISTANCE CERTAIN POSITIONS AB
ONE SINGER CLINICAL LAB
TECHNOLOGIST. FOUR A DIFFICULT
SET THESE THESE POSITIONS ARE
NOT DIRECTLY INVOLVED WITH
PATIENT CARE BUT ARE THEY
PROVIDE SUPPORT WHICH IS- FOR
HEPA POSITIONS AND ONE STAFF
SERVICE MANAGER POSITION. SO
THAT'S JUST THE FIRST YEAR.
FIFTY JUST TO GIVE ME A SENSE
FOR ONE. PATIENT HOW MANY
POSITIONS ARE WE. ALLOCATED OR
I'M SORRY OR PER PER POSITION
HOW MANY. PATIENTS ARE WE
SERVING I GUESS MAYBE THAT'S THE
BETTER ANSWER CUSTOMER QUESTIONS
ZERO FOUR FOR A PHYSICIAN IT IS
LIMITED BY WHAT'S CALLED A TAX
WAIVER AND- I BELIEVE OUR
POSITION POPULATION ARE WE ARE
EXPERTS. OUR ONE HUNDRED
PATIENTS- PRIMARILY THOUGH DR
KEENAN HAS WE MADE EFFORTS TO
EXPAND. THAT TO THE MAXIMUM. ALL
RIGHT NOW- THAT'S JUST OUR
ADDICTION MEDICINE CENTRAL TEAM-
BUT I'M I'M WONDERING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I GUESS THAT'S ANOTHER
WAY TO LOOK AT THIS I THINK YOUR
QUESTION OF WHAT'S THE BREAKDOWN
IN TERMS OF DIRECT PATIENT CARE-
THE VAST MAJORITY OF POSITIONS
WE ARE ASKING FOR OUR CLINICAL
POSITIONS THAT TOUCH THE
PATIENT. AS DR DUNLAP WAS SAYING
SO FOR THE MEDICAL FOLKS WHICH
INCLUDES YOU KNOW PHYSICIANS
SPECIAL WORKERS PHARMACISTS FARM
TAX LABORATORY ASSISTANCE- IT
IT'S ABOUT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT POSITIONS FOR THAT FIRST
YEAR AND THEN NURSES WHO DO SOME
OF THE INITIAL SCREENING AS WELL
AS- I ADMINISTER THE MEDICATION
IT'S A HUNDRED AND TWELVE FOR
THAT. FIRST YEAR AND SO THAT
REALLY IS THE MAJORITY OF
POSITIONS ARE WHAT I CONSIDER
DIRECT CLINICAL PATIENT CARE
POSITIONS. I GUESS I GUESS MAYBE
THE BARE MAJORITY I'M JUST
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
OTHER 50% OF POSITIONS ARE GOING
TOWARD. IT'S MORE ABOUT TWO
THIRDS OF THE POSITIONS A
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT PLUS A
HUNDRED AND TWELVE. FORTY THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT PLUS
12% NINE HUNDRED TWELVE WHAT THE
HUNDRED AND TWELFTH FROM ELEVEN
FORTY I'M SORRY YEAH. THIRD
PARTY. BURKE BUT THEY WERE STILL
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT I MEAN I'M
I'M NOT ACCORDING TO THE
CRITICAL PART OBVIOUSLY- WELL
BUT OF FURNITURE MEDICAL
JUDGMENT ABOUT THAT I TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE OTHER THE
SEVENTY POSITIONS OBVIOUSLY WHAT
WE DO I TOTALLY AGREE THAT
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS NEED
SUPPORT JUST TRYING TO HAVE A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THE- AND
THEN I GUESS ALSO. ARMED WHAT
WE'RE HOPING THE POLICY EVEN AS
WE AS WE KNOW THE POPULATION
WILL GO DOWN YOU'RE STILL
PROJECTING THE INCREASE IN
DEMAND TO UP TO TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND. SO OUR BEST ESTIMATES-
OKAY HE SAID HE WANTED TO. NO SO
OUR OUR OUR PROJECTIONS UP
THROUGH- DECEMBER WERE SPOT ON
IN TERMS OF THE GROWTH RATE AND
THEN ON THE ON THE CRIME- SEARCH
IT THE PRISON SYSTEM AND SO WE
FELT A LITTLE BIT LOWER TARGET
BUT NOW THAT A MICRON SEARCH IS
A PROCEEDING WE BELIEVE THAT
WILL BE BACK ON TRACK TO HIT OUR
TARGET FOR THE END OF THIS
FISCAL YEAR OF THAT SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND SIX
THE ONE IS THAT WHAT IT WAS
RIGHT YOU CAN'T ALL THAT YOU
SPECIFICALLY YEAH. OKAY-
REMEMBER I AM ALSO AN- OUR
POPULATION PROJECTIONS WE KNOW
THE BETWEEN TWO FIVE AND PERCENT
ACROSS COPY ARE TO HAVE AN
OPIATE JUST AND NOT THE ENTIRE
IT WOULD HAVE EITHER SEXY SHE'S
JUST WE ARE SCREENING IT'S OR SO
PRETTY PRETTY QUICKLY SOMETIMES
AND IN FACT PRETTY CLEAR THAT WE
ARE NOT AT THE STANDARD IF YOU
WILL. THAT WE SEE NATIONALLY AND
AS DR KEENAN MENTIONED WITH THE
INK. AND THE PREVIOUS DISORDER
AND THEY INCREASING DEATHS
EVERYWHERE. I DON'T PERSONAL AN-
OCCASIONS OTHER THAN CALIFORNIA
AND- THE OTHER AT POINT THAT YOU
BRING WITH REGARD TO ANY OF THE
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS THERE ARE.
RECTIFICATIONS ADDITION IN THERE
AND I. LIKE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLAIN THAT
DURING REGULAR COMMUNICATIONS
TEAM DEVELOPED AN WHAT'S CALLED
THE IRISH DETIK INSIDER. IMAGE
POPULATION THEY PROVIDE OVER TWO
HUNDRED FIFTEEN THOUSAND. COPIES
OF THAT THAT INCLUDES JOURNALING
SOME SELF HELP INFORMATION THEY
HAVE I THINK THE YEAR SO
FEBRUARY IS HEART HEALTH. IT'S
BEEN. ALL OF US ARE DIRECTOR
DIRECTOR HEINZ YOUR YOUR ONLINE
VIDEO TURNED OFF AND WE CAN'T
HEAR YOU ANYMORE AND IF YOU CAN
HEAR US. YOU'VE GOT CUT OFF
RIGHT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT HEART
HEALTH MONTH. PROVIDES. YOU
BROKE THE SYSTEM. KERN. I THANK
GOD FOR THE OTHER PERSON OTHER
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF YOUR PARTY
FOR ALL CONTINUE TO BE ON HERE
OH DEAR THE OTHER QUESTION I
WOULD HAVE IS HOW THE PROGRAM
WORKS IN CONNECTION TO REDUCING
THE INFLOW OF NARCOTICS INTO THE
PRISON SYSTEM ABOUT OBVIOUSLY
THE NINE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
HEAR ABOUT. IN OUR- SUB HEARING
THAT EVEN DURING COLD WIND.
THERE WERE NO VISITORS- WE STILL
SAW A FIFTY AN UPTICK IN
NARCOTICS ENTERING INTO. OUR
SYSTEMS AND JUST KIND OF TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT IF THERE IS ANY.
SORT OF PARTNERSHIP THERE. I
DON'T KNOW THIS IS THE PROGRAM
THAT DEALS WITH SO THAT PARTIES
I WILL DEFER ON THAT PIECE AND
I'M SURE- I MEAN I WOULD JUST
SAY IN GENERAL THOUGH THE
QUESTIONS THAT MR TANG IS.
ASKING AS TO TWO FOLD ONE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE METHODOLOGY
OF HOW WE GOT TO TWO THREE
HUNDRED AND TEN IT'S A SIZEABLE
NUMBER WITH THE FESTIVAL-
INVESTMENT BUT TO IN THE PAST
WE'VE DONE THESE INVESTMENTS
AND- WE HAVE. FUNDED OVER FOUR
HUNDRED POSITIONS WE HAVE A LOT
OF VACANCIES IN THE FIFTH AND IN
THAT IN THAT SPACE AS WELL WE
HAVE CLOSE TO TWO HUNDRED
VACANCIES THERE. AND SO- I THINK
THERE'S ALSO CONCERNS THAT WE
ARE. ALLOCATING FUNDS WILL MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO FILL IN THE
VACANCIES OR US COAL THAT HAS.
FORCED US TO. A STAR PROGRAM
STOP PROGRAM START IN THE MIDDLE
THIRD JUST CONTINUE HOW MIGHT
THAT AFFECT YOU KNOW- THE
SERVICES DOWN DOWN THE ROAD OR
WHETHER OR NOT WE NEED TO FIND
THAT THIS LEVEL- NOW OR IF OR
IF. THERE'S A SMALLER NUMBER TO
BEGIN WITH AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT THAT SB VISITED AND IN THE
FUTURE BUDGET. AND SO I THINK
THE FOURTH OF THE CONCERNS THAT
ARE YOU ARE IN PART HEARING. HI
I HAVE TO DO HAVE TO DEAL WITH
WITH THAT PIECE. THERE IS A TO
STRONGLY RECOMMEND THAT- NOT
ONLY IN WRITING BUT AS YOU COME
BACK TO US IF YOU HAVE.
ADDITIONAL ANSWERS ABOUT THE
METHODOLOGY. I AM ABOUT THE
ABILITY OF HOW REALISTIC IT IS
TO ACTUALLY FILL UP OF ALL THOSE
POSITIONS BY. TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. THANK YOU MA'AM TRACKING
THAT SUMMARIZES- OUR POINTS
THANKS FOR THE TIP. NO PROBLEM I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THERE'S ENOUGH
MONEY FOR ALL OF MY OTHER EACH A
ISSUES TO. SAY I EXPECT YOUR I
APPRECIATE YOUR PRUDENT HERE- IF
NONE OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS ON THE SITE
AND WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
CLOSE UP ISSUE NUMBER TWO. THANK
YOU TO THE PANELISTS AND MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE. WHICH IS
OUR BACHELOR'S DEGREE PROGRAM.
AND WE HAVE- I THINK I HAVE FOUR
PANEL LISTENING BECAUSE IT'S
JUST GOING ORDER- WITHOUT
WAITING FOR A PROMPT. GOOD
AFTERNOON I AM SHANNON PLAINTIFF
TRANSCENDENT OF THE OPETH THE
CORRECTIONAL EDUCATION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
AND I'M HERE TO SHARE THAT THERE
IS A REHABILITATIVE REVOLUTION
UNDER WAY IN CALIFORNIA
PRESIDENT. IN THE PAST SEVEN
YEARS BECAUSE OF THE SUPPORT OF
THE LEGISLATURE AND SPENT A
PASSAGE OF SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
NINETY ONE WHICH ALLOWED
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY TO TEACH CLASSES INSIDE
CDCR INSTITUTIONS. HIGHER
EDUCATION HAS GROWN ENORMOUSLY.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY LOS ANGELES
BECAME THE FIRST CSU OFFSPRING
TO BE A PATHWAY INSIDE CDCR.
SPENT TEN AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WE PILOTED BACHELOR DEGREE
PATHWAYS AND FOR ADDITIONAL
INSTITUTION. AS PART AT CDC OUR
GOAL TO COMPLETELY ALERT A RATTY
KATE ILLITERACY. WE NOW HAVE
OVER FIFTY THOUSAND INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS WITH CONFIRMED HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA. WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THRIVING IN EVERY
PRISON CURRENTLY FOURTEEN
THOUSAND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS ARE EARNING
TRANSFERABLE EIGHT. THERE IS A
TIDAL WAVE OF DEMANDS FOR A
BACHELOR OF ARTS OPPORTUNITY. IN
FACT SEVEN HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHT DEGREES EARNED IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DURING CO
THAT. DEFAULT ONLY INCREASE AS
WE EMERGE FROM THE- DARK CODE
THAT DEFINES. CORRECTIONAL
EDUCATION IS TRANSFORMATIVE THE
OFFICE OF CORRECTIONAL EDUCATION
SEEKS TO EXPAND THE EMBANKMENT
CALIFORNIA'S MAKING THROUGH ITS
WORLD CLASS HIGHER EDUCATION. TO
INCARCERATED CALIFORNIANS BY
FUNDING BFA. DEGREE PROGRAMS IN
SEVEN CITIES INSTITUTIONS WE ARE
REQUESTING FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND DECREASING TO FOUR
POINT SEVEN MILLION ANNUALLY
BEGINNING IN TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE AND FIFTEEN POSITION TO
MAINTAIN AND EXPAND THE NUMBER
OF PRESIDENT OFFERING BACHELOR'S
DEGREE PROGRAM IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH SEVERAL DIFFERENT
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES. EIGHT SEVEN HOT IN
ADDITION OFFERING A BA DEGREE.
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS WHO HAVE
EARNED A FULLY TRANSFERABLE
ASSOCIATE OF ARTS DEGREE IN ONE
OF OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROGRAM
WOULD BE ABLE TO APPLY TO ONE OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
THAT IS PARTNERING WITH CDC ARE.
COMPLETE THE FINAL TWO YEARS OF
UPPER DIVISION COURSES SO WHAT
YOU MIGHT THINK OF AS THEIR
JUNIOR AND SENIOR YEARS. AS YOU
KNOW CDC HAS EXPONENTIALLY
INCREASED IT HIGH SCHOOL
ACHIEVEMENT AND OUR PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITIES. THE NOTION OF A
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE ON ITS
HEAD. WE HAVE CREATED A PRISON
TO COLLEGE PIPELINE INSTEAD AND
WITH SUPPORT SERVICES LIKE THOSE
OFFERED TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND THE RIGHT COLORS
THAT WORK AND BUYERS YES YOUR
PARTNER YOUR PROJECT REBOUND.
DIDN'T EXPERIENCE A TRUE
EDUCATION CONTINUING WHERE THEY
RECEIVE A WARM HAND OFF TO
COLLEGE AS THEY RELEASED FROM
PRISON. WE NEED STUDENTS WHERE
THEY ARE WHEN THEY ENTER THE
CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM AFFECT THEIR
SKILL ABILITIES. AND DESIRES AND
THEN ASSISTANT TO COMPLETE THEIR
GOAL THE THAT IF YOUR
APPLICATION IN A CORRECT
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAM OR
COLLEGE DEGREE. THE MULTI
GENERATIONAL IMPACT ON THE
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
CANNOT BE OVERSTATED THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SHARE MY
ENTHUSIASM FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
AND PRETEND. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME'S
ORLANDO SANCHEZ WITH THE L. A.
L. WE DO NOT HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE PROPOSAL AT THIS TIME WE
THINK THAT THE PROPOSAL. AT THE
PROPOSED BACHELOR DEGREE
EXPANSION PROGRAM IS PROMISING
GIVEN THAT RESEARCH SUGGESTS
THAT HIGHER EDUCATION HAS
POSITIVE OUTCOMES FOR
INCARCERATED PEOPLE. HOWEVER
DURING OUR ORIGINAL ANALYSIS IT
WASN'T CLEAR TO US AS TO WHY THE
FOR REQUESTED AMOUNT WAS
NECESSARY GIVEN THAT THE BA
PROGRAMS WERE ESTABLISHED AND
OPERATED WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT'S
EXISTING BUDGET. AND SOME OF
THOSE CAN BE FOUND WITHIN THE
AGENDA BUT SINCE THEN THE
DEPARTMENT HAS PROVIDED FURTHER
INFORMATION ON WHY IT CANNOT
CONTINUE TO OPERATE THE-
PROGRAMS WITHIN THEIR EXISTING
BUDGETS. ONE REASON IS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAD ESTABLISHED NO
COST CONTRACTS WITH THE PARTNER
UNIVERSITIES ON A LIMITED TERM
BASIS. AS OPPOSED TO A PERMANENT
BASIS THE SECOND IS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT INDICATED THAT IT HAD
USED TO SAVINGS FROM BACON
ACADEMIC INSTRUCTOR POSITIONS.
OUR THE RESULT OF STAFFING
SHORTAGES AND RECRUITMENT
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PANDEMIC. BERMAN NOTED THAT IT
INTENDS TO FILL THESE TEACHER
POSITIONS AND THEREFORE THE
FUNDS WOULD NOT BE AVAILABLE ON
A PERMANENT BASIS. GIVEN THE
QUESTIONS WE RAISED HAVE BEEN
SUFFICIENTLY ANSWERED. WE DO NOT
RAISE FURTHER CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSAL AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
TO BE HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS. I
THINK YOU A DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO SPECIFIC COMMENT AT
THIS TIME AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DR BRADY
HEINER. I'M A PROFESSOR OF
PHILOSOPHY AND THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
PROJECT REBOUND CONSORTIUM. SO I
ADDRESS YOU TODAY AS THE
REPRESENTATIVE FOR FOURTEEN
PROGRAMS AT CSU CAMPUSES ACROSS
THE STATE. THE MISSION PROJECT
REBOUND IS TO SUPPORT THE HIGHER
EDUCATION AND SUCCESSFUL
REINTEGRATION OF FORMERLY
INCARCERATED STUDENTS. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF WHOM COME FROM
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
BACKGROUNDS. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN THE LEGISLATURE
INVESTED THREE POINT THREE
MILLION ON GOING TO SUPPORT CSU
PROJECT REBOUND PROGRAMS. IT'S
MY PLEASURE TO REPORT ON THE
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC RETURN ON THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT. JERRY GARCIA
LEGISLATIVE STAFFERS PROVIDED
THE COMMITTEE WITH THE FACT
SHEET CONTAINING MANY METRICS OF
OUR PROGRAM SUCCESS. IN THAT
REPORT YOU WILL SEE THAT DURING
TO PANDEMIC YEARS THE PROJECT
CONSORTIUM MANAGED TO EXPAND
FROM NINE CAMPUS PROGRAMS TO
FOURTEEN CAMPUS PROGRAMS. WHAT
IS THE ISSUE AS A WHOLE
EXPERIENCED A DROP IN ENROLLMENT
TO THE LOWEST LEVEL SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN. PROJECT
REBOUND DOUBLE DARN MOMENT AND
WHILE THE EQUITY GAP FOR
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY AND
PELL RECIPIENTS STUDENTS ACROSS
THE CSU HAS WIDENED DURING THE
PANDEMIC. TWO THIRDS OF PROJECT
REBOUND STUDENTS CONTINUE TO
EARN A THREE POINT OH GPA OR
HIGHER EVERY SEMESTER. AND
COMPARED TO CALIFORNIA'S
RECIDIVISM RATE OF 46%
RECIDIVISM RATE AMONG STUDENTS
IN OUR PROGRAMS IS LESS THAN 1%
BUT EVERY CONCEIVABLE METRIC ARE
PROGRAMS WORK AND WHILE I'M
HAPPY TO DISCUSS THESE METRICS
IN MY REMAINING TIME I'D LIKE TO
SHARE AN EXAMPLE THAT CONVEYS
THE SPIRIT THAT MAKES PROJECT
REBOUND SO SUCCESSFUL. LAST WEEK
A PROJECT REBOUND STUDENT AT CAL
STATE FULLERTON DIED IN A TRAGIC
CAR ACCIDENT. MICHAEL PRUDENT
WAS POISED TO GRADUATE IN MAY
WITH A THREE POINT NINE GPA. HE
WAS ON HIS WAY TO A MASTER'S
PROGRAM IN HIGHER EDUCATION
LEADERSHIP AT CSU LONG BEACH.
WHEN THE PROJECT REBOUND
COMMUNITY LEARNED OF MIKE'S
HOSPITALIZATION OVER A DOZEN
STAFF AND STUDENTS FROM OUR FOR
SISTER CAMPUSES IN THE REGION
ARRIVED AT THE HOSPITAL TO OFFER
SUPPORT. PROJECT REBOUND HELD
HEALING CIRCLES IN WHICH MIKE'S
FAMILY AND SOME THIRTY STAFF AND
STUDENTS PARTICIPATED. DURING
THOSE CIRCLES STUDENTS REFERRED
TO MIKE AS A LIFELINE BECAUSE
LIKE MANY OF OUR STUDENT
EMPLOYEES. WROTE LETTERS TO THEM
ON BEHALF OF PROJECT REBOUND
WHILE THEY WERE STILL
INCARCERATED. OFFERING
ENCOURAGEMENT AND THE HOPE OF
HIGHER EDUCATION. BUDGET REBOUND
SENT FIVE THOUSAND SUCH LIFE
LINES INTO CDCR THIS YEAR ALONE
. PROCESSING BRIEF MEN AND WOMEN
WHO ARE SAN WHO WERE ONCE
SENTENCED TO LIFE IN PRISON BUT
WHO ARE NOW PURSUING CSU DEGREES
EXPRESSED LOVE AND SHOWED UP FOR
ONE ANOTHER LIKE FAMILY.
STUDENTS VOICED GRATITUDE FOR
PROJECT RENOWNED NOT ONLY FOR
SUPPORTING THEM WITH ADMISSIONS
AND ACADEMICS BUT FOR SHOWING
BEEN BELOVED COMMUNITY. TEACHING
THEM HOW TO PROCESS GRIEF AND
ANGER YOU LOVE RATHER THAN THE
PATTERNS OF ABUSE ADDICTION AND
ORGANIZED ABANDONMENT THAT THEY
EXPERIENCE IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
OF ORIGIN AND THROUGH CARS FOR
PUBLIC SYSTEMS. THAT'S WHAT
MAKES PROJECT REBOUND SO
SUCCESSFUL. OUR STAFF WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED INCARCERATION
THEMSELVES PROVIDE OUR STUDENTS
WHAT THEY SO DESPERATELY NEED. A
FAMILY THAT ACCEPTS THEM AND
UPLIFTS THEM TO BE THEIR BEST
SELVES. MADAM CHAIR FOR THE
LEDGES SUPPORTER PROJECT REBOUND
. AND FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY. I THANK YOU
TO THE PANELISTS ON THIS INSULT
IT'S EXCITING TO SEE- THE
SUCCESSES CONNECTED TO THIS
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS- BOTH IN
AND OUT OUT THERE AND SO I GUESS
MY QUESTION IS ARE AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON THOSE
SUCCESSES SO ON A NIGHT THAT. AS
WELL. HOW DO WE SCALE THIS UP
RIGHT NOW AND SEVEN- PRESENTS A
NOT ALL OVER CAL STATE ARE
PARTICIPATING PROJECT REBOUND-
AND- THE FUNDING BECAUSE RIGHT
THE PROGRAM BUT HOW DID IT HOW
DO WE SCALE THIS UP SO THAT IT'S
AVAILABLE. IN ALL OF OUR
PRESENCE IS THAT ALL OVER
CALIPHATE'S PARTICIPATE IN A
PROGRAM OVERSEEN STRONG
CORRELATION FOR SUCCESS. OF THE
FAR AS THE INDIVIDUALS. ON WE
HAVE THOUGHT LIKE THAT. YEAH I
HAVE BOUGHT ON THAT- AND I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THE PROGRAM THAT WE'VE
GOTTEN GOING SO FAR- IT IS OUR
INTENTION TO SERVE. INCARCERATED
FOLKS SAID EVERY SIX THIRTY
LOCAL AS WELL AS EVERY
GEOGRAPHIC AREA BUT IN THE LONG
RUN MY HOPE IS THAT WE'LL BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE. A HUB IN THE
NOT FAR NORTHERN REGION OF THE
STATE. AT LEAST ONE IN THE
CENTRAL REGION AND THEN ONE IN
THE SOUTH AND THEN ALSO FOR ALL
THE DIFFERENT SECURITY LEVELS.
NOW NOT ALL OF THE YEAH BURKE
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PRISONS ARE
WITHIN A LEGITIMATE REASONABLE
DRIVING DISTANCE FROM. A. B. F.
U. AND SO WHAT WE'VE DONE IS
REALLY. FOCUSED ON THOSE
INSTITUTIONS. WHERE WE HAVE THE
BEST. WHERE RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHERE THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS DOING A
FANTASTIC JOB OF COLLABORATING
WITH MY STAFF ON THE INSIDE TO
GET STUDENTS THROUGH THEIR-
THEIR- POST SECONDARY
PROGRAMMING. AND THEN- REALLY
FOCUSING AND ALSO ON THOSE-
INSTITUTION AND THE ISSUES THAT
HAVE A STRONG- PROJECT REBOUND
PROGRAM SO IN THE SHORT TERM AS
THE FEDERAL HELLO. BECOMES THE
REALITY NEXT YEAR RATED BIGELOW
AND SOME OF THE CURRENT
CHALLENGES THAT OUR FOLKS. HAVE
TO DEAL WITH WITH HELLO AS THOSE
RESTRICTIONS ARE LIFTED AND
THINGS GET A LITTLE BIT EASIER
WE DO ANTICIPATE INCREASED
NUMBER. SO WHAT MY HOPE IS THAT
WE GO AHEAD AND FIND THESE SEVEN
AND THEN COME BACK YOU IN A YEAR
AND THEY LOOK LOOK HOW GREAT
THAT SAYS WE HAVE MANY MORE
STUDENTS- HOW CAN WE EXPAND. THE
END OF THE SO THERE'S THE THANK
YOU MISS AND MISS WHEN INCOME.
ON THE SUCCESS WITH THE FAR- IS
THERE A PLAN ALREADY THAT'S BEEN
DEVELOPED OR THE PLAN BEING
DEVELOPED SO THAT WE GO PAST THE
SEVEN AND PASSED MIXTURE. SO
THAT THE SISTER OF A PATHWAY
FORWARD FOR US ALREADY THAT'S
BEEN PLANNED. YEAH SO WHAT WE'VE
DONE- IS WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE- FOUNDATION.
COULD TAKE A DEEP DIVE INTO OUR
COLLEGE DATA TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE COLLEGE. BACHELOR'S DEGREE
PROGRAMS THAT WERE IMPLEMENTING
MADE THE GREATEST MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY. SO FOCUSING ON
FOR EXAMPLE LEVEL TO- POPULATION
SO THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE STUDENTS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PURSUE THEIR BA.
NOW EQUITY IS A HUGE ISSUE FOR
ME AND HELLO- I WAS NOT WILLING
TO MOVE FORWARD UNTIL WE GET OUT
THE SERVER WOMEN. SO WE HAVE A
NASCENT PATHWAY AT CALIFORNIA
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S
FACILITY- WE'RE TALKING WITH
COCKTAIL A ABOUT- THE FUTURE
PROGRAM AT THE I. W. THE HEAD
MEETING LAST WEEK ON FRIDAY WITH
A CAL POLY HUMBLE. AND SAN DIEGO
STATE WERE INTERESTED IN SERVING
THE IMPERIAL VALLEY. SO THAT THE
GOAL WOULD BE TO GET THE PROGRAM
UP AND FULLY FUNCTIONAL. ONCE WE
SEE WHAT THE DEMAND IS. ONE HELL
IS OUT REPENTED AND ALL THE
FEDERAL REGULATIONS ARE
COMPLETED BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
YET DONE- THEN WE'D BE. HOW MANY
STUDENTS WE HAVE PREPARED AND
MOVE FORWARD AT THAT TIME WITH
THOSE. PRESENT THAT ARE WITHIN
AN APPROPRIATE DEFINITION OF A-
YEAR. THAT IS INTERESTED IN
PARTNERING WITH US. WHEN WENDY.
IF IN YOUR IDEAL. WORLD MATHIS
QUESTIONS AS I'M EAGER TO SEE
THIS EVERYWHERE SO- IN YOUR EYE
AND I WORRY ABOUT EQUITY SO IN
YOUR IDEAL WORLD WHEN DO YOU.
WHAT'S THE TIME LINE AS YOU AS-
AS YOU'RE WORKING AND EXPANDING
WHAT THE TIME LINE IN YOUR HEAD
OF YOUR IDEAL WILL BEFORE WE
COULD SEE THIS AND- MOST OF OUR-
PRESENCE. ALL RIGHT NOW IN A
DEFENSIVE THE CSU PROGRAMS THAT
WERE- WORKING TO FIRM UP AND
EXPANDS WE ALSO HAVE ONE PRIVATE
OF BACHELORS DEGREE PROGRAM AND-
ARRANGEMENT WITH THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA IRVINE THE THIRD
STUDENTS THAT ARE J. DONOVAN SO-
AND THEY HAVE DIFFERENT FUNDING
SOURCES- THROUGH THEIR OWN INTER
CAMPUS RESOURCES SO IN ADDITION
TO THE SEVEN THAT WERE ASKING
FOR THE FUNDING FOR WE HAVE A
FEW MORE- ABOUT THREE ACTUALLY
BECAUSE YEAH W. R. J. D. AND-
THE- R. SOME. BATCHES DEGREE
OPPORTUNITY. SO MY ANTICIPATION
WOULD BE ONCE WE SEE THE IMPACT
THAT HELD NEXT YEAR- BY THE TIME
WE GET TO THE TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE SCHOOL YEAR WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE SO MANY STUDENTS READY FOR
COLLEGE AND BEYOND THAT WE'RE
GOING TO COME BACK TO YOU AND
SAY LOOK THIS IS REALLY WORKING.
WE NEED THE FUNDING TO HAD JUST
EXPAND. AND OF COURSE WE HAVE
THE SAME KINDS OF ISSUES THAT
YOU CARE ABOUT ALL THE TIME FROM
CDC. MAY HAVE TO THE COVERAGE OF
THE KINDS OF THINGS AND WHAT
WE'VE DONE IS COLLABORATED- SO
THAT THAT THE ADULT BASIC
EDUCATION PROGRAM THAT. OCCURRED
DURING THE DAY ARE SECOND WATCH-
AND RCTV PROGRAM. RYAN DURING
THE DAY AND THEN THE COLLEGE
PROGRAMMING BEGAN. APPROXIMATELY
TWO OR THREE O'CLOCK IN THE
AFTERNOON WHEN ALL OF A SUDDEN
THE CLASS AND STATE- BASES ARE
AVAILABLE. WE'RE SHARING AND
WE'RE DEVELOPING SIMULTANEOUSLY
MULTI USE. BATHROOMS THAT CAN BE
USED BY ANY GROUP WISHING TO
COME IN SO WHERE YOU THIN
LEVERAGING TECHNOLOGY TO DO THAT
SO THAT THE FACE CAN BE SHARED
BUT THERE'S- THERE'S A LOT GOING
ON. THAT WILL ULTIMATELY BE I
BELIEVE CONTRIBUTE TO THE
SUCCESS OF OUR LONG TERM GOALS
FOR HIGHER. EDUCATION WE ARE.
THANK YOU THE WAY HAVE ANY.
MISTER CHANG I'M SURE IF I MAY.
THE BRADY FROM PROJECT REBOUND.
I'M IF I THE STATE BLUE O
INVEST IN HIGH EDUCATION FOR
CURRENTLY AND FORMERLY
INCARCERATED CALIFORNIANS I
REALLY IMPLORE YOU TO THINK AND
INVEST IN- IN THE CREATION OF A
STUDENT CENTERED ECOSYSTEM
REALLY THAT THAT NOT JUST
INVOLVE CDCR BUT ALL THREE
PUBLIC POST SECONDARY
EDUCATIONAL SEGMENTS BECAUSE- IN
ORDER TO SUCCEED THE STUDENTS
MUST NAVIGATE THROUGH ALL OF
THESE COMPLEX SYSTEMS AND THAT
REQUIRES THE SUPPORT OF
COORDINATED PROCESS THESE.
COORDINATED AND DEDICATED
PRACTITIONERS- AND NOT JUST A
KIND OF PIECEMEAL AMALGAM OF
STATE INSTITUTIONS THAT DESPITE
THEIR BEST INTENTIONS OFTEN WORK
SIMPLY TO REPRODUCE THEIR THEIR
OWN BUREAUCRACIES- SO FOR
INSTANCE FROM PROJECT REBOUNDS
PERSPECTIVE WE'VE MAPPED THE
STATE AND CREATED OUTREACH TEAMS
ASSIGNED TO PARTICULAR CDCR
FACILITIES. SENATE BILL FOUR
SIXTEEN- JUST LAST YEAR PLACE TO
STATUTORY PRIORITY ON COLLEGE
PROGRAMS WITHIN CDCR- TO WORK
WITH- THE CSU PROJECT REBOUND
CONSORTIUM THE RISING SCHOLARS
NETWORK IN OUR- IN OUR SISTER
SYSTEM- AND YET OUR OUTREACH
TEAMS HAVE VERY INCONSISTENT
ACCESS. TO PROVIDE THAT THAT
IMPORTANT PRE MATRICULATION
ADVISING AND WARM HANDOFF THAT
SHIPMENTS WEIGHING MENTIONS I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
FROM TO FOREGROUND THAT THE
SUCCESS OF PROJECT REBOUND IS
ESSENTIALLY CONTINGENT UPON THE
FACT THAT THE MAJORITY OF OUR
STAFF HAVING INCARCERATION
EXPERIENCE THEMSELVES THAT'S
PART OF WHAT CREATES THE
CREDIBLE MESSENGERS- THAT THAT
LEAD TO OUR RECRUITMENT AND OUR
PERSISTENCE SUCCESS IN HIGHER
RENT. AND SO YOU MIGHT EXPECT
THAT OUR STAFF HAVE EXPERIENCE
INCONSISTENT- APPROVAL WHEN IT
COMES TO ACCESS IT'S A- TO
PROVIDE THAT THAT'D- SO HAVING
SOMETHING FOR INSTANCE LIKE
GREEN CARDS FOR PROJECT REBOUND
APPROVED OUTREACH TEAMS- I THINK
WOULD GO A LONG WAY TOWARD
CREATING SOME OF THOSE THOSE
PATHWAYS THOSE THOSE PRISON TO
COLLEGE. PIPELINES THE MISS
NGUYEN MENTIONS. I 100% AGREE
WITH YOU BRADY I COULDN'T AGREE
MORE AND I'LL- TELL YOU THAT
IT'S BEEN A FRUSTRATING FOR ALL
OF US. FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS-
WHEN AS YOU KNOW OUR
INSTITUTIONS HAVE BEEN SHUT DOWN
THE MODIFIED PROGRAMMING SO
NOBODY FROM THE OUTSIDE BEEN
ABLE TO COME IN. AND IT IT- YOU
KNOW WHEN I THINK ABOUT THAT BUT
FIND THAT WE'VE MET. REBOUND
FOLK OR RIDING DOLLARS
REPRESENTATIVES IN PARKING LOT
TO EXCHANGE STUDENT WORKS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S WORK
STILL DIFFERENT BY THE
INSTITUTION I MEAN THAT. THE
DESIRE IS THERE IT IT NOW THAT
THINGS ARE OPENING UP AGAIN I
REALLY ANTICIPATE BEING- EVEN
MORE. OF THAT THAT WARM HAND OFF. THAT THAT IS THE IDEAL. THANK
YOU DIRECTORS FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
R. HATER. YOU YOU BOTH I THINK
PEOPLE SHOULD BE COMMENDED FOR.
THE GREAT JOB YOU'RE BOTH DOING.
ON THIS PROGRAM ARE QUITE OFTEN
IN THIS. SUBCOMMITTEE WE HEAR A
LITANY OF EXCUSES OF WHY THINGS
CAN'T BE DONE. AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU IGNORING ALL OF
THOSE REASONS WHY WE CAN'T DO
THINGS AND JUST REALLY. DOING
DOING YOUR JOB AND SO JUST JUST
SO I UNDERSTAND THE METRICS AND
LET ME ALSO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
METRICS BECAUSE- I DON'T HAVE TO
ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT ALL THE
VARIOUS METRICS BECAUSE YOU 5%
OF THE FOREST. ON SO FROM TWENTY
NINETEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE I
JUST WANT TO UNDERSTAND JUST
WANNA JUST BE REITERATED BE-CLEAR. HE WENT FROM THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY CENTS A ROLE
TO FIVE SIXTY SIX. AND THEN
GRADUATING. YOU WENT FROM SIXTY
ONE TO ONE FIFTY ONE- SAME TIME
FRAME IT ALSO. YOU ROLLED
GRADUATE STUDENTS FROM TWENTY
NINE TO NINETY FIVE IN MY IN MY
READING THAT CORRECTLY. I JUST
REMEMBER. LOWS THIS IS BRADY
HEINER FROM PROJECT REBOUND- THE
METRICS THAT YOU'RE CITING OUR
METRICS FROM THE CSU PROJECT
REBOUND CONSORTIUM SO THOSE ARE
OUR STUDENTS WHO ARE- EARNING
DEGREES ON CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES OUTSIDE OF CCR BUT YES
ALL THOSE METRICS ARE ARE
CORRECT. GOD I GOT AND I GOT A
GUEST DIRECT SUPERINTENDENTS
WHITE HOUSE HAS OTHER NUMBERS
SEPARATE FROM. PROJECT REBOUND I
SAID. YES THE NUMBERS THAT THAT
I HAVE AT THIS POINT I JUST THIS
PAST YEAR- SO IN ALL OF. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WE GRADUATED OUR
FIRST. COHORT OF STUDENTS FROM
CAL STATE LA I'M INSIDE THE
LEVEL FOR HIGH SECURITY
INSTITUTION- TWENTY FIVE MEN
AREN'T THERE. ARE COLLEGE
DEGREES THAT BACHELOR'S DEGREES
IT WAS. AN UNBELIEVABLE
UNBELIEVABLE EXPERIENCE AND THEN
WHAT I THINK IS INTERESTING AND
WORTHWHILE TO NOTE IS THE FACT
THAT- EIGHT OF THE- UNIT THAT
STARTED BACK COPART. IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN WITH HEALTHCARE LA- I'M
ESPECIALLY GOT THEIR SENTENCES
REDUCED STORE COMMUTED THE
IMPORTANT LIFE FIRST. AND THEY
GOT OUT AND THEY WENT ON TO
CAMPUS AT CAL STATE LA BECAUSE
OF THE SUPPORT THEY HAD TO
PROJECT REBOUND IT WOULD SEEM
WHAT. THEY WERE ABLE TO HAVE
HOUSING THEY HAVE THEIR FOOD
NEEDS MET THEY HAD ALL THOSE MAD
LOS YOU KNOW HIERARCHY OF NEEDS
MET. AND THEN THEY WERE ABLE TO
WALK ACROSS THE BOARD- THEY EARN
THEIR THEIR BACHELOR OF ARTS
DEGREE IN WITH THE REST OF THE
CAMPUS- YOU DON'T POPULATION.
LAST JULY SO. IT IT IT- TIRED.
CORRECTIONAL EDUCATION ACCOUNT.
AND THE MULTI. IMPACT OF CAN'T
BE. AND RIGHT NOW. WE HAVE.
FOURTEEN THOUSAND STUDENTS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
EARNING THEIR TRANSFERABLE
ASSOCIATE OF ARTS DEGREE WE JUST
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE. A PLACE TO GO NEXT RIGHT
SO THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
LEARN. THANK YOU CAN CAN YOU Q-
PROGRESS TOWARDS THEIR TOWARDS
THEIR GOAL TO DON'T TOTALLY
AGREE AND WE WANT TO SUPPORT YOU
AS MUCH AS- WE CAN AND I KNOW
THAT WHEN I HAD A CHANCE TO
VISIT SOUTH AFRICA'S IT WAS
UNFORTUNATE- THE IN A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROFESSOR THAT I BELIEVE
USED TO GO THERE. HADN'T BEEN
THERE AND WHAT WITHIN THE WAY
THE INMATES TALKED ABOUT I
THOUGHT THEY HADN'T BEEN THERE
ARE MAYBE A FEW MONTHS BECAUSE
THE PERCENT RETIRED. IN TWO
YEARS SINCE ALL OBVIOUSLY WE
WANNA- INSURE THAT THOSE
RESOURCES ARE BEING. CONNECTED
AT A TIME WHEN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ENROLLMENT IS DOWN.
THERE'S NO REASON. FOR THEM NOT
TO GO TO THEIR NEAREST FACILITY
TO WORK WORK. ON INCARCERATED
INMATES WHO WANNA ONE OF LOWER
MANHATTAN I CAN'T IMAGINE A
BETTER REACHED BETTER USE OF
RESOURCES FOR THE STATE. AND
CLEARLY- YOU HAVE THE DATA TO
BACK UP YOUR RESULTS. I THINK.
YOU KNOW SPECIFICALLY IS JUST A
MUCH BETTER USE FOR PEOPLE'S
TIME. TO BE PART OF THAT SYSTEM
ON. THE IN THE VISITING THIS.
PROPOSAL THE FIVE MILLION THAT'S
PROPOSED FOR GENERAL FUND TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE- IS ANY OF THAT
GOING TO PROJECT REBOUNDER THIS
IS JUST. I BELIEVE FOR YOU FROM
YOUR OFFICE TO PRETEND TO SWIM
I'M SORRY. THAT'S FOR MY OFFICE
AS WELL AS FOR TUITION AND OTHER
SUPPORT FOR THE STUDENTS. SO WE
NEED TO PROVIDE FUNDING TO THE
CSU IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE PROGRAMS IN THE
UNIT. AND ONCE WE GET HEALTH I
THINK THAT'S WHY WE HAVE HAD A
LOWER COST FOR THE SUBSEQUENT
YEARS BECAUSE NEXT YEAR. ON JULY
FIRST- HELD WILL BE TURNED. ALL
OF OUR GREAT BUT WILL BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THE HEALTH PLAN WITHOUT
SOME OF THE REALLY DIFFICULT
BARRIERS. THAT RETAINING IN
THEIR WAY LIKE. EVENTS AND
ETCETERA GOT IT IN FOR THE CSU
STUDENTS HOW MANY SINCE YOU
STUDENTS IS THAT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FUNDING FOR THAT ALSO
INCLUDE ALL OF THE EIGHT DEGREES
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT AS WELL.
BEAT THE EIGHT DEGREES ARE- YOU
KNOW THAT 99% OF OUR STUDENTS
GETTING THEIR ASSOCIATE OFARTS
DEGREES ARE ON A CALL A
CALIFORNIA PROMISED FRANCE SO
THEY'RE FINDING IT HARDER- WHAT
DEATH FUNDING WILL DO IF THE
COURT. THE- FIFTY STUDENT AT
MILL CREEK FIFTY AT BOTH-
THERE'S- A HUNDRED IT WILL BE UP
TO ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED STUDENTS
IN BACHELOR OF ARTS DEGREE THREE
CSU IF THE FUNDING FOR THE- I
GOT AND THEN. THIS IS SEPARATE
FROM PROJECT REBOUND IS THAT
CORRECT PROFESSOR TOTALLY
SEPARATE YEAH TOTALLY SEPARATE.
YEAH FOR A BIT BUT ARE THE BUT
THINK OF CLEARER ON. YEAH WE
JUST HEARD PROPOSAL EARLIER THAT
WE HAD A VERY DIFFICULT TIME
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE MONEY WAS
GOING THE FIFTEENTH. OF MUCH
CLEARER IN TERMS OF AN
INDUCTIVELY MUCH CLEARER IN
TERMS OF THE RESULTS. YOU KNOW
THE WE KNOW WHAT THAT THE
REHABILITATION. PART OF THE
DEPARTMENT IS THE NAME IS RATHER
NEW- WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING THIS
SEEMS LIKE A VERY SMALL AMOUNT
OF MONEY FRANKLY CONSIDERING THE
PAST PRESENT OR HAND. SO WE
DEFINITELY WANT TO BE.
SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR EFFORTS AS
WELL AS OUR PROFESSOR HUNTERS
EFFORTS. SO ON. PLEASE LET US
KNOW WHAT WE CAN. CONTINUE TO DO
STREETS OF PORT YOUR EFFORTS
BECAUSE WITH THE OBVIOUSLY I
I'VE I PERSONALLY THE MORE
STUDENTS. YOU HAVE- TO LET LESS
LIKELY TO DOUBLE THE LESS
RECIDIVISM WE'RE GOING TO HAVE.
I THINK THE BETTER THE BETTER
OUR STATE IS GOING TO BE SO
PLEASE FROM- WE'LL LET LET LET
US KNOW HOW WE CAN SUPPORT YOU
LIKE I SAID THIS NUMBER SEEMS
FAIRLY. MODEST CONSIDERING THE
TASK THAT YOU'RE TACKLING. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT. IT IS A MEMBER THANK
YOU ALL THINK YOU WERE GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT THEY WERE GONNA
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR-
FOR ISSUE NUMBER FOUR WE HAVE
VARIOUS BUDGET PROPOSALS. UNTIL
WE'VE DIVIDED UP INTO THREE
STUFF PANELS. I WILL STATUS
AFTER EACH THE PANEL WITH UP TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS.
FROM THE MEMBERS BEFORE WE
PROCEED. AND WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND START WITH THE PANEL
NUMBER ONE WHICH IS RE PURPOSING
CONDEMNED HOUSING. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY I'M RON
DAVIS SOCI DIRECTOR DIVISION OF
ADULT INSTITUTIONS. CDCR
REQUESTS ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A CONSULTING
CONTRACT TO EVALUATE AND MAKE
RESIDENT RECOMMENDATIONS
REGARDING. THE RE PURPOSING OF
CONTENT HOUSING AND SUPPORT
SPACES AT SAN QUENTIN. THIS
CONTRACT WILL HELP DEVELOP IDEAS
HOW THIS EXISTING SPACE CAN BE
USED TO CREATE A POSITIVE
HEALING ENVIRONMENT. THAT
PROVIDES INCREASED
REHABILITATIVE EDUCATION AND
HEALTHCARE OPPORTUNITIES THANK.
THIS PROPOSAL PROVIDES FUNDING
TO EVALUATE EXISTING SPACE AND
PROVIDE INNOVATIVE IDEAS FOR
FUTURE USE I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ON THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
KNOWN YOU THE L. ALES OFFICE
CAITLIN O'NEILL YEAH. THANK YOU
CAITLIN O'NEILL WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
THE ARCHITECTURE AT SAN QUENTIN
BANKS LOOTING BE HOUSING
FACILITY AND THAT IS THE SUBJECT
OF THIS PROPOSAL HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY PROBLEMATIC DURING
THE EAST COAST AND I TÍNH
PANDEMIC. THAT'S BECAUSE THE
FACILITY CONSISTS ESSENTIALLY OF
FIVE TIERS OF CELLS STACKED ON
TOP OF EACH OTHER WITH OPEN BAR
DOORS THAT ALLOW AIR TO FLOW IN
AND OUT OF THE CELLS- AND SO
THAT MEANS THAT- INFECTED AIR
CAN PASS BUT- BETWEEN CELLS THAT
ARE BETWEEN NEIGHBORING CELLS OR
INFECTED DROPLETS CAN FALL FROM
THE TOP TIER TO THE BOTTOM
ENTERING STYLE THE ONE WAY. THE
FACILITY ALSO AS WE UNDERSTAND
DOESN'T HAVE- VERY GOOD INTAKE
OF OUTSIDE AIR AND EXCHANGE OF
AIR BECAUSE MANY OF THE WINDOWS
ARE WILD WELL THE CHILD AND-
ESSENTIALLY THAT FACILITIES-
HOUSING MANY OF HOUSING
FACILITIES AT SAN QUENTIN
ESSENTIALLY HAVE. INDUSTRIAL
FANS THAT SORT OF RECIRCULATING. EXISTING AREAS WITHIN THE
FACILITY- AND WHILE CDC ARE
FULLY DEFINED THE SCOPE OF WHAT
IT'S PLANNING TO ASK A
CONSULTANT TO THE PROPOSED
CONSULTANT TO- ASSESS AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON. THE
DEPARTMENT INDICATES THAT IT
DOESN'T PLAN TO REQUIRE THAT IT
CONSULTANT TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ADDRESS THESE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS. AND SO
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THIS WOULD
EITHER LEAVE IMPORTANT ISSUES
UNADDRESSED- OR TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE DEPARTMENT LATER CHOSE
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES SUCH AS
BY. MODIFYING FACILITIES TEN-
IMPROVE. BE TRANSFERRED ERROR
AND- AN INTAKE OF AIR OUTSIDE
AIR. AND IT COULD REQUIRE
POTENTIALLY I'M DOING ARE
DESTROYING- THE MODIFICATIONS
THAT ARE RECOMMENDED BY HIS EAP
CONSULTANT. THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED. I AND SO WE WOULD THAT
THE LEGISLATURE DIRECTED
DEPARTMENT TO REPORT AT SPRING
BUDGET HEARINGS ON THE DEFINED
SCOPE OF THE PROPOSED
CONSULTANTS WORK. SECOND THE
RATIONALE FOR NOT HAVING THE
CONSOLE WE CONSIDER THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERNS THAT I JUST
CRIED. AND THIRD THE COST OF
REQUIRING THE CONSULTANT TO
CONSIDER THOSE CONCERNS AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
ADDRESS THEM. THANK YOU. LET ME
SOLANO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AS
FAR AS ADDRESSING THE SCOPE AND
POTENTIAL ADDITIONAL COSTS THERE
IS THE POSSIBILITY THAT THE
FINAL AMOUNT COULD BE SLIGHTLY
HIGHER LOWER DEPENDING ON THE
FINALIZED GO- AS THE PROJECT IS-
AS THE DETAILS ARE DETERMINED BY
THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
CONTRACTOR HOWEVER THE
ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES IT'S A
REASONABLEFIGURE FOR THE WORK
AND THE ADMINISTRATION HASN'T
AND WE DON'T PLAN TO PRECLUDE
THE CONSULTANT FROM CONSIDERING
PER. PERTINENT PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WHEN MAKING A
RECOMMENDATION AND WE REITERATE
THATTHE PURPOSE OF THE
ASSESSMENT AND ULTIMATE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO GENERATE
IDEAS ON THE BEST USE OF THE
SPACE TO CREATE ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF THE INCARCERATED POPULATION.
THANK YOU. FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- SO I AREAS THAT YOU'RE
YOU DON'T PRECLUDE THE
CONSULTANT FROM CONSIDERING BUT
ARE WE ASKING THE CONSULTANT
BEING SPECIFIC THAT WE WOULD
LIKE THEM TO CONSIDER HEALTH
IMPROVED AND- IMPLICATIONS I
THINK AS WE ARE ENTERING OUR
THIRTY YEAR OF THE PANDEMIC. I
SEEMS SOMETHING REASONABLE TO
ADD TO THE SCOPE. THIRTY SENATOR
PER MINUTE. BINANCE AT AT AT
THIS TIME WE HAVEN'T
SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFIED WHAT THE
PLAN IS IN THOSE DETAILS WILL BE
SORTED OUT BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE CONSULTANT
ASKING THE FORWARD. AND SO COME
SPRING WILL YOU BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SOME OF THAT INFORMATION
FOR US. WHEN HE SHREDDED PERFECT
FINANCE I BELIEVE THAT WON'T
HAPPEN UNTIL THE DEPARTMENT
ENGAGES WITH THE CONSULTANT-
WHICH WOULDN'T BEGIN IN THE
SPRING. BUT YOU'RE ASKING US FOR
THE MONEY AHEAD OF TIME EVEN
THOUGH WE STILL DON'T KNOW WHAT
WE'RE- WHAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
PAYING FOR. THIS IS A VERY
PRUDENT THAT WERE. ANY MONEY
TOWARD SOMETHING THAT WE'RE NOT
SURE WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR IT.
AT THIS POINT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
IDENTIFIED THE SPECIFIC
CRITERIA- AND- WE'VE LEFT IT
PRETTY WIDE OPEN ADD TO CHART TO
DETERMINE WHAT. WHAT'S WITH ALL
THE NEEDS THAT THEY MAY
POPULATION THE PAST. I THINK FOR
MYSELF WITH MEMBER THE
LEGISLATURE AND CHECKS AND
BALANCES AND HAVING TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO. THE VOTERS I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
BEING PRUDENT UNTIL THOSE
DETAILS. ARE GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT TO US EVER GOING TO BE
MOVING FORWARD WITH WITH THESE
PROPOSALS WHETHER IT'S A MODEST
AMOUNT OR A LARGE AMOUNT I
GENERAL I THINK YOU'VE HEARD US
REPEAT OVER AND OVER AGAIN THAT
WE WANT TO DETAILS. TO HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN AND WHAT WE'RE
INVESTING IN. WITH THE PHONE.
LINE THAT YOU DROPPED YOUR-
SERVICES RECEIVED I THINK. I'M
SORRY WE'RE HAVING A HARD TIME
HEARING HERE WHERE THAT IS
SPEAKING. MODELLEN THE CLAIM
THAT BE DIRECTOR FISCAL SERVICES
FOR CDC ARE YES. IN GONNA.
APOLOGIES THANK YOU- IS SO THE
FUNDING THAT WE'RE REQUESTING IS
TO START THAT WORK WITH THE
CONSULTANTS SO WE UNDERSTAND
THAT DETAILS RIGHT NOW OUR-
THOUGHT. PRECISE DETAILS ARE NOT
AVAILABLE RIGHT THIS MOMENT BUT
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THE
FUNDING IS TO ENGAGE WITH A
CONSULTANT IS TO WORK OUT. OF
WORK AND IT TELLS US THAT THEY
CAN COMPLETE THEIR EVALUATION
ASSESSMENT AND PROVIDE A REPORT
BACK THAT WE WOULD THEN COME FOR
LEGISLATORS. TO REQUEST
ADDITIONAL MONEY TO IMPLEMENT
SOME OF THOSE ITEMS- ORDER. OR
BEFORE IN A DIFFERENT WAY SO
THIS IS JUST THE INITIAL FOR
RIGHT OR A INTO DETERMINING THE
BEST A USE THAT THE SPACE. SO WE
WANT. AT ANY POINT TIME WE
WOULDN'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION
UNTIL WE ACTUALLY ENGAGE WITH
THE CONTRACTOR TO DO THAT WE
WOULD NEED FUNDING TO START AT.
THAT EXECUTE THE CONTRACT. I
THINK WHEN WE ENTER NEGOTIATIONS
FOR A CONTRACTOR STATUS ANYBODY
THAT NEEDS TO BE THERE AT THE
VERY BEGINNING. TO DO THAT AND I
THINK THAT WOULD JUST. BE
PRUDENT IF YOU TAKE OUR ADVICE.
THAT YOU HAVE SOME OF THE SCHOOL
FIGURE IT OUT. I THINK YOU'RE
ASKING A CONTRACTED TO GIVE YOU
AN ESTIMATE OR ENTER INTO
SOMETHING THAT'S SOMETHING
PRETTY BASIC THAT THEY'RE ALSO.
GOING TO WANT. TO HAVE FROM FROM
YOU SO THAT THEY CAN GIVE YOU
YOU KNOW AT A FAIR FLOW. OUT
THERE INTO JUST. ADDING BASIC
CONTRACT IN ONE ON ONE SO I
THINK IF YOU WANT. TO BE YOUR
PARTNERS AND WE WANT TO BE
PARTNERS INFORMATION IS.
IMPORTANT WE KEEP GETTING. AREAS
PROPOSALS WITH LITTLE
INFORMATION JUST ASKING US TO
TRUST YOU AND IT'LL COME
TOGETHER LATER BUT THAT THEN.
IT'S ASKING US NOT TO DO OUR JOB. WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT- SUB PANEL. WITH
THE CAL PH EDITORIAL EXPANSION.
GOOD AFTERNOON DAVE LEWIS W.
DIRECTOR OF FACILITIES PLANNING
ACTIVATION MANAGEMENT-
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL HEALTH
CARE SERVICES- WE ARE REQUESTING
FUNDING TO SUPPORT A JANITORIAL
CONTRACT WITH CAL P. I. A. THIS
OUT FOR THE HEALTH FACILITIES
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM THIS CONTRACT
PROVIDES- FOR THE PROGRAM WHICH
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR CLEANING AND
SANITIZING DIRECT PATIENT CARE
AREAS WITHIN- CCR INSTITUTIONS.
THESE RESOURCES WILL SUPPORT
HAVE MEANT ADDITIONAL AS REVISED
THREE POSITIONS TO REDUCE THE
SUPERVISORY RATIO FROM ABOUT
FORTY TO ONE TO TWENTY ONE TO
ALLOW. THE SUPERVISORS PROVIDE
MORE MENTORING AND TRAINING TO
OUR CAR STRAIGHT POPULATION THAT
WORKS FOR THEM- AND IT ALSO
INCREASES THE NUMBER OF SERVICE
AREAS THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
SERVICE- REFLECTING SOME
ADDITIONAL- AREAS THAT THEY
CHECK ON PROGRAM IS TAKING OVER
INCLUDING THE PSYCHIATRIC
INPATIENT PROGRAM HEADS TO HIS
FELLOW STATE PRISON AND
STANDALONE DENTAL CLINICS AND
ALSO WE CONSTRUCTED HEALTHCARE
FACILITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM
SPACE- DOES COME ONLINE SINCE
THE CONTRACT WAS FIRST INITIATED
- THIS INTO. PROGRAM OFFENDERS
FOR POSTING. EMPLOYMENT THROUGH
A CERTIFIED HEALTHCARE
ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES NATIONAL
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY THE CAL
PIA'S STAFF. WITH THE M.
AMERICAN HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE FOR THIS
PROPOSAL. HI THIS IS ORLANDO AT
THE LEGISLATIVE APPLE THE SAUCES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
WE VIEW THIS PROPOSAL AS HAVING
TWO COMPONENTS- THE FIRST IS
THAT A PROPOSES TO EXPAND THE
CONTRACT CONTINUE HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES AS HEARD AND THEN THE
SECOND IS TO PROPOSED CHANGES. I
IN THE RATIO OF CUSTODIAN
SUPERVISORS TAKE A STUDY AND
STAFF AND THEREFORE WE ASSESSED
THE PROPOSAL IN THESE TWO
COMPONENTS THAT ARE- NOT SPACED
OUT WITHIN THE PROPOSAL THAT
GIVEN THAT THE QUALITY OF THE
SERVICES PROVIDED BY CAL PA HAVE
BEEN AT AN ACCEPTABLE STANDARD
THAT IT DOES NOT RAISE CONCERNS.
WE FIND THE PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
THE CONTRACT TO INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES REASONABLE. BUT WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
THE FUNDING NECESSARY TO EXPAND
INTO NEW HEALTH CARE FACILITIES.
HOWEVER WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THE SECOND
PART OF THE PROPOSAL TO CHANGE
THE RATIO CUSTODIAN SUPERVISORS
TO CUSTODIAN STAFF. I THOUGHT
OUR ASSESSMENT CHANGING THE
RATIO APPEARS UNNECESSARY AND
THIS IS FOR TWO REASONS. THE
FIRST IS THAT WHILE COUNTY A
RAISES PROBLEMS RESULTING FROM
LACK OF SUPERVISORS. SO DOES NOT
PROPERLY KEEPING INVENTORY OR
NOT PROVIDING TIMELY EVALUATIONS
WE NOTE THAT THESE PROBLEMS HAVE
NOT BEEN SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH. TO
IMPACT THE QUALITY OF SERVICE
PROVIDED THE SECOND REASON WE
WANT WHITE CHANGING THE
SUPERVISOR TO STAFF RATIO
APPEARS UNNECESSARY. THAT CAP
YEAH HAS NOT CLEARLY INDICATED
HOW THE ADDITIONAL SUPERVISORS
PROPOSED. WOULD IN FACT
ALLEVIATE THE PROBLEMS THEY'VE
IDENTIFIED FOR EXAMPLE IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT OTHER ACTIONS SUCH
AS ADDITIONAL TRAINING. IS ONE
POSSIBILITY AMONG SEVERAL OTHERS
THAT WOULD ADDRESS THAT
IDENTIFIED PROBLEMS IN A MORE
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT MANNER.
FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE
RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WRONG IMPROVE THE
FUNDING NECESSARY TO EXPAND.
INTO THE NEW HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES WE ALSO RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE TO RACK CAL
QUE TO REPORT THE AMOUNT OF THE
REQUESTED FUNDING. ASSOCIATED
WITH CHANGING THE CUSTODIAN
SUPERVISOR RATIO SEPARATELY FROM
EXPANDING THE CONTRACT. WE KNOW
THAT AT THE TIME OF OUR ANALYSIS
LPA WAS UNABLE TO PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION- BUT BASED ON
LIMITED DATA WE ESTIMATE THAT
SEVERAL MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THE
REQUESTED FUNDING IS RELATED TO
CHANGING THE SUPERVISOR TO STAFF
RATIO. THANK YOU NOT BE HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS. DR MADAM AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT'S
A SENTIMENT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. OKAY THIRTY IN
SUPERVISORY RATIOS AS YOU'VE
HEARD AVERAGE ABOUT FORTY
INCARCERATED AND CIVIL SERVICE
STUDENTS JACK TWO ONE IN CIVIL
SERVICES CUSTODIAN SUPERVISOR.
SUPERVISORY POSITIONS ARE ABOUT
OVERSIGHT STAFF DEVELOPMENT AND
TRAINING. CALCAVECCHIA'S GOALS
ARE TWO FOLD THE FIRST IS TO
PROVIDE QUALITY JANITORIAL
SERVICES AND SECONDLY TO ENHANCE
PUBLIC SAFETY BY PROVIDING
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
PRODUCTIVE WORK AND TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE
EMPLOYABILITY POSTING CURSE
RATIONS. INCREASING THE NUMBER
OF SUPERVISORS WOULD ALLOW
CALTRAIN IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
SERVICES AND BETTER EET THEIR
MISSION BY PROVIDING WORK
FEEDBACK IN TRAINING. ON THE JOB
TRAINING WHICH IS CRITICAL TO
ANYONE'S JOB PERFORMANCE
EFFECTIVE FEEDBACK- CONTROL AND
OVERSIGHT OF INVENTORY IN
ROPHECIES INSURING APPROPRIATE
STAFF INTERACTIONS FINDING AND
KEEPING QUALIFIED STAFF WHICH
THERE IS- HAS BEEN SOME TURNOVER
WITH THE CUSTODIAN STAFF. AND
REALLY CONDUCTING THOSE
CLEANLINESS AUDITS AUDITS TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS A FULL
THREE SIXTY FEEDBACK- FOR THOSE
SERVICES. SO THIS IS WHY- THE
PROPOSAL WOULD CHANGE THAT
SUPERVISORY RATIO- AND I WOULD
PROVIDE CALCULATE- TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE COLLEGE OUR
GUIDANCE ON CUSTODIAN SUPERVISOR
RATIO. THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ON IT AND I
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE- AT THE CC WE
DIDN'T GET- COSTS FOR THE
EXPANSION VERSUS THE SUPERVISORS
SO THE EXPANSION WOULD WOULD BE
ROUGHLY ABOUT FIVE MILLION PER
YEAR WHERE IS FORCE AND-
INCREASE IN SUPERVISORS- AS- THE
BREAKOUT SACRAMENTO MENTIONED
WOULD BE- THREE POINT SIX
MILLION IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND THEN FIVE POINT FIVE
MILLION- IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR AND THEREAFTER. THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU SO ARE YOU I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE SUPERVISOR RATIO
PIECE FOR. A MINUTE IN AND WHAT
IS OUR ULTIMATE GOAL FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE INCARCERATED
- AND SALUTE YOU TALKED BOUT TO
FALL BOTH THE QUALITY OF THE
JANITORIAL SERVICES. BUT THEN
ALSO PROVIDING THE SKILL SET-
WOULD AND AS SEEN AS A
VOCATIONAL PROGRAM PROGRAM THAT
WOULD THEN BE ABLE TO LEAD TO-
EMPLOYMENT ONCE ONCE THEY LEAVE-
THE PRESENT. DO WE HAVE ANY DATA
ARE WE TRACKING WHETHER OR NOT
THIS IS ACTUALLY WORKING AS A
VOCATIONAL PROGRAM OR THESE
INDIVIDUALS WALKING OUT WITH
SOME SORT OF CERTIFICATION. ARE
THEY LANDING JOBS IN THIS IN
THIS PROFESSION ONCE THEY LEAVE
AND HOW AND SALAS IS THE SUCCESS
RATE THERE TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
THIS IS ACTUALLYA REAL
VOCATIONAL PROGRAM AND NOT JUST.
ANOTHER MEANS TO ACCOMPLISH THE
GOAL OF CLEANING HAVING CLEAN A
CLEAN CENTER- CAL PA DOES NOT
TRACK. SUCCESS RATES FOR
PLACEMENT POST INCARCERATION AND
UNFORTUNATELY- SO WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY. DATA REGARDING THE ACTUAL
PLACEMENT RATES WE DO HAVE YOU
KNOW SEVERAL SUCCESS STORIES OF
COURSE NUMBER OF. INDIVIDUALS
THAT WERE ABLE TO LAND JOBS AND
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL POST
INCARCERATION BECAUSE OF THIS
PROGRAM. THE RECIDIVISM RATE IS
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER THAN THE
GENERAL RECIDIVISM RATE- FOR
PARTICIPANTS IN CALCULATE
PROGRAMS. AND SO IN THAT WAY IT
HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL BUT WE
DIDN'T THE HELP YEAH IT DOES NOT
TRACK THEM INTO VISUALS WERE WE
COULD PROVIDE THAT SORT OF. DATA
AS FAR AS SUCCESS THE PLACEMENT
. THANK THE SAID GIVEN THE LACK
OF DATA AND TO IS NOT CLEAR THAT
THIS IS I. C. WORKING AS A
VOCATIONAL PROGRAM- AND GIVEN
THE ALLEYWAYS. L. L. L. A COMMON
. ABOUT THEY'RE NOT MEET NEEDING
TO BE A RACIAL DECREASE HOW DO
WE JUSTIFY- THIS THIS RATIO
DECREASES IT DOESN'T MAKE IT
DOESN'T SEEM TO. HAS A LOT TO ME
THAT WE NEED TO DECREASE RATIO
BASED ON THE LACK OF DATA AND-
NOW WE HAVE SO FAR. WE'VE SEEN
YEAH WE DO REGULAR AUDITS THAT
THEY JAPAN PROGRAM IN
INSTITUTIONS AND THEY DO AN
EXCELLENT JOB OF PROVIDING THE
SERVICES OF CLEANING.
INSTITUTIONS WHAT- CAL PA COULD
DO A BETTER JOB OF IS THE
MENTORING ASPECTS. OF HOPING THE
CAR STRAIGHT INDIVIDUALS
UNDERSTAND THE PROGRAM BETTER
THE DAY ARE BETTER SUITED THEY
DO RECEIVE A CERTIFICATE WHEN
THEY BELIEVE THAT SUCH A IT'S A
CERTIFICATE PROGRAM. THAT MEETS
THE- STANDARDS OF THE AMERICAN
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION FOR CLEANING. AND
CERTIFICATE PROGRAM- AND IN THAT
WAY IT'S VERY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM
BUT WE WOULD. WE THINK THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE BETTER MENTORING AND
TRAINING FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
AS THE PROGRAM PROCEEDS THAT
THERE IS LOWER THAN A FORTY TO
ONE RATIO IF IT'S THAT TWENTY TO
ONE RATIO THEY'RE ABLE TO
PROVIDE. THAT TRAINING THAT
FEEDBACK- THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THE DUTIES. AND AS THEY GO FORWARD. BUT
IF. AT THE ARE ARE SHOWING THAT
THE CLEAN. IS ADEQUATE- AND IF
THAT'S PART OF YOUR GOAL DO THEY
NEED ADDITIONAL MENTORING. AND
THEY'VE THAT MENTORING IS MEANT
TO BE S. TOWARD A CAREER ONCE
THEY LEAVE WE DON'T HAVE. THAT
INFORMATION AVAILABLE- WHAT ARE
THE GUARANTEES THAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY GETTING AN ARM OUR
MONEY'S WORTH HERE. THE
SENTIMENT ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- IN REVIEW OF THOSE. I'M
COMPLIANCE MONITORING UNIT
REPORTS- THAT THAT'S EASY AGE CS
DOES- SO OVER CALCULATES
CLEANING PROCESS EASE YOU'LL
FIND THAT THEY'RE NOT PERFECT
THEY ARE- DOING ADEQUATE
CLEANING BUT THERE'S DEFINITELY
AREAS WHERE PEOPLE CAN LEARN AND
IMPROVE AND THAT'S PART OF WHAT
THOSE SUPERVISORS COULD
POTENTIALLY DO- IS GIVING.
BETTER FEEDBACK THAT WHEN PEOPLE
LEAVE THEY HAVE THE SKILLS
NECESSARY TO EXCEL ON ALL THOSE
COMPONENTS- ACROSS THE BOARD SO
AND IT. THERE'S ALWAYS ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT. I THINK MIGHT MAKE
TO BE CLEAR MY CONCERN IS THAT
IF THEY'RE NOT PLAGUE OF THEY'RE
NOT GETTING JOBS IN THIS FIELD
ONCE THEY LEAVE IT DOESN'T
MATTER HOW WELL TRAINED THEY
ARE- AND SO THE INVESTMENT SEEMS. IT IT IT'S IT SEEMS IT SEEMS
THAT NECESSARY OF WE ALREADY
HAVE ACT ADEQUATE- CLEANING
GOING ON. THE ONE THING TO NOTE
IS THAT- WHILE THEY DON'T HAVE A
MECHANISM IN PLACE TO TRACK POST
INCARCERATION APPOINTMENT THEY
ARE- THERE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE EDT IN OTHER DEPARTMENTS
WITH THE PRISON TO EMPLOYMENT
INITIATIVE AND PART OF THAT IS
TO PROVIDE EMPLOYMENT DATA-
UPPER FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS AND- THERE ARE SOME
BARRIERS TO TRACKING CITIZENS
WHO ARE FORMERLY INCARCERATED
THAT THIS GROUP IS DEFINITELY
LOOKING INTO WAYS TO GET BETTER
DATA ON SOMETHING LIKE THIS. AT
WITHOUT AGAIN WITH THAT DATA OR
FINDING A WAY TO GET THROUGH
THOSE BARRIERS THAT THEN AND WE
HAVE TO ASK THE QUESTION OF IS
THIS SAVE OCCASIONAL PROGRAM. OR
JUST A SERVICE FOR THE PRESENT
AND BEING HONEST WITH YOURSELF
ABOUT WHAT IT IS AND- YEAH
CALLING A SPADE A SPADE. AND SO
MAYBE WHEN YOU COME BACK TO US
YOU COULD LOOK INTO HOW MIGHT WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO BETTER TRACK
THAT INFORMATION SO WELL MAYBE
WILL BE A LITTLE BIT FAILURE AND
SOME OF THESE PROPOSALS. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR DOES ONE MORE
THING THIS IS CYNTHIA FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCING. I JUST
WANTED TO ALSO NOTE THAT- TELL
ME I HAVE HAD DIFFICULTY.
RETAINING STAFF AND CUSTODIANS
AND IT. THERE IS A LOT MORE
CONSTANT CHURN AND HAVING
EFFECTIVE SUPERVISION CAN HELP
REMEDIATE THAT- AS WELL AS THE
FACT THAT I LOWER SUPERVISION
RATE IS CONSISTENT WITH HOW HR
GUIDANCE. THIS IS ORLANDO
SANCHEZ WITH THE- L. A. L. IN
REGARDS TO- BEING- THE
SUPERVISOR RATIO BEING-
FOLLOWING A COMPLIANCE WITH
KELLY CHARLIE ACTUALLY FOLLOWED
UP WITH KELLY CHARTER AND- THIS
IS RATIO THAT CALIFORNIA A HOPES
TO ADDRESS IS ACTUALLY AN
EXPIRED RATIO ALSO- THAT'S ONE
THING WE FOLLOWED UP WITH A
CHARM WERE ABLE TO GET A LITTLE
BIT MORE INFORMATION ON THAT- IN
THAT REGARD CALCULATE DOES NOT
HAVE TO FOLLOW THAT GUIDELINE.
OKAY. WE JUST TO REITERATE WE
HAVE A LOT OF THE SAME CONCERNS
THAT THE ALLEY- BROUGHT UP ON
THIS RACIAL- INVESTMENTS- AS
WELL AND SO AS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD JUSTIN COURAGE- THE
DEPARTMENT TO RETHINK THAT
REQUEST OR THINK OF THERE'S
OTHER WAYS. TO HELP RETAIN STAFF
FOR OTHER WAYS TO IMPROVE IN
THOSE AREAS. OUR WHERE WE WILL
PASS ADEQUATE TO A MUCH BETTER
JOB IN CLEANLINESS OUT THERE- IF
THERE ARE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WILL MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT THE PANEL WHICH IS
THE REDUCTION WORKLOAD. THIS IS
NOT A ONE CLEANED UP YOU DEBORAH
KERR OFFICE OF FISCAL SERVICES
FOR CDC ARE- WE'RE REQUESTING
RESOURCES FOR PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT. UNIT TO ADDRESS CHIARI
WORKLOAD WHICH IS SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE AS A RESULT OF
STATUTORY AND OPERATIONAL
CHANGES. IN SUMMARY THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING THE
NINETEENTH POSITION TO SUPPORT
THE DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS ARE UNIT AT SEVEN
POINT SIX OPPOSITION TO SUPPORT
THE OFFICE OF LEGAL AFFAIRS.
RESOURCES REQUESTED FOR OFFICE
OF LEGAL AFFAIRS WILL BE
UTILIZED TO RESPOND ALL PR REYES
ASSOCIATE IT WITH. OF THE FOUR
CATEGORIES ARE TRIGGERING EVENTS
THAT WERE ADDED TO PENAL CODE
SECTION EIGHT THIRTY TWO POINT
SEVEN. YEAH YOU YOU WHICH
INCLUDE ITEMS SUCH AS ROCKING A
REASONABLE OR EXCESSIVE FORCE OR
UNLAWFUL ARREST RESEARCH.
DIVISION OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS
HANDLE ALL KYARI OTHER PR A
WORKLOAD ONE TWENTY FROM ANY
PERSON WHO HAS THE RIGHT TO
INSPECT- REQUEST AND RECEIVE
COPIES OF PUBLIC RECORDS. OTHER
ARE NOT EXEMPT. FROM PUBLIC
DISCLOSURE. I REQUEST SOME
ALMOST IN THE YEAR AND ARE HAS A
TWO BASIC YOU TO INCREASE. PRIOR
TO ONE TO TWO THE DEPARTMENT DID
NOT AN ESTABLISHED UNIT OR THAT
OF THE- TO HAVE ALL P. R. A.
RIVER. ANY IN PART ONE TO TWO
BUDGET CYCLE RECEIVE SEVEN
POSITION TO LOOK ADDRESS
DOCUMENT PRODUCTION WORKLOAD.
AND WORKLOAD IDENTIFIED WITH
BEFORE TWENTY ONE. BUT THIS
REQUEST WILL PROVIDE RESOURCES
TO SUPPORT THE ON GOING
INCREASED WORKLOAD- IF YOU ARE A
REQUEST FOR ALL. OTHER
APPLICABLE PUBLIC RECORDS AND SB
SIXTEEN WORKLOAD RELATED TO YOU
AT THE INTERNATIONAL CATEGORIES
IDENTIFIED. IN PENAL CODE EIGHT
THIRTY TWO POINT SEVEN. IT WENT
ON YOU KNOW WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. ACROSS FOR
PROPOSALS- THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING A TOTAL OF TWENTY ONE
POINT SIX NEW POSITIONS AND TWO
POINT EIGHT MILLION GENERAL FUND
ONGOING AS WELL AS READ
REDIRECTION OF FVE EXISTING
POSITIONS AND EIGHT HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE THOUSAND. TO
SUPPORT THAT AND- THE EXISTING
AND NEW REDACTION WORKLOAD THAT
WAS JUST DESCRIBED. WE FIND THAT
THE LEVEL OF RESOURCES REQUESTED
APPEARS REASONABLE IN THE NEAR
TERM HOWEVER THE DEPARTMENT
INDICATES THAT IT'S- IN THE
PROCESS OF IMPLEMENTING NEW-
SOFTWARE THAT IT EXPECTS TO
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE THE-
EFFICIENCY AT WITH WHICH STAFF
ARE ABLE TO PERFORM REDAKTION
WORKLOAD. SO IT'S UNCLEAR CDCR
WILL NEED BEES THIS LEVEL OF
RESOURCES IN THE FUTURE AFTER
THAT SOFTWARE IS FULLY
IMPLEMENTED. SO WE RECOMMEND
TAT THE LEGISLATURE- APPROVED
THE PROPOSED POSITIONS AND
FUNDING ON A TWO YEAR LIMITED
TERM BASIS. RATHER THAN ON AN
ONGOING BASIS AS IS PROPOSED-
AND THEN AFTER CDCR HAS FULLY
IMPLEMENTED A NEW SOFTWARE AND
HAS A BETTER SENSE OF THE ON
GOING WORKLOAD. IT CAN'T COME
FORWARD WITH A- A REQUEST FOR
ONGOING RESOURCES AS PART OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
BUDGET PROCESS. AND I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT THIS APPROACH OF.
PROVIDING LIMITED TERM POSITIONS
IN AREAS WHERE THERE IS- LACK OF
CLARITY ON THE ON GOING NEED IS
NOT. UNUSUAL SOMETHING THAT
APARTMENT IS ACTUALLY. PROPOSING
TO DO IN A FEW CASES. THANK YOU
. THE AFTERNOON ALISON HEWITT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
ADMINISTRATION UNDERSCORES THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE VARIOUS
REQUESTS FOR THESE PERMANENT I'M
GOING RESOURCES FOR REDUCTION AS
THE DEPARTMENT IS CURRENTLY
STRUGGLING TO MEET THE WORKLOAD
DEMANDS ASSOCIATED WITH PARAQUAT
REQUESTS AND THE SOFTWARE THAT
THE ONLY- MENTIONS ME OUR LEAD
TO SOME EFFICIENCIES AND CERTAIN
WORKLOAD FUNCTIONS BUT IT
DOESN'T ACTUALLY IMPACTS THE
CORE WORKLOAD THAT'S REQUIRED
WHICH RELATES TO THE ACTUAL
MANUAL REDUCTION OF THE FOOTAGE
WHICH CAN TAKE TEN MINUTES TO
REDACT ONE MINUTE OF AUDIO
FOOTAGE AND TWENTY MINUTES
STRAIGHT DOC ONE MINUTE OF VIDEO
FOOTAGE ON AVERAGE. AND SO AND
THEN THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF WORKLOAD THAT I THE
SOFTWARE ISN'T LIKELY TO IMPACT
WHICH HAS TO DO WITH RESEARCH
CASE PREPARATION TRACKING
CORRESPONDENTS IN REPORTING I TO
THE OVERALL VOLUME OF WORKLOAD
IS SIGNIFICANT IN THE
ADMINISTRATION FEELS THIS IS A
FAIRLY CONSERVATIVE STARTING
POINT- AND THE VOLUME OF
WORKLOAD IS LIKELY TO OFFSET ANY
EFFICIENCIES THAT ARE GAINED
THROUGH THE REDUCTION SOFTWARE
WITH THAT AD BILLABLE. THE
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU-
OKAY ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME IN
THIS PANEL FONG REMOVE THIS ON
TO THE NEXT- ISSUE NUMBER FIVE.
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
REALIGNMENT. AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY AME IS DR HEATHER FULTON AND
THE DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE CURRENTLY DJJ
PREPARING FOR THE CLOSURE IN
RESPONSE TO S. B. EIGHT TWENTY
THREE BUT I WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR OUR FOCUS. WILL CONTINUE
TO BE THE CONTINUITY OF ALL
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS OF IN A
SAFE AND REHABILITATIVE MATTER
FOR ALL THE GUITAR CARE
CURRENTLY WE HAVE A POPULATION
OF SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY YOUTH
AND WE EXPECT THE POPULATION TO
BEGIN REDUCING AND FUTURE
MONTHS. DJJ IS FOCUSED ON
PROVIDING MEANINGFUL AND
TAILORED REHABILITATIVE SERVICES
FOR EVERY YOUTH AND DJJ UNTIL WE
CLOSE THE NEEDS OF DJJ YOUTH ARE
SIGNIFICANT AND COMPLEX WHICH IS
WHY MEASURED APPROACH IS
IMPORTANT WHEN MAKING DECISIONS
REGARDING HOW YOU THREE CHANCES
THAT COUNTIES BOTH ACTIVELY
DOWNSIZING THE SYSTEM. THE
MANNER IN WHICH THE TRANSITION
OF CARE IS COORDINATED IT'S
CRITICAL THE TRANSFER CARE
REQUIRES A ONE SIZE FITS ONE
MODEL AS WE KNOW EACH THAT YOU
CHOOSE IS UNIQUE AND EACH OUNTY
IS UNIQUE. THAT IS WHY WE HAVE
BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO AND
BEING GAUGED WITH OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
YOUTH AND THEIR FAMILIES. IN
TRANSITION PLANNING. AND TELL
THEIR TRANSIT CARE. A CENTRAL
COMPONENT TRANSITION PLANNING
THANK ADDRESSING NEED SUCH AS
MENTAL HEALTH I'M GOING MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS CONTINUED POSITIVE
EDUCATIONAL DEVELOPMENT
EMPLOYMENT AND OTHER OUTCOMES
RELATED TO AVOIDING RECIDIVISM.
THANK GOODNESS PROVISION IN THIS
CASE PLANNING FOR EACH YOUTH IS
A KEY COMPONENT TO THE
TRANSITION OF CARE SO THAT THEIR
STAFF ARE AWARE OF THE USED
STRENGTH THEIR NEEDS BUT
SERVICES THAT YOU'VE RECEIVED
BOND DJJ ADDITIONAL TREATMENT
MEANS RECOMMENDED AN EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT. IT ALSO ALLOWS FOR
COLLABORATION AND FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS FOR CREATING THE
BEST PLAN TO MOVE TO LOCAL CARE
AND SUCCESSFULLY SUCCESSFULLY
INTEGRATING. THE YOUTH INTO
THEIR NEW TREATMENTS CITING. THE
CHALLENGES FACE THE ARE OVER
NEXT MONTHS SIXTEEN ONE ARE REAL
. AND THE PAST FEW YEARS HAVE
BEEN HARD ON BOTH USE STOP FOR
MULTIPLE REASONS WE'VE HAD TO
ASK FOR PATIENCE AND
FLEXIBILITY. A LOT TO ASK OF
ANYONE IT'S REALLY A LOT TO ASK
OF YOU WHO ARE STILL LEARNING
HOW TO COPE WITH. DIFFICULT
EMOTIONS AND CERTAINTY AND
CHANGE. ONE OF OUR PRIMARY
CHALLENGES TO AND THE RETENTION
OF STAFF WHO UNDERSTANDABLY HAVE
BEEN SEEKING EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES JOB STABILITY FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
RECOGNIZING THE NEED TO RETAIN
AND RECRUIT VALUABLE VALUABLE
STAFF TO DJJ DEMONSTRATION OF
PROPOSED OPTIONS FOR STAFF TO
HAVE EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
PRIOR TO THE CLOSURE AND
INCENTIVES TO STAY UNTIL THE
CLOSURE ON LEASE. DJS CORE
MISSION IS REHABILITATION. THIS
IS WHY THESE ACTORS ARE VITAL TO
COMPUTING. FORGET THAT ENABLE TO
PROVIDE THE QUALITY EDUCATION
AND TREATMENT FOR YOU UNTIL THE
VERY LAST DAY. IN TERMS OF COBIT
WE CONTINUE TO BE DEVOTED AND TO
THE CARE OF OUR USE AND IT HAS
BEEN OUR TOP PRIORITY FOR THEIR
SAFETY AND OUR STAFF IF E. SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC.
AS OF TODAY WE HAVE NO ACTIVE
CASES WITH ANY OF OUR
FACILITIES. LIKE MANY WE ARE
ANXIOUS TO RETURN TO SOME SENSE
OF NORMALITY AND WE RE IN THE
PROCESS OF REVIEWING A ROAD MAP-TO RE OPENING. WELL WE WILL NEED
TO CONTINUE TO BE VIGILANT AS WE
NAVIGATE THESE NEXT SIXTEEN
MONTHS AND BE READY TO MAKE
CHANGES AS NEEDED TO KEEP
EVERYONE SAFE. THANK YOU AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. I THINK YOU A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
SPECIFIC QUESTION DOES HE KNOW
SPECIFIC COMMENTS BUT AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- FOR DOCTOR BOTH- HAVE YOU
BEEN RECALLED BY THE COUNTY
SINCERE LACK REALIGNMENT WITH
THE ANNOUNCED AND DO WE KNOW
WHERE THE STUDENTS WERE
EVENTUALLY PLACED. I AM WE HAVE
HAD STANDS AT. TWENTY TWENTY WE
HAVE HAD NINETY TWO CASES THAT
WERE A PETITION WAS PUT INTO THE
PORT FOR THEM TO BE RECALLED
TWENTY THREE OF THOSE WRE
GRANTED I BELIEVE IN THE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE LARGE VAST
MAJORITY OF THOSE CASES AND THEY
WERE- NOT NECESSARILY ALL DUE TO
CLOSURE. SEVERAL OF THEM WERE
BUT ENSURING KOPEN- BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING WITH THE VAST
MAJORITY IS THEY WORK GRANTED AT
LEAST. CAME ANY QUESTIONS THE
SYSTEM CORRECT THANK YOU FOR THE
UPDATE WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER SIX.
I
WANT TO PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW
YOU HAVEN'T REALLY HELPFUL
SUMMARY IN YOUR AGENDA- AND THIS
PROPOSAL IS FOR ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR JUVENILE
FACILITY IMPROVEMENTS. TO
RESPOND TO THE CURRENT AND
PRESSING NEEDS THAT COUNTIES ARE
FACING TO MODERNIZE AND UPDATE
THEIR FACILITIES TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN MEETING THE GOALS
OF DJJ REALIGNMENT WHICH DOCTOR
PULLS HIS JUSTIN SPEAKING ABOUT-
THE KEY. THANK YOU AND REALLY
SIGNIFICANT POLICY GOALS ARE IN
THIS PROGRAMMATIC CHIPS INCLUDE
ENSURING THAT THERE IS
PROGRAMMING AND TREATMENT TO
SUPPORT POSITIVE YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT- ARMED SERVICES IN
COUNTY FACILITIES NEED TO BE
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
TRAUMA INFORMED. AND IN AS MANY
CASES AS POSSIBLE KEEP YOUNG
PEOPLE CLOSER TO HOME. CALLIE'S
MONEY BE SURE THAT THEY'RE ABLE. TO PROVIDE YOU WITH A- WITH
ALL THE SERVICES THAT THEY NEED
PROGRAMMING AT THE APPROPRIATE
LEVELS AND I THINK EVERYONE IN
THIS ROOM IS CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITIES THAT EXIST THAT IF
IT COUNTY WHETHER THAT'S A
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OR JUDGE
RECREATION APARTMENT. DOESN'T
FEEL LIKE THEY'RE PREPARED TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF A PARTICULAR
YOUNG PERSON THAT THERE'S AN
INCREASED RISK THAT THAT YOUNG
PERSON WILL BE TRANSFERRED INTO
THE ADULT. REMOTE SYSTEM AND SO
WE WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
COUNTIES HAVE BEEN MOVING VERY
VERY QUICKLY SINCE SB EIGHT
TWENTY THREE PASSED AND THEY
NEED TO BE READY AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE TO MEET THE NEEDS THE
NEEDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE. WILL BE
COMING INTO THE ACCOUNTING
SYSTEM AS YOU KNOW JOHNNY
SUBMITTED THEIR SB TWENTY THREE
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS- IN THE
OFFICE THE VIEWS AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION IS CONDUCTING A
ROBUST REVIEW. OF THOSE COUNTY
PLANS- I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LOOK THROUGH SEVERAL OF THEM
AND- THESE THEMES CONTINUE AGAIN
AND AGAIN. YOU SEE- THAT THAT
THE IDEAS. THE COUNTIES HAVE
FOCUSED ON. BASEBALL OUR AND
FACILITY THAT MIGHT. TO PROVIDE
FROM WORK. A MORE HOME LIKE
ENVIRONMENT- AND NUMEROUS OTHER
THINGS CONSISTENT WITH THE GOALS
OF THIS CHANGE IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE AND
THERE'S QUITE A BIT THAT'S BEEN
RAISED BY THE L. A. R. O. AND
SOME IN YOUR ANALYSIS AS WELL.
THIS IS NOT INTENDED TO INCREASE
CAPACITY IT'S INSTEAD TO IMPROVE
OF WHAT THE HOW THE FACILITIES-
ARE ABLE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
YOUTH COMING THEIR WAY- I KNOW
THAT WE- HAVE BEEN AT THIS
HEARING FOR QUITE A WHILE SO I
THINK I WOULD LIKE TO. STOP
THERE AND SEE WHAT QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE. AND THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. WE RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED COUNTY
OPERATED JUVENILE FACILITY
GRANTS PROGRAM. BECAUSE THE
ADMINISTRATION DID NOT PRODUCT
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT INFORMATION.
ON HOW IT ARRIVED AT THE A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND IT
IS NOT CLEAR WHY ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IS NECESSARY. WE WOULD
LIKE TO POINT OUT A FEW THINGS
THAT WENT TO THIS RECOMMENDATION
. EARLY THE PROPOSAL IS NOT
BASED ON A THOROUGH ASSESSMENT
OF COUNTY FACILITY NEEDS. WHAT
THE ADMINISTRATION DID CONDUCT A
SURVEY TO DETERMINE WHETHER
COUNTIES WOULD BE INTERESTED IN
RECEIVING MORE FUNDS. NO
ASSESSMENT HAS BEEN CARRIED OUT
TO IDENTIFY SPECIFIC
DEFICIENCIES. OR SHOW THE EXTENT
TO WHICH EXISTING COUNTY
FACILITIES ARE IN NEED OF REPAIR
pOR NOT ADEQUATE TO PROVIDE. THE
REHAB SERVICES TO RE ALIGNED
YOUTH. THIS MAKES IT DIFFICULT
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO EVALUATE
THE APPROPRIATENESS OF THE
PROPOSED A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. IN ADDITION WHEN
CONSIDERING WHETHER COUNTIES ARE
IN NEED OF THIS FUNDING OF THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
TWO THINGS. THE FIRST IS THAT IN
RECENT YEARS. THE LEGISLATURE
HAS PROVIDED THREE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR IT JOVENEL COUNTY
FACILITIES THAT HAVE LED TO
NEWLY CONSTRUCTED AT SPACE. AND
REPAIRS THAT ARE ARE ONLY
RECENTLY COMING ONLINE IS NEWLY
CONSTRUCTED SPACES MAY BE IN
BETTER CONDITION. AND MORE
CONDUCIVE TO RE HAVE PROGRAMMING
. SECOND POINT IS THAT COUNTIES
HAVE THE ABILITY TO CONTRACT
WITH EACH OTHER FOR ADDITIONAL
SPACE. IT IS POSSIBLE THAT SOME
COUNTIES MAY HAVE FACILITY NEEDS
SUCH COUNTIES CAN CONTRACT WITH
OTHERS TO HOUSE HE'S RELYING TWO
YEARS. AND IN FACT THE SURVEY BY
THE SEC FOLLOWING REAIGN THEM
AND FOUND THAT SEVERAL COUNTIES
WOULD BE WILLING TO TAKE ON.
REALIGNED YEARS FROM OTHER
COUNTIES. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
REJECT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
IF IN THE FUTURE THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ABLE TO
PROVIDE A DETAILED ASSESSMENT OF
COUNTY JUVENILE FACILITY NEEDS.
THAT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THESE
NEWLY CONSTRUCTED BED SPACES AND
THE INABILITY OF COUNTIES TO
PARTNER AMONGST EACH OTHER AND
THEN THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER PROVIDING FACILITY
GRANTS TO THOSE COUNTIES AT THAT
TIME. AND THE LAST POINT WE'D
LIKE TO MAKE. IS THAT THIS
PROPOSAL IS EXCLUDABLE UNDER THE
STATE APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT. AS A
REMINDER TO THE LEGISLATURE THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION IMPOSES
A LIMIT ON THE AMOUNT OF REVENUE
THE STATE CAN APPROPRIATE EACH
YEAR. OFTEN CALLED THE CELL. THE
STATE CAN EXCLUDE CERTAIN
APPROPRIATIONS FROM THE SOUTH
CALCULATION SUGGESTS BENDING ON
CAPITAL OUTLAY WHICH THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD FALL UNDER. AS
SUCH IF THE LEGISLATURE REJECTS
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ITWOULD
NEED TO REPURPOSE THE ASSOCIATE
FUNDING FOR OTHER SOLID
EXCLUDABLE PURPOSES. THANK YOU
AND HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS. I
THINK YOU IT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. WITH THE CLOSURE DJJ ON
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
THREE COUNTIES WILL ASSUME THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR SERVING ALL
JUSTICE INVOLVED YOUTH. TO THE
YOUTH ACROSS THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE CONTINUUM THIS INCLUDES
YOUTH THAT WILL HAVE A GREATER
REHABILITATIVE NEEDS AND
GENERALLY REQUIRE A HIGHER LEVEL
OF SERVICE. THE ADMINISTRATION
IS PROPOSING FUNDS BASED ON
LOCAL NEEDS WITH THE GOAL OF THE
FIFTEEN COUNTIES IN PROVIDING
SPACES THAT WILL SUPPORT
TREATMENT AND REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING FOR THE RELATING TO
YOU THAT THEY WILL THEY ARE NOW
AND WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
SERVING UNDER SB EIGHT TO THREE
IN SB NINETY TWO. AND I'D BE A
CITY CAN SHARE THIS ADDITIONALLY
IT WAS EVIDENT THROUGH THE GRANT
ADMINISTRATION PROCESS FOR THE
SB EIGHTY THREE YOUTH PROGRAMS
AND FACILITIES GRANT PROGRAM AND
WE UNDERSTAND MANY OF THE COUNTY
PLANS REQUIRED UNDER SB EIGHT TO
THREE. INCLUDE REFERENCES TO
FACILITY RELATED NEEDS
PARTICULARLY AS IT COULD TAKE
PERTAINS TO CREATING A MORE
THERAPEUTIC AND HOME LIKE
ENVIRONMENTS. THE ADMINISTRATION
IS SEEKING IS THAT COMING UP TO
BE AS SUCCESSFUL AS POSSIBLE AND
SERVING THE REALIGN POPULATION
AND HAS IDENTIFIED A HUNDRED
MILLION AS A REASONABLE AMOUNT
TO PERFORM FACILITY
MODIFICATIONS AND IMPROVEMENTS.
TO PROVIDE THERAPEUTIC AND YOU
CENTER TREATMENT AND
REHABILITATIVE STATE AND
ENVIRONMENTS. AND ADDITIONALLY
DID YOU SCHEDULED TO CLOSE IN
JUST SEVENTEEN MONTHS THE
ADMINISTRATION IS SEEKING TO
PROVIDE FUNDS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE TO ENABLE COUNTIES TO
UNDERTAKE AS MUCH PLANNING AND
PROJECT WORK PRIOR TO DJS CLOSER
AS POSSIBLE. I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
WITHOUT HAPPY. TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU. MR GOOSE MON ARE YOU AVAILABLE
. HE YES CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY- BUDGET COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS FRANKIE WAS MINE I'M
AN ATTORNEY AT THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW OR  LEAD A
TEAM OF ATTORNEYS POLICY A
COMMUNITY ADVOCATES FOCUSED ON
ADVANCING POLICIES AND
INVESTMENTS PROVEN TO BE
EFFECTIVE AT PROMOTING POSITIVE
OUTCOMES FOR YOUTH INVOLVED IN
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
INCREASING COMMUNITY HEALTH AND
SAFETY I ALSO SPENT SIX YEARS AS
AN ADOLESCENT INCARCERATING
COUNTY JUVENILE HALL AND STATE
YOUTH PRISONS. I'M HERE TODAY TO
VOICE MY STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ALLOCATE ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OF STATE FUNDS TO
COUNTIES TO SUPPORT IMPROVEMENTS
TO COUNTY OPERATED JUVENILE
FACILITIES AT THE STATE PREPARES
TO CLOSE DJJ I WANT TO BE CLEAR
ABOUT MY POSITION I AGREE THE
STATEMENT INVEST RESOURCES IN
DEVELOPING LOCAL CAPACITY AND
THE RIGHT INFRASTRUCTURE TO
BETTER SERVE YOU HOWEVER A HASTY
DECISION TO DUMP ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS INTO RENOVATING
LOCAL YOUTH JAILS HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO UNDERMINE THE
HEALING BASED DIRECTION FOR
YOUTH JUSTICE THAT WAS ENACTED A
LITTLE OVER A YEAR AGO WITH SB
EIGHT TWENTY THREE. WE ARE AT A
CRITICAL MOMENT WHERE WE NEED TO
PROCEED THOUGHTFULLY NOT JUST
BECAUSE A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IS A LOT OF TAXPAYER
MONEY BUT BECAUSE THE STATE MUST
ENSURE THAT EACH STEP IT TAKES
SUPPORT THE DIRECTION IT HAS
CHOSEN AND DOES NOT UNDERMINE
AND CAUSE HARM TO YOUNG PEOPLE
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES THE PURPOSE
OF SB TWENTY THREE WAS TO CLOSE
CALIFORNIA'S PUNITIVE AND
HARMFUL YOUTH PRISONS AND
INSTEAD OF INVESTING LOCAL
ALTERNATIVES THAT BETTER PROMOTE
POSITIVE YOUTH DEVELOPMENT AND
REDUCE CRIME AND RECIDIVISM
UTILIZING TRAUMA INFORMED
CULTURALLY ROOTED AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
SERVICES FOR YOUTH IN THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT.
UNFORTUNATELY MOST COUNTIES ARE
MAKING PLANS FOR THE LONG TERM
INCARCERATION OF YOUTH IN
JUVENILE HALLS MAXIMUM SECURITY
SHORT TERM DETENTION FACILITIES
THAT ARE FAR MORE RESTRICTIVE
PUNITIVE AND HARMFUL TO YOUNG
PEOPLE THAN WHAT DJJ OFFERS NOW
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED ALLOCATED
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
STATE FUNDS TO SUPPORT
IMPROVEMENTS TO PUNITIVE AND
HARMFUL YOU DETENTION FACILITIES
WITH. NO JUSTIFICATION FOR THE
AMOUNT PROPOSED OR FORT PROPOSED
FOR. WEALTHY AGAIN THE ONE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. IS ARBITRARY
AND WOULD DO LITTLE TO MAKE ANY
JUVENILE HALL SUITABLE FOR
POSITIVE YOUTH DEVELOPMENT AND
THE ENTIRE STATE. HOWEVER A
HUNDRED MILLION A ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR STATE INVESTMENT
TO LOCAL JUVENILE FACILITIES
WOULD LOCK US INTO OVER
PROGRESSIVE APPROACH. TO SERVING
YOU. ONE THAT IS RELIANT ON
PUNITIVE CORRECTIONAL MODELS AT
ODDS WITH SB TWENTY THREES
INTENT. OF DEVELOPING LOCAL
TRAUMA INFORMED CULTURALLY
ROOTED AND DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE TREATMENT FOR YOUTH
IN THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
APPROPRIATE SETTINGS. THE
LEGISLATURE MEANS EJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AS IS. AND
INSTEAD INVEST THE STATE'S
RESOURCES INTO RESEARCHING 
DEVELOPMENTAL AND REHABILITATIVE
NEEDS OF DJJ ELIGIBLE YOUTH. AND
THE NEEDS OF COUNTIES TO IMPROVE
INDIVIDUAL YOUTH OUTCOMES AND
COMMUNITY HEALTH AND SAFETY. AT
LET'S TAKE A MOMENT TO DO THIS
RIGHT BECAUSE THE DECISION THAT
WE MAKE IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
MONTHS. WILL HAVE A FAR REACHING
IMPACT FOR YEARS AND DECADES TO
COME. THE STATE COULD TASK THE
OFFICE OF YOU CAN COMMITTEE
RESTORATION TO SURVEY THE FIELD.
RESEARCH BEST PRACTICES
ENVIRONMENTS FOR YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT. AND DEVELOP SHORT
AND LONG TERM SOLUTIONS FOR
PROGRAMMING AND SPACE NEEDS.
WITH THIS INFORMATION THE STATE
CAN RESPONSIBLY AND EFFECTIVELY
INVEST ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OR MORE. IN NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET. SESSION TO IMPROVE
YOURSELF COMES. OR BLACK BROWN
AND INDIGENOUS WITH HISTORIES OF
ABUSE NEGLECT POVERTY AND OTHER
DISADVANTAGES. TO DO OTHERWISE
WOULD RISK HARMING VULNERABLE
YOU FOR GENERATIONS INCREASING
TRANSFERS TO THE ADULT SYSTEM
WASTING STATE TAX DOLLARS ANY
ROAD IN THE PUBLIC'S TRUST AND
WELL INTENTIONED YOUTH JUSTICE
REFORMS. I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO NOTE
CALIFORNIA'S PLAN TO CLOSE THE
JJ BEGAN WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL DRIVEN BY BUDGETARY
CONCERNS. AND A RECOGNITION THAT
ARE OUTDATED HARMFUL YOU
CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM WAS NO
LONGER ACCEPTABLE. BUT HERE WE
ARE TODAY ENTERTAINING PROPOSAL
FROM THE SAME GOVERNOR THAT
WOULD INVESTIGATE IF IT CAN
STATE RESOURCES IN OUTDATED
HARMFUL YOUTH CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES. WITH LITTLE CONCERN
FOR COST TO OUR STATE AND IT'S
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS. WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO PAY A NEW
COURSE FOR YOUTH JUSTICE. A
MODEL SYSTEM THAT IS ROOTED IN
DATA AND RESEARCH AND GIVE
MEANING TO SB TWENTY THREE
VERSION OF HEALTH CENTER.
RACIALLY JUST SYSTEM THAT HONORS
THE TREMENDOUS POTENTIAL OF ALL
YOUTH LIKE MYSELF. HOWEVER THAT
WOULD REQUIRE US TO LEARN FROM
OUR MISTAKES AND NOT CONTINUE TO
MAKE HASTY DECISIONS AND POOR
INVESTMENTS IN CONCRETE CELL
BLOCKS STEEL DOORS. AND BARBED
WIRE FENCES WITH NO
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR HOW COUNTY
USE PUBLIC RESOURCES. AND HOW WE
TREAT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN WE KNOW BETTER AND WE
HAVE THE TIME AND RESOURCES TO
DO BETTER. LET'S SLOW THINGS
DOWN COME UP WITH A THOUGHTFUL
PLAN OPTIONS AND INVEST IN THE
HEALTH AND PROSPERITY. OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THAT- FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF. FINANCE- WANT TO READ YOU A
PIECE OF THE GOVERNOR'S DJ
REALIGNMENT WHICH INCLUDED THE
PROVISION THAT SAID. IT IS THE
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR COUNTIES TO
USE EVIDENCE BASED AND PROMISING
PRACTICES THE PROGRAMS THAT
IMPROVE THE OUTCOMES OF YOUTH
AND PUBLIC SAFETY REDUCE THE
TRANSFER OF YOUTH INTO THE ADULT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. ENSURE
THAT THIS POSITIONS ARE IN THE
LEAST ETHNIC- IN THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE OPERATIVE
ENVIRONMENT REDUCE AND THEN
ELIMINATE RACIAL AND ETHNIC
DISPARITIES AND REDUCE THE USE
OF CONFINEMENT IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM BY UTILIZING
COMMUNITY BASS RESPONSE AND
INTERVENTIONS. CAN YOU SPEAK TO
HOW THIS PROPOSAL I HEAR THROUGH
THE STATUTORY PROVISION. I'M
SURE THIS IS A HARD WITH THE BSE
THEME MAY I RESPOND. YES OR HER.
ARM THE PROPOSAL I'M GONNA ASK
YOU TO SPEAK UP A LITTLE BIT. OH
SURE LET ME CHECK MY MICROPHONE
HERE. IS THAT BETTER YES OKAY
THANKS- SO I THINK THAT THE
CONCERNS THAT- MISTER BECAUSE
MINE HAS OUTLINED ARE ONES THAT
ARE SHARED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
BY THE SPCA AND BY COUNTIES AND
WHILE CERTAINLY- THERE ARE ARE
DIFFERING VIEWS I THINK IF WE
WERE TO REVIEW TOGETHER THE
COUNTY PLANS THAT HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF SB EIGHT TWENTY THREE- THEY
ARE FULL OF EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES AND AN EVIDENCE BASED
AND PROMISING PRACTICES. ARE
HUGE CONCERN AND I THINK WHY
THERE'S A CERTAIN- URGENCY IN
THE TIME HERE IS THE SECOND ITEM
THAT YOU NOTED THE OUR SHARED
GOAL TO REDUCE TRANSFERS TO
ADULT COURT. ON LET'S KEEP IN
MIND THIS REALLY IS A COMP.
ARENA WHERE'S WHERE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT SERVICES NEED TO BE
DELIVERED AND THERE IS A
CONTINUUM OF CARE THERE'S ALSO
YOU KNOW WHAT TIME FRAME FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE- MIGHT INITIALLY BE
HOUSED IN A MORE RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT WHILE. PROGRAMMING
AND TREATMENT AND REHABILITATIVE
SERVICES ARE BEING DELIVERED- OF
THOSE. PROGRAMMING AND
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES ARE-
GOING TO IN. A NUMBER OF
INSTANCES NEED TO BE PROVIDED AT
A COUNTY DETENTION FACILITY AND
IT IS EXACTLY THE CONCERNS THAT
FRIEND HE WAS MY OUTLINED ABOUT
WANTING TO CHANGE ON THE
PHYSICAL PLANT THE FEEL AND- THE
ABILITY FOR THERE TO BE A MORE
HOME LIKE ENVIRONMENT BETTER
CLASSROOMS AND SOMEONE- THERE IS
ALSO A CONTINUUM OF. CARE AND
CAN AND COMMUNITY PARTNERS WILL
ABSOLUTELY BE INVOLVED IN SB
EIGHT TWENTY THREE AS IT IS
IMPLEMENTED SO IT'S- KIND OF YOU
KNOW NOT ALL- THE SERVICES ARE
NOT ALL GOING TO BE DELIVERED IN
IN DETENTION FACILITIES AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL THERE'S A WHOLE
RANGE OF NEEDS. OUT THERE AND
WHILE I KNOW ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS CERTAINLY IS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS TO GO INTO THIS WE ALSO
KNOW THAT FACILITY MODIFICATIONS
TEND TO ADD UP REALLY REALLY
QUICKLY AND WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
THINGS LIKE- ADDING CLASSROOMS
AND CHAINING CHANGING FURNITURE-
EVEN IN SOME CASES LIKE THOSE
WHO ARE HERE FROM LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WERE TO DECIDE TO. ADD CLIMBING
IN- THE ROOMS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
AND THOSE JUVENILE DETENTION
FACILITIES WHICH PRESENTLY DON'T
HAVE TOILETS AND SINKS THOSE
KINDS OF COSTS THAT UP REALLY
REALLY QUICKLY SO I WOULD JUST
AGREE THAT IT'S A LOT OF MONEY
AND I WOULD ALSO STATE THAT THE
NEEDS ARE VERY HIGH. SO YES THE
POLICY HOLDERS ARE CLEARLY IN
THEIR REDUCING TRANSFERS TO
ADULT COURTS ARE USING THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT
ADDRESSING THE REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUES OF REDUCING RACIAL AND
ETHNIC DISPARITIES BUT THERE
ALSO NEEDS TO BE A SERVICES
AVAILABLE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
ACROSS THE CONTINUUM OF CARE AND
THIS IS JUST ONE PART. OF THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE. SO THIS IS
JUST ONE PART OF THE CONTINUING
OKAY MAYBE THAT GOES INTO. IN
GENERAL MY CONCERNED WITH THIS
PROPOSAL AND WHY ABOUT THAT
PIECE OF. IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT WE
HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN- AND
THAT WE'RE MOVING IN THAT ALL
THE COUNTIES ARE MOVING IN THE
SAME DIRECTION IT'S NOT FAIR
THAT WERE HELPING THE COUNTIES
MOVE IN THE SAME DIRECTION THAT
WE'RE HOLDING THEM ACCOUNTABLE
ALSO YOU MENTIONED THAT SOME
COUNTIES HAVE COMMITTED PLANTS
BUT NOT ALL HAVE. SO HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THIS IS AN EQUITABLE
PROCESSES FOR ALL ND NOT JUST
FOR SOME OUT THERE- AND THE
REALITY IS THAT. MAYBE MORE THAN
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IS
NEEDED AT THE END OF THE DAY I
AND THAT'S A REALITY THAT WE
NEED TO FACE AND BE READY FOR
BUT HAVING A CARE PLAN THAT THAT
IS COMPREHENSIVE IS IMPORTANT
AND IT IT. IT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE.
WE'RE WE'RE MOVING IN THAT
DIRECTION I FEEL THAT WITH THAT
I MONEY. TOWARD SOMETHING THAT
MAYBE IS GOING TO REPEAT A LOT
OF WHAT WE ALREADY HAVE. WELL I
PUBLIC THINGS IN RESPONSE THAT
I'M SORRY IF I GAVE YOU THE
IMPRESSION THAT NOT ALL COUNTY
SUBMITTED PLANS THEY ABSOLUTELY
DID. I JUST REFERENCE THAT I'VE
REVIEWED SEVERAL AND NOT ALL ON
BUT ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES DID
SUBMIT THEIR IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
TO THE OFFICE OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION. AND IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT A Y. C. R.
WILL BE MEETING WITH EACH AND
EVERY COUNTY TO REVIEW THOSE
PLANS TO BETTER UNDERSTAND- WHAT
THEY HAVE IN MIND AND DID BEGIN
THIS I THINK. REALLY IMPORTANT
PRACTICE OF ENSURING THAT- THAT
COUNTIES HAVE ACCESS TO OUR
ADVICE ON BEST PRACTICES TRAUMA
INFORMED APPROACHES AND SO ON
AND SO FORTH- I GUESS IT WOULD
BE. YOU KNOW CERTAINLY POSSIBLE
THAT WE COULD ALL COME TO
AGREEMENT THAT. A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR COUNTY
FACILITY NEEDS ISN'T SUFFICIENT
BUT- I'M JUST MOST CONCERNED
ABOUT THE- URGENT NEED TO MAKE
SOME OF THESE IMPROVEMENTS. SO
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE WHO- ARE CAN
BE APPROPRIATELY PLACED IN THE
COUNTY JUVENILE FACILITY THAT
THAT OPTION EXISTS AND THAT
JUDGES AND DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
AND PROBATION DEPARTMENTS- ARE
ABLE TO HAVE THAT OPTION. AS
OPPOSED TO INCREASING TRANSFERS
TO ADULT COURT. BOB THIS IS VERY
MUCH YOU KNOW INSTEAD OF BEING
MAJOR IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES
THAT ARE ALL IN FLUX. AND THE
FACILITY NEEDS HAVE EMERGED AS
ONE OF THE. MORE TIME SENSITIVE
ONES. IT'S INTERESTING THAT THE
MERCH AS TIME SENSITIVE ONE
WHEN. THE INITIAL NEGOTIATIONS-
DID NOT INCLUDE. INFRASTRUCTURE
RESOURCES BECAUSE THERE WASN'T
THERE WAS NOT ENOUGH DATA- THAN.
I IN THE PLANS THAT THE COUNTY
SOMETHING ADDED I DON'T THINK
HAVE. DO MUCH. WITH THE
FACILITIES EITHER. AND SO I JUST
WORRY THAT SEVENTEEN MONTHS WILL
BE HERE QUICK- I UNDERSTAND THE
SHORT WINDOW OF TIME AND I
UNDERSTAND THE GRAVITY IN THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE WORK THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE. IT'S NOT CLEAR TO ME
THAT WE ARE PRIORITIZING THE
ACTUAL WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE VERSUS. TO SAYING WE DID
SOMETHING. I AND SO LET'S DO
THIS- AND SO THAT'S THAT'S MY
CONCERN THERE. I DON'T KNOW YOU
WANT TO COMMENT ON THAT- WELL I
MEAN I CERTAINLY AGREE WITH YOU
THAT THAT THERE ARE NUMEROUS
COMPETING PRIORITIES THAT NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED TO ENSURE
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS AND- HE FOR THIS
CONVERSATION TODAY ON WATER THAT
DEFICIENCIES IN FACILITIES AND
IT IS SOME OF WHAT FRANKIE WAS
MINE MENTIONED YOU KNOW A MORE
RESTRICTIVE AND- JAIL LIKE
ENVIRONMENT FOR YOUTH WILL WHERE
POSSIBLE BUT THE GOLAN THE HOPE
IS TO STOP IN THOSE ENVIRONMENTS
MAKE THEM MORE HOME LIKE- AND
ALSO PAY ATTENTION TO THE OVER
ARCHING POLICY GOAL OF. LEAST
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT- BUT I
THINK IT'S JUST IMPORTANT KEEP
IN MIND THAT YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE A
VARIETY OF PROGRAMMING AND
TREATMENT AND REHABILITATIVE
NEEDS THAT THAT HAVE TO BE BACK
. WHEN I AGREE WITH THE LAST
PART OF YOUR STATEMENT I'M NOT
CONVINCED THAT THIS HUNDRED
MILLION IN INFRASTRUCTURE. IS
ADDRESSING THAT LAST PART OF
YOUR STATEMENT I THINK WE DO
SHARE THE COMMON GOAL I THINK
IT'S THE QUESTION IS ARE WE
INVEST IN A WAY THAT GETS US TO
THAT COMMON GOAL AND I'M NOT
CONVINCED OF THAT. AT AT THIS
POINT. MR STILL. THANK YOU AND
JUST TO REITERATE WITH THE
CHAIRED SAID NGUYEN THE PROPOSAL
FIRST CAME TO US THROUGH THERE
WAS. IN THIS COMMITTEE A LOT OF
SUPPORT FOR. REFORMING DJJ BUT I
THINK SOME CONCERN ABOUT WHAT
THE IMPLEMENTATION WAS THAT AND
I THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
HEARING. HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
TO ME LOOKING AT STATEWIDE NEEDS
PROBABLY DOESN'T SOUND LIKE
ENOUGH AND THIS IS JUST THE
BUDGET WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BUDGETING MONEY SO WHAT THE
ULTIMATELY IMPORTANT HERE.
BEFORE THAT MONEY GETS SPENT IS
UNDERSTANDING THE PROCESS. AND
LAST YEAR WE WENT AROUND AND
AROUND WITH THE- I SEE ARE AND
WHAT OUR EXPECTATION OF THEIR
MISSION IS AND HOW THEY ARE
GOING TO FUNCTION. WITHIN THE
STATE IN FACT WE WANTED TO SPEND
MORE MONEY WITH THE YC R. THAN
THAT HAD BEEN PROPOSED AND THE
REASON IS. THAT IF THAT AGENCY
IS NOT. IS NOT CREATED TO HAVE
THE STRENGTH THE RESEARCH
ABILITY THE ABILITY REALLY TO
LAY OUT BEST PRACTICES AND-
WHAT'S GOOD INCENTIVES ARE GOOD
OPTIONS IN FRONT OF COUNTIES TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE COUNTIES AND
ARE ARE IMPLEMENTING THOSE THEN
WE'RE JUST KIND OF PERPETUATING
AT A LOCAL LEVEL WHAT HAD BEEN
DEVELOPED AT THE STATEWIDE LEVEL
THAT'S NOT REALLY SERVING THE
KIDS SO IT'S I THINK THE
FRUSTRATION HERE. IS AROUND THE
TIMING OF THE WAY THE PROCESS
COMES TOGETHER THAT IF WE ARE
JUST HAVING A PART OF MONEY IN
THE DESIRING TO SPEND IT. THE
OUTCOMES ARE UNCERTAIN. AND WE
COULD HAVE CREATED SOMETHING
HERE THAT WILL BE DETRIMENTAL TO
OUR KIDS. IF THE IF PART OF THIS
IS IT WILL I'M NOT SURE IT'S
CLEAR FOR US THE ROLE OF- I SEE
ARE THROUGH THIS PROCESS. AND
THE GOAL WITH CREATING OVERSEE
OUR WAS WAS FOR US SINCE WE
WEREN'T NECESSARILY GOING TO BE
THIS ABOUT A PROBLEM WITH
REALIGNMENT ACROSS THE BOARD.
MANDATING CERTAIN PROGRAMS WORK
THAT SINCE WE'RE ALLOWING THE
COUNTIES TO DO THE
IMPLEMENTATION. WE THEN ARE
INCENTIVIZING CAJOLING CREATING
SOME. OPPORTUNITIES FOR COUNTIES
TO SEE WHERE THEIR BEST
OPPORTUNITIES ARE. THIS IS A LOT
OF MONEY I'M NOT SURE IT'S GOING
TO BE ENOUGH MONEY BUT THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF THE
INCENTIVES. THAT WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO SEE IS OKAY COUNTIES YOU
WANT TO BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
SOMETHING. WE NEED TO KNOW THAT
YOU'RE IMPLEMENTATION IS IT IS
THIS VISION OF. BEST
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUTH FOR
THEIR DEVELOPMENT FOR THEIR
FUTURE HOW DOES YOUR PROGRAM HOW
DOES YOUR PLAN. FIT THE STATE'S
ULTIMATE GOAL AND IF IT DOES
THEN YES COUNTIES ARE GOING TO
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO DO THESE
KINDS OF INVESTMENTS THE STATE
IS GOING TO HAVE TO STEP IN AND
PROVIDE THOSE KINDS OF. THAT
THAT HELP FOR THOSE INVESTMENTS
. BUT IT THEY NEED TO BE WE NEED
TO HAVE THE CONFIDENCE. THAT
THOSE COUNTY PROGRAMS ARE
BENEFITING THE KIDS THE WAY THAT
WE ARE VISITING AND SO I THINK
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE HEARING HERE
WIT WITH THE CONCERNED AND A
LITTLE BIT OF. IS THE TIMING AND
WE SEEM TO OFTEN WHERE THERE'S
LARGE PARTS OF MONEY EVERYBODY
WANTS US POTS OF MONEY. WE FIND
WAYS TO GET OUT THE DOOR.
THERE'S TOO MUCH AT STAKE HERE
WITH THESE KIDS TO DO THAT TOO
QUICKLY SO I THINK THIS
COMMITTEE. WOULD BE BETTER
SERVED UNDERSTANDING THE VARIOUS
ROLES HERE UNDERSTANDING WHAT
SOME OF THE CONSTRAINTS ARE WHAT
SOME OF THE CONVERSATIONS ARE
WHAT THE COUNTY'S PLANS ARE. AND
THESE ARE GOING TO BE NOT
NECESSARILY COUNTY BY COUNTY
FACILITIES BECAUSE SOME OF OUR
SMALL COUNTIES ARE NOT GOING TO
HAVE. THE RESOURCES TO BE BLE
TO DEVELOP AND MANAGE SOME OF
SOME OF WHAT THE THEIR
OBLIGATIONS ARE GOING TO BE IT
WILL NEED TO BE ON A REGIONAL
BASIS. AND SO FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT SOME WHAT'S
GOING TO BE REGIONAL WHAT'S
GOING TO BE SPECIFIC COUNTY
WHICH COUNTIES ARE GOING TO GET
WHAT. TELL WHAT THOSE RESOURCES
ARE SO THAT WE CAN PROVIDE. NOT
NECESSARILY EQUALLY BUT
EQUITABLY ACROSS THE STATE THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EVERY KID IN
EVERY COUNTY. TO HAVE THE SAME
ABILITY. TO ADDRESS WHATEVER IT
IS THEY THEY NEED TO ADDRESS TO
BECOME PRODUCTIVE TO GET OUT OF
THE SYSTEM. BACK INTO SCHOOL
BACK INTO JOBS BACK INTO OUR
COMMUNITY IN A PRODUCTIVE WAY.
SO I THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
HEARING FROM ME PERSONALLY. THE
HUNDRED MILLION SOUNDS LIKE A
BIG NUMBER I THINK IN THE END
IT'S PROBABLY NOT GOING TO BE
ENOUGH BUT WHAT'S MOST
IMPORTANT. IS THAT WE UNDERSTAND
THE PROCESS BY WHICH THESE
GRANTS ARE BEING. ARTICULATED
BEING DEVELOPED AND THEN BEING
AWARDED AND THEN WHAT THE
ACCOUNTABILITY IS. SO I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S REALLY WHAT THE
FRUSTRATION IS THAT YOU'RE
HEARING. WE WANT YOU WE NEED YOU
TO DO WITH HOW. WE ACROSS THE
BOARD WITH ALL OF THESE. BUT WE
ALSO NEED TO UNDERSTAND AWAY SEE
OURS ROLE. EN SUITE WHAT THEIR
VISION IS THAT THEY'RE JUST
GETTING THAT STARTED. SO THINK
THE CAUTION IS. NOT TO DO THIS
TOO QUICKLY EVEN THOUGH I
UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO MOVE
QUICKLY ON THIS IN THE POSITION
THAT THE COUNTIES ARE IN BUT WE
ALSO HAVE TO BE CLEAR THAT WHAT
WE'RE INVESTING IN THROUGH THIS
PROCESS. MEATS ARE UNDERLYING
GOALS HERE. THE MANAGER MY
RESPONSE. YES THANK YOU-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE I THINK
YOUR COMMENTS WERE VERY WELL
TAKEN- THE TIME URGENCY AS WE'VE
SPOKEN ABOUT A COUPLE OF TIMES
REALLY HAS TO DO WITH THE FACT
THAT IN SEVENTEEN MONTHS
COUNTIES ARE GOING TO NEED TO
HAVE- LET'S HOPE-
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
TRAUMA INFORMED CULTURALLY
SENSITIVE EVIDENCE BASED-
OPTIONS AS THEY ARE- YOU KNOW
APPEARING BEFORE THE JUVENILE
COURT- I JUST WANTED TO MENTION
ONE OTHER THING AND I'M THE
ALLEY- MENTIONED- THE TOPIC OF
THE FACT THAT IT IS. IT'S
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT NOT EVERY
COUNTY ACROSS OUR FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. HAS JUVENILE DETENTION
FACILITIES THERE ABSOLUTELY WILL
BE A VARIETY OF COUNTIES THAT
NEED TO WORK WITH LET'S HOPE
MAJOR NEIGHBORING COUNTIES OR
OR- YOU KNOW REGIONS WITHIN THE
STATE BUT IT'S FIGHT WE CAN
PROVIDE A LIST- TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE STAFF WITH THEIR
FIFTEEN COUNTIES IN THE STATE.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY JUVENILE
DETENTION FACILITY SO I USE THAT
AS ONE EXAMPLE OF I THINK IT
WOULD BE ABSOLUTELY DOABLE TO
HAVE SOME. POLICY GUIDANCE PUT
IN ALONG WITH THIS FINDING THAT
REFLECTS WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND WHAT THIS BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE IS CONCERNED ABOUT.
ABOUT ENSURING THAT THE FUNDING
IS INVESTED IN ALL OF THE POLICY
GOALS THAT ARE. WOVEN THROUGH SB
EIGHT TWENTY THREE I THINK IT'S
COMPLETELY DOABLE AND I'LL JUST
SAY AGAIN THE TIME URGENCY COMES
FROM THE FACT THAT- DJJ IS
CLOSING IN THE VERY NEAR FUTURE
SELF. THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS. ANYONE ELSE- FIFTY TWO
PLEASE LISTEN TO THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE AND MYSELF WE HAVE
COMMON GOALS BUT THIS PROPOSAL
THE SAN. WE'RE NOT CONVINCED
THAT THIS PROPOSAL GETS US TO
OUR COMMON GOALS AND THAT WERE
BEING- PRUDENT WITH OUR WITH OUR
INVESTMENT- AND SO I DO HOPE WE
HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
AND- A BETTER APPROACH COME
COMEY. THANK YU FOR WE'RE GONNA
GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN OUR GUN BUYBACK
PROGRAM. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
KATIE HOWARD AGAIN FOR THE BST
STEAM- I WANTED TO GET AGAIN IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME IS SUPER
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THIS PROPOSAL
ON IT IS THAT IT'S PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S- PACKAGE ON SOME-
PUBLIC SAFETY- ENHANCEMENTS THAT
ARE IN THE BUDGET THIS YEAR THE
GUN BUYBACK PROPOSAL IS. TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS- ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND- AND I ALSO FOUGHT
YOUR- AGENDA LAID OUT THE
ISSUES- REALLY WELL- AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE HAS
RAISED SOME SIMILAR CONCERNS
ABOUT. HOW WILL WE KNOW IF SUCH
A PROGRAM IS SUCCESSFUL- IT
CALLS IN OBJECTIVES ARE NOT
SPELLED OUT SO. I WOULD
ANTICIPATE THAT THERE WOULD
ABSOLUTELY BE NOT ONLY THE NEED
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO MORE
SPECIFICALLY STATE GOALS FOR
THIS PROGRAM AS WE CONTINUE TO
MOVE THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS.
I KNOW THAT YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MANY OF THE- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
YOU'RE ALREADY FAMILIAR WITH
THE- EXTENSIVE GRANT
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT. THE PSEC
IS USING. YES YOU SEE HOW. AND-
IF I MAY I THINK WE DO A- GOOD
JOB WHEN WE HAVE A NEW GRANT
PROGRAM TO BRING SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS TO THE TABLE- FROM A
WIDE VARIETY OF BACKGROUNDS- AND
DISCIPLINES AND LIVED
EXPERIENCES SOMEONE. SO DOWN THE
ROAD AFTER SOME MORE SPECIFIC
CALLS MIGHT BE SPELLED OUT BY
THE LEGISLATURE THAT EXECUTIVE
STEERING COMMITTEE THAT BUILDS
THE GRANT- ITSELF THE REQUEST
FOR PROPOSALS AND SCORING
CRITERIA AND ALL OF THAT- THERE
WOULD BE ALL OF THE- NECESSARY
ACCOUNTABILITY IN PLACE SO. THAT
THIS INVESTMENT IN- YOU KNOW.
INSURING GUNS ARE- THAT WE HAVE
A REDUCTION IN GUNS AND THAT WE
HAVE A BETTER ABILITY TO EDUCATE
YOUNG PEOPLE ABOUT ON THE
DANGERS OF GUNS AND GUN
VIOLENCE- WE CAN GET TO SOME
SHARED GOALS- AGREEMENT ON WHAT
THE SHARED GOALS SHOULD BE A
BUSY SEASON A REALLY GOOD
POSITION TO IMPLEMENT A NEW
CRAFT PROGRAM SO I KNOW WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR ABOUT THE LACK OF
SPECIFICITY- IN THIS PROPOSAL
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO TALK FURTHER
ON. HOW TO GET THIS IN SHAPE
THAT THIS SUBCOMMITTEE IS MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH. AND IT I NEED
ONLY WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- MISS HOWARD
DID PREVIOUS OVER COMMENTS FOR
YOU- AND SO THIS PROPOSAL IS ONE
OF NINE TOTAL PROPOSAL THAT MAKE
UP THE GOVERNOR'S PUBLIC SAFETY
PACKAGE- WE DID RAISE CONCERNS
WITH ABOUT SEVEN OF THEM AND
RECENTLY REPORT. RELEASED A
REPORT THAT OFFERS A FRAMEWORK
FOR LEGISLATIVE DELIBERATION OF
THE PACKAGE IN IT IN TOTAL. AS
WELL AS OPTIONS FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION- MY COMMENTS TODAY
ARE GONNA FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON
FIREARMS AND THIS PROPOSAL. SO
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO THIS
PROPOSAL. WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
THIS PROPOSED GRANT PROGRAM
ALONG WITH A COUPLE OF OTHER-
BUT YOU'LL BE HEARING AT A LATER
HEARING. WOULD PROVIDE THE SEC
WITH SIGNIFICANT IMPLEMENTATION
OF FORTY AFTER THE BUDGET IS
ENACTED. SO BECAUSE OF THIS IT
IS CURRENTLY UNCLEAR HOW THE
FUNDING WOULD BE ALLOCATED AND
USED AND IT'S DIFFICULT TO
ASSESS WHETHER THE PROGRAMS
WOULD ACTUALLY BE EFFECTIVE. SO
FOR EXAMPLE WITH GUN BUYBACKS.
THEY CAN BE TARGETED TO ADDRESS
DIFFERENT PURPOSES SUCH AS TO
REDUCE FIREARM SUICIDE OR TO
REDUCE THE FIREARM CRIME RELATED
VIOLENCE. SO IF THE GOAL IS TO
REDUCE FIREARM CRIME RELATED
VIOLENCE RESEARCH ACTUALLY
SHOULDN'T SUGGESTS. THAT THESE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS ARE MORE
EFFECTIVE AT THEIR STRUCTURE IN
PARTICULAR WAY. SUCH AS
REQUIRING THAT FIREARMS BE
WORKING. IN ORDER TO RECEIVE AN
INCENTIVE PRIORITIZING THE TYPES
OF FIREARMS THAT ARE GENERALLY
USED IN CRIMES. AND OR FOCUSING
ON THE TYPES OF INDIVIDUALS OR
LOCATIONS THAT ARE MORE PRONE TO
FIRE OF VIOLENCE. BUT AT THIS
POINT IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER OR
NOT THAT WOULD BE PART. OF- THIS
PROPOSAL. MORE BROADLY WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE THINKING THE ENTIRE
SAFETY PACKAGE WE DO RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE DETERMINE
ITS HIGHEST PRIORITY PUBLIC
SAFETY GALS. SPECIFIED CLEAR
OBJECTIVES TO ACHIEVE THOSE
GOALS AND THEN PROVIDE THE
FUNDING IN A MANNER THAT
ACTUALLY ENSURES THAT THOSE
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES ARE
ACHIEVED. SO IN TERMS OF
THINKING ABOUT THOSE HIGHEST
PRIORITY PUBLIC SAFETY GOALS
THEY MAY OR MAY NOT INCLUDE
FIREARMS. IF THE LEGISLATURE IS
INTERESTED IN PRIORITIZING
CERTAIN FIREARM RELATED POLLS.
DATA DOES INDICATE THAT THERE
HAS BEEN A GROWTH IN HOMICIDE
FIREARM DEATHS AS WELL AS AN
INCREASE IN THE SHARE OF
HOMICIDES AGGRAVATED ASSAULTS
AND ROBBERIES THAT INVOLVED
FIREARMS. ADDITIONALLY AS OF
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE THEY
WERE NEARLY TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS
ON THE STATE'S ARMED AND
PROHIBITED PERSONS LAST- THIS
COMMITTEE HAS HEARD OF THEM
BEFORE THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO
SUBSEQUENTLY BECOME PROHIBITED
FROM POSSESSING- FIREARMS OR
AMMUNITION THAT THEY HAD LEGALLY
PURCHASED AFTER THEY ARE
CONVICTED OF. FELONIES OR
CERTAIN MISDEMEANORS FOUND BY A
COURT TO BE A DANGER TO
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS DUE TO
MENTAL ILLNESS. OR HAVE A
RESTRAINING ORDER AGAINST THEM
AND RESEARCH HAS INDICATED THAT
FARM PRINT PROHIBITIONS AGAINST
SOME OF THESE INDIVIDUALS CAN
HELP DECREASE VIOLENT CRIME OR
HOMICIDE. AS HIGHLIGHTED IN YOUR
AGENDA WE'VE HIGHLIGHTED- TWO
OPTIONS. THAT COULD HELP ADDRESS
FIREARM RELATED GOALS- IF IT'S A
PRIORITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
THE FIRST ONE IS. THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED TEN MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
LAST YEAR- AS PART OF THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET FOR DOJ'S GUN
VIOLENCE REDUCTION PROGRAM. TO
ENABLE COUNTY SHERIFF'S TO HELP
REDUCE THE ARMED AND PROHIBITED
PERSONS LIST BY SEIZING FIREARMS
AND AMMUNITION FROM THOSE WHO
SHOULDN'T HAVE THEM. SO THE
LEGISLATURE IS INTERESTED IN
FURTHER REDUCING THE NUMBER ON
THIS LIST IT COULD PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO THIS
PROGRAMME. AND MAKE OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES SUCH AS THE
CITY POLICE ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
THE GRANTS. THE SECOND OPTION IS
OF THE LEGISLATURE WANTS TO
LIMIT THE GROWTH OF THE ARMED
AND PROHIBITED PERSONS LAST AND
THAT WOULD BE TO PROVIDE FUNDING
TO LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS. TO ENSURE THAT
FIREARMS ARE RELINQUISHED AT THE
TIME INDIVIDUALS ARE GOING
THROUGH THE COURT PROCEEDINGS
WHERE THEY'RE ULTIMATELY
DETERMINES- TICKET. THERE
ULTIMATELY PROHIBITED FROM
OWNING THOSE FIREARMS. SO THAT
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU. JUST A MOMENT
THE FINANCE HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I WE JUST
WANTED TO REITERATE WHAT MISS
HOWARD INITIALLY SAIDTHAT WE
THE ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES THAT
THAT GUN BUYBACK PROGRAM IS.
SORT OF A COMPREHENSIVE MULTI
PRONGED. COMPONENT OF REDUCING
GUN VIOLENCE IN CALIFORNIA-
COINCIDING WITH YOU KNOW VARIOUS
PROPOSED LEGISLATION LIKE AB
FIFTEEN NINETY FOUR AB TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY ONE OR AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY ONE JUST KIND OF. THE
COMMENT THAT THE ISSUE OF GUN
VIOLENCE FROM AS MANY ANGLES AS
POSSIBLE I WE DO ALSO WANT TO
NOTE THAT THE EXISTING LANGUAGE
IN THE PROPOSED GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET REQUIRES A 10% CASH OR IN
KIND MATCH. FROM PARTICIPATING
GRANTEES AND THAT- INCENTIVES
MAY BE PROVIDED FOR FOLKS THAT
RELINQUISHING FUNCTIONAL
FIREARMS AND THE ADMINISTRATION
IS MORE THAN HAPPY TO CONTINUE
LEGISLATURE AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS THE KIND OF ENSURE THAT
THIS PROGRAM IS EFFECTIVE IT'S
POSSIBLE IT REDUCING THE NUMBER
OF GUNS IN CALIFORNIA. I'M MORE. THAN HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. I THANK YOU
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION I KNOW.
ARE THESE BUY BACK PROGRAMS. DO
NOT ALWAYS REQUIRE THAT THESE
GUNS BE DESTROYED- SOMETIMES
THEY SHOW UP ON THE AUCTION
BLOCK WITH THIS PROPOSAL DO YOU
ARE YOU PLANNING TO INCLUDE THE
REQUIREMENT THAT ALL GUNS
COLLECTED BE DESTROYED UNLESS
THEY'RE FOUND TO BE PART OF
EVIDENCE IN A CASE. THIS IS
KATIE HOW ARE WITH THE BSE SEEKS
. NOT YET GOTTEN INTO THAT LEVEL
OF DETAIL IN- BUILDING OUT THE
PROPOSAL BUT THAT IS THE SORT OF
THING THAT CERTAINLY COULD BE
ADDED- AND PROFESSIONAL LANGUAGE
AS PART OF THE BUDGET. SO BACK
TO JUST A AND THOSE DETAILS
REALLY MATTER THIS IS A DETAIL
THAT IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR OUR
ULTIMATE GOAL IN ADDITION TO AS
WE HEARD FROM. THE ALLEY- OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT BE MIGHT BE MORE
BENEFICIAL AND ACTUALLY TAKING
GUNS A- OFF THE STREETS OUT
THERE AND THAT INVESTMENT AS
WELL- AND SO WOULD JUST
ENCOURAGE THAT THAT A MINIMUM.
WE INCLUDE THAT PIECE. IN THIS
VENTURE PRESSURED MR LACKEY F.
YES SOME. IN THE PAST WE'VE BEEN
TOLD BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AT THE PACE GOLDFRAPP'S
INVESTIGATORS IS INSUFFICIENT TO
ATTRACT ENOUGH STAFF. IS ANY OF
THE REQUESTED FUNDING EXPECTED
EXPECTED TO ADDRESS THE NEED TO.
INCREASE THE PAY FOR THOSE
NEEDED. TO FILL THESE APPS
INVESTIGATED POSITIONS BECAUSE
HERE'S MY FRUSTRATION WE HAVE.
IDENTIFIED AS OF JANUARY.
412-300-0600 ILLEGALLY ARMED
PERSONS. THAT'S A HUGE LIABILITY
THAT AND IT'S BEEN AN
UNMANAGEABLE NUMBER SINCE I'VE
BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE WE DON'T
IT'S GROWING IT'S NOT GETTING
ANY BETTER. AND WE HAVE THIS POT
OF MONEY THAT WE'RE GOING TO-
SUPPOSEDLY ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
BUT GUN BUY BACK DOESN'T DISARM
THESE PEOPLE. SO MUCH MY
QUESTION IS WHAT ARE WE DOING TO
FIX THIS OF. THIS HUGE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE THREATENING OUR
PUBLIC. THAT'S IT THAT'S MY
QUESTION I GUESS MORE
SPECIFICALLY AS ANY OF THE MONEY
. ARE CONSIDERED TO BE- FUNNELED
TOWARDS THE INCREASE TO PAY. FOR
INSTIGATORS. I'M SORRY I SAID
NOT AT THIS TIME. THAT'S IT
SEEMS TO ME LIKE THAT WOULD BE A
LOGICAL CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
. YOUR. THANK YOU MR LACKEY-
EIGHTY WITH MR LIKE IS COMMON IS
JUST- IS THIS THE BEST WAY FOR
US TO REACH OUR GOAL OF
ELIMINATING GUNS ON THE STREET
ARE THERE ADDITIONAL WAYS TO DO
THROUGH POLICY OR OTHER
INVESTMENTS US THIS LUCKY IF IS
BRINGING UP I KNOW THAT THIS
PROGRAM MIGHT BE A FILL THE
PROGRAM- BUT IT'S NOT SURE THAT
WE'RE ACTUALLY GETTING THEIR
MONEY'S WORTH AT THE END OF THE
DAY- IT IF WE HAVE BETTER WAYS
TO DO THIS SPECIALLY WHEN THE
FUNDS ARE NOT BEING DESTROYED.
AND EVERYTHING BEING PUT BACK UP
ON THE AUCTION BLOCK- AND SIZE
BEST DISCUSSIONS CONTINUE ON
THIS PIECE OF WE COULD PLEASE
SUPPLEMENT WITH ADDITIONAL
THINGS THAT WE COULD DO BEYOND.
THIS GUN BY PROGRAM. GUN BUY
BACK PROGRAM- IF THERE ARE NO
MORE FOR QUESTIONS THAT WAS OUR
LAST ISSUE AND I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND THANK OUR PANELISTS
FOR BEING HERE TODAY AND MOVE ON
TO PUBLIC COMMENT. THERE IS NO
ONE IN THE ROOM FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. SO I WILL MOVE ON TO
THE- TELEPHONE FEATURES AND HAS
UP TO ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT TO THE COMMITTEE IS ON
THE WEBSITE. IT'S ALSO ON THE
SCREEN OF YOUR STREAMING THIS
HEARING BUT JUST IN CASE THE
TOLL FREE NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. 1-487-769-2895 SEVEN. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN.
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY PEOPLE
ON THE PHONE. WE DO IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
TODAY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. IN THAT COMMAND AGAIN IS.
ONE SEVEN ZERO. OUR FIRST PUBLIC
COMMENT COMES FROM LINE FORTY
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MORGAN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MARIE WASHBURN WITH THE
CENTER ON JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE. WE'VE BEEN MONITORING
DJJ FOR YEARS AND WE'RE DEEPLY
CONCERNED RIGHT NOW ABOUT YOUTH
WELL BEING. BETWEEN KOBE THE
STOCK IN CRISIS AND THE FACILITY
CLOSURE RECINE CONDITIONS. 78%
OF YOU CONTRACTED CODED AS PART
OF THE MOST RECENT SURGE- AND
BECAUSE THE- INVADING
CHALLENGES. EVR IS PROJECTING
THERE WILL STILL BE NEARLY FIVE
HUNDRED USED IN BJJ IN YOUR ACT-
WE URGE YOU TO CLOSELY EXAMINE
THESE PROJECTIONS AND START
SENDING IT HOME THANK YOU. X. WE
WILL GO TO LINE FIFTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON DANIEL SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA A WE
SUPPORT ISSUE SIX REGARDING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
INVEST A HUNDRED MILLION AT
EIGHT TWENTY JUVENILE FACILITIES
A SPEECH REALIGNMENT OF THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE CONTINUE ON THE
COUNTY. THIS ONE TIME FUNDING IS
INTENDED TO TRANSFORM CURRENT
SPACE TO SUPPORT A MORE POSITIVE
ENVIRONMENT IN EXISTING
FACILITIES CAN BE USED TO MAKE
THE FAITH WE CURRENTLY HAVE MORE
RESPONSIVE TO THE LONGER TERM
POPULATION HAS REALIGNED.
EXAMPLES OF THIS MAY INCLUDE
ADDING GREEN SPACE FOR
RECREATION AND OUTDOOR
ACTIVITIES AND TRAINING CREATING
MORE HOME LIKE LIVING SPACES AT
THE DINNER CREATING PROGRAMMING
ROOM DECORATION AROUND.
EDUCATIONAL TRAINING EIGHT. THIS
NEEDS WILL LOOK TO DEPEND ON
THE- I WHAT IF YOU HAVE A- IS
THE KIND WE AND THE TO SUPPORT
RELYING YOU'D KERN. IN OUR CARE
. WHAT THIS PROPOSAL. THAT WERE
COURT DETERMINES THAT A SECURE
TRACK IF NECESSARY THAT THESE
FACILITIES SPACES IN WHICH THAT
YOU PROVIDE WILL RECEIVING YOUTH
CENTER PROGRAMMING AND SERVICES
SHOULD BACK MEET THE
REHABILITATIVE AND SEATING THANK
YOU. WE LOOK FORWARD TO MORE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE COMMITTEE
ON THE SPECIFIC NEEDS IDENTIFIED
AND LOCAL PLANS AND WORKING
TOGETHER ON EFFECTUATED- AND
OUTLINING A PROCESS- THAT
RECOGNIZES- BOTH THE NEED AND
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND I DO
APPRECIATE THAT RECOGNITION THAT
THE NEED BABY EVEN GREATER THAN
THAT- AND WE WANNA CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER ON EFFECTUATE. IN
THE SHARED GOAL THANK YOU. AN
LINE SIXTY. HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTY I LIVE IN SAN JOSE I AM
WITH CURRENT CALIFORNIANS UNITED
FOR RESPONSIBLE BUDGET AND I AM
A MOTHER WHO HAS WORKED WITH AT
RISK YOUTH. REGARDING ISSUE
NUMBER SIXTY ONE AUTHORITY
GRANTED RECOMMEND NO SHOULD THE
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL RIGHT NOW THIS ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL
IS AN EXAMPLE OF BAD POLICY
MAKING THE DOLLAR AMOUNT
REFLECTS NO RESEARCH NO
STATEMENT NEED NOT RATIONAL
THINKING THIS PROPOSAL WOULD NOT
MORE MONEY TO GET OUT
CORRECTIONAL MODEL THAT WE KNOW
HARM YOUNG PEOPLE INSTEAD WE
SHOULD INVEST TIME AND RESOURCES
INTO GETTING THAT'S RIGHT.
RESEARCH THE NEEDS OF YOUNG
PEOPLE RESEARCH THE CAPACITY OF
COUNTY MEET THAT NEED ON THE
STRATEGY THAT MEETS THE NEEDS OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY I THANK
THIS COMMITTEE FOR THE WORK THAT
THEY DO- AND. I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU DO THANK YOU HAVE A GOOD DAY
. WYNESS. FOUR GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS BRIANNA CHRYSLER AND THE
U. KWON POLICY ATTORNEY AT FIVE
NOBODY KNOWS THAT I LOVE AND I
HAVE NOW AND I AM CALLING TODAY
TO SAY NO PLEASE VOTE NO ON THE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
PROBATION AND COURT LOCAL
FACILITIES I AM A FORMERLY
INCARERATED YOUNG PERSON IN
THESE COUNTY FACILITIES AND
TODAY AS AN ADVOCATE I'VE BEEN.
VERY DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THAT
THESE FACILITIES HAD THE SAME
ISSUE THAT THEY DID WHEN I WAS A
YOUNG PERSON WHO IS INCARCERATED
SB EIGHT TWENTY THREE CALLED FOR
TREATMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND TRAUMA
BASED NEEDS ARE SERVICES THAT
PROMOTE HEALTHY ADOLESCENT
DEVELOPMENT FAMILY ENGAGEMENT
TRAUMA INFORMED CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE PROGRAMMING NONE OF
THIS IS BEST SERVED ANY JAIL
LIKE FACILITIES THESE ARE
SERVICES THAT ARE PASSED ON IN
THE COMMUNITY CONNECTED WITH
COMMUNITY BASED. HEALTH BASED
RESEARCH BASED CERVANTES AND
THEY'RE NOT PERFECT AND THAT CAN
HAPPEN IN A IN A PRISON LIKE
FACILITY IF YOU INVEST MONEY
INTO THESE COUNTY FACILITIES ARE
YOU'RE KNOCKING ME CLOSING YOUTH
PRISONS ARE GOING TO BE BUILDING
THEM AT THE COUNTY LEVEL NAY
URGE YOU NOT TO ACCEPT. THIS
INVESTMENT THANK YOU. LINUS.
THREE LINE SIXTY THREE OR MY
COULD OPEN. LINE. SIXTY SIX.
GOOD EVENING AND THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT MY NAME
IS MEREDITH THAT THE TELL I AM A
RESIDENT OF SAN FRANCISCO AND A
STAFF ATTORNEY WITH THE YOUTH
LAWCENTER WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
PROPOSAL TO SPEND A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ON LOCK UP
FACILITIES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IT'S
SIMPLY AN INAPPROPRIATE USE OF
PUBLIC FUNDS WITH NO RESEARCHER
ANALYSIS TO JUSTIFY THE SPENDING
AND NO STRINGS ATTACHED TO
ENSURE IT ACTUALLY LEAD TO
BETTER OUTCOMES FOR YOUTH AND
COMMUNITIES. IN TWENTY TWENTY
CALIFORNIA TOOK A BOLD STEP OF
CLOSING YOUTH PRISONS AND
SHIFTING JUVENILE JUSTICE TO A
PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH ONE
HUNDRED MILLION PROPOSAL MOVED
IN THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION BY
INVESTING IN A FAILED PUNISHMENT
MODEL WE SHOULD NOT WASTE MORE
MONEY ON YOUTH LOCKED INSTEAD WE
MUST INVEST IN THE FULL
CONTINUUM OF PROGRAMS NEEDED FOR
HEALTHY AND POSITIVE YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT AT CALLED. FOR UNDER
STATE LAW THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY
TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON ONE OF
PUBLIC AMENITIES RIDE WE ARE
CURRENTLY THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
WITH CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY JUSTICE I
WOULD LIKE TO GIVE PROMINENCE TO
ISSUE ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
REGARDING BJ'S BUDGET WE ARE
AWARE OF EXTENDED LOCKDOWNS IN
UNITS BE COMBINED IN THE MIDDLE
OF CALL VISIT WHERE WHERE THAT
UTAH COMPLAIN ABOUT NOT
RECEIVING ADEQUATE FULL BEING
HUNGRY AS WELL AS STAFF ON YOUTH
BILIC'S. THIS IS A DIRECT RESULT
OF TOO MANY YOUTH THEY'RE NOT
AND NOT ENOUGH STAFF SHOWING UP
TO WORK AT THE SENATE BUDGET
HEARING WE HEARD FROM THE
GEORGIA PROJECTION OF TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY USED TO WILL
REMAIN NOW THAT MINISTER JIM
PRENTICE PROJECTING THAT FIVE
HUNDRED YOU WILL REMAIN AT THE
CHEN TAKE UNTIL ITS DOORS CLOSED
NEXT YEAR. THIS CURRENT CRISIS
PUT THESE YOUTH IN HARM'S WAY
AND I REJECT CLOSER EXAMINATION
PUBLIC DJJ POPULATION PROTECTION
AS WELL AS A PRIME A PLAN TO
BRING OUR KIDS HOME SOONER
SECOND REGARD ISSUE SIX AND THE
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ALSO
IS A HIGHLY RECOMMENDED NO FOR
THIS PURPOSE OUTPUT PROBLEM
AFTER THIS PROPOSAL TO EXTEND
WHICH IS SLOW DOWN AND LOOK AT
WHAT IS NEEDED. WE SHULD
EXPLORE HOW TO INVEST IN
COLLABORATIVE PARTNERSHIPS THAT
PROMOTE PUBLIC HEALTH COMMUNITY
BASED PARTNERSHIPS WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT HOUSING EDUCATION
AND MORE CALIFORNIA MUST INVEST
IN THE CONTINUUM A COMMUNITY
BASED PUBLIC VIEW DEVELOPMENT
ALTERNATIVES CALLED. FOR UNDER
ITS B. TWO THREE THANK YOU.
HELLO. SEVENTY HELLO. HELLO WE
CAN AREA. HI MY NAME IS NATASHA
JOHNSON AND I'M A POLICY ANALYST
AT THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM I
RECOMMEND NO TEN A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE JUVENILE
FACILITIES GRANT BUDGET PUT MORE
MONEY INTO RENOVATING JANET
PUNITIVE OUTDATED CARCERAL UGL
WHEN WE NEED TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF HOME LIKE
FACILITY. SENATE A SYSTEM ROOTED
IN COMMUNITY HEALTH WELLNESS AND
RESTORATION THIS IS WHERE THE
INVESTMENT MUST BE MADE.
ADDITIONALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
MOST RECENT COVERED OUTBREAK AT
DJJ AND CONSIDERING THE
INSTITUTION CLOSER NEXT YEAR.
YOU SHOULD BE RELEASED TO ENSURE
ENSURE A FOURTH OUTBREAK DOES
NOT OCCUR AND YET THEY'RE NOT.
AGAINST TO ELEMENTS. LONG
PERIODS OF ISOLATION LIMITED
ACCESS TO SCHOOL IN PROGRAMMING
AND OVERALL UNHEALTHY AND UNSAFE
LIVING CONDITIONS THANK YOU.
LINE. FIFTY SEVEN. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES WE CAN AREA. OKAY
GREAT- HI MY NAME IS LIZ PLAN
ACCORDINGLY- BAKER STREET
SACRAMENTO AND ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE CURRENT COALITION I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE ALLOCATION OF A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR. THE
LEVEL- YOU CAN CHARACTERIZATION-
THIS DECISION WOULD FURTHER
SHIFT MASTERCARD DURATION TO THE
LOCAL LEVEL COUNTIES ARE ALREADY
RECEIVING MILLION THROUGH THE
DJJ BLOCK GRANT AND MANY ARE
ALREADY USING THIS MONEY FOR
RENOVATION PROJECT. WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER THE FAILURE OF
ALLOCATING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO COUNTY JAIL EXPANSION
FOLLOWING ADULT AB ONE OH NINE
REALIGNMENT IN TWENTY ELEVEN
INSTEAD OF HOW- ALLOCATING THOSE
FUNDS TO COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES LIKE HOUSING MENTAL
HEALTH CARE- THAT ACTUALLY
PREVENT INCARCERATION OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE NO SAFER AND ARE
COUNTY JAIL CONTINUED TO BE
DEADLY. OVERCROWDED PLACES THAT
THE GOAL IS TRULY TO PREVENT
HUSING PERSPIRATION YOUR BUDGET
DECISIONS NEED TO REFLECT HOW
GETTING HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR YOUTH JAIL RENOVATION AND
EXPANSION WILL NOT MAKE YOU A
FAVOR IT WILL NOT PREVENT YOU
THINK RESTORATION. AND IT WILL
NOT- THE FACT THAT THE ALLEGED
GOALS AT AWAY FROM- PUTTING
USING. ALAINA. NINE CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES WE CAN AREA. MY NAME IS
ARTI I LIVE IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA I'M A YOUTH COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER FOR YOUNG WOMEN'S
FREEDOM CENTER AND I WILL LIKE
TO STRONGLY DISAGREE WHICH A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL
TO FIND- DJ DAY AND- OTHER.
PLACES LIKE THAT BECAUSE- I
BELIEVE THAT INSTEAD OF FINDING
PLACES THAT DO THINGS LIKE
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT AND PEPPER
SPRAY PEOPLE INSTEAD OF TRYING
TO CALM DOWN SITUATION USED TO
FUNDING BY CREDIBILITY PATIENT
CENTER I WOULD APPRECIATE IF YOU
GUYS WOULD TAKE THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND BUILT
CENTERS IN EVERY COUNTY THAT DO
THINGS BY CATS. PROGRAMS
GOVERNMENT CENTER THAT WORK ON
TAKING PEOPLE OUT OF THE
UNDERGROUND STREET ECONOMY AND
PUTTING THEM INTO A PREDICAMENT
WHERE THEY CAN LEARN HOW TO GET
MONEY THE LEGAL WAY AND INVEST
IN THEIR- THEIR MEDICAL BENEFIT
. AND THEIR MENTAL WELLBEING
THANK YOU. LINE. SIXTY EIGHT. HI
MY NAME IS LAURA WITH ALFIE AND
I WORK FOR THE W. HERE WE'RE
GOING TO TOOTHPASTE IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AS SOMEONE WHO WORKS
FOR AN ORGANIZATION THAT IS
COMMITTED TO DISMANTLING
STRUCTURAL RACISM I URGE YOU TO
REJECT THE ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL IN ITEM SIX THE
PROPOSAL INVEST IN AN OUTDATED
PUNISHMENT MODEL AND IT WILL
RESULT IN MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
BEING DUMPED INTO JUVENILE HALL
INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE INHERENTLY
HARMFUL. AND ARE INCONSISTENT
WITH A HUMAN BASED APPROACH IF
WE INVEST A HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS IN JUVENILE HALL WE CAN
EXPECT THE USE OF COLOR WILL BE
WAREHOUSED IN JUVENILE HALL BUT
NINETEEN PAINTED WALLS AND
PUBLIC TELEPHONES AND MEDITATION
ROOMS AND CLOSETS FOR YEARS TO
COME AT THE SATE WE ARE IN A
MOMENT WHEN WE MUST CONFRONT THE
NUMEROUS POLICY CHOICES THAT
HAVE RESULTED IN AN CONSCIONABLE
INEQUITIES IN THE DEEPEST AND
MOST HARMFUL CORNERS OF OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM. THE STATEMENT
MAKE A CHOICE FOR MILLIONS MORE
INTO INSTITUTIONS LIKE JUVENILE
HALL BUT HAVE CONSISTENTLY
FAILED USE OF COLOR OR TAKE THE
TIME TO BE DATA DRIVEN INTO
INVESTORS STATES RESOURCES INTO
BETTER UNDERSTANDING COUNTY
NEEDS YOUTH NEEDS AND DEVELOPING
A PLAN THATMORE APPROPRIATELY
NEEDS DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS OF DJJ
ELIGIBLE YOU I URGE YOU TO
REJECT THE PROPOSAL AND TAKE THE
TIME. TO DO RIGHT BY OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE THANK YOU. LINES. NINE
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR NOT
THE CYBER ON THE HOW THE LOS
POLICE OFFICERS UNIT AT THE
THIRTY FIVE BACK HERE TONIGHT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
NINE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN THE STATE LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP HOW TO TRANSFER THE
YOUTH AND DJJ DOWN THE COUNTY
LEVEL- THE THOUSANDS OF
PROBATION OFFICERS THAT WE
REPRESENT LOS ANGELES IN
PREPARED. TO WORK ON THE SUCCESS
IN BETTER CONDITION OF THOSE
FOLKS BACK INTO SOCIETY IN IN
INTO A PRODUCTIVE AND SUCCESSFUL. MANNER ABOUT DISABILITIES.
SOURCES NOT LAY OUR OUR- A- BILL
. OVER A HUNDRED YEARS OLD IN
SOME IN SOME CASES. AND IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT THE STATURE AT
LEAST INCREASE THE PROBABILITY
OF SUCCESS ON THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WILL GO. A LONG
WAY CUT YOU'RE TAKING THOSE
FIRST COUPLE STEPS. IMMEDIATE
BAD THAT- BASED ON OUR
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT WE NEED IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY YOU KNOW AT
THAT BEEN STATED NO NUMEROUS
TIMES THROUGHOUT THE TEARING- WE
ESTIMATE THAT THE HUNDRED
MILLION ACTUALLY FALL
DRASTICALLY SHORT OF WHAT'S
NEEDED. AS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION OF
OFFERING FOLKS TO COME DOWN TAKE
A LOOK AT. LOOK AT OUR
FACILITIES AND WHERE THEY'RE
DEFICIENT AND HOPEFULLY. MAKE
THOSE IMPROVEMENTS GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU. LINE SEVENTY ONE. HI
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIRMAN WHAT
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ALBERT YEAH
THANK YOU CAN ACTUALLY PREVENT
PRIVATE DIVISION COALITION AT
THE DATA COMMITTED ARMED WITH
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE. I URGE THAT IF
COMMITTEE TO VOTE NO ON THE ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL
THE PROPOSAL TO PROMOTE AN
OUTDATED ADDITION APPROACH IF
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
PROPOSAL MAKERS ARE STATE I
REQUEST A BOOK PROJECT THAT
RATHER THAN INVESTING IN
COMMUNITY HEALTH. AND YOUTH
EMPOWERMENT. YOU HAVE THAT ONE
ONE HUNDRED MILLION BUT DALY WHO
WENT TO- BECAUSE PHYSICAL
PSYCHOLOGICAL AND EMOTIONAL
HARM. RECOGNIZE THAT. WE ARE IN
A MOMENT OF AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REALIZE OUR VISION OF YOU JUST
THE ONE IN LINE WITH THE INTENT
OF SB EIGHT TWO. WHICH HONOR
YOUR HUMILITY AND- THEIR
POTENTIAL BUT THE THREE THAT
I'VE HEARD I URGE YOU TO VOTE
NO. THANK YOU. AS A REMINDER IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY YOU CAN DO SO BY
PRESSING. ONE END ZERO. THAT
COMMAND ONE MORE TIME IS. ONE
THEN ZERO. X. WILL GO TO LINE
SEVENTY THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
IN THIS IS EMILY HARRIS I'M THE
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
AND WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TANK
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. AND THE
ELEVATOR CENTER WE ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH ALL OF THE FOLKS
WHO HAVE THE PRIOR SPEAKERS
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO HAVE SHARED
THEIR PERSONAL EXPERIENCES IN
DURING TIME INSIDE OF- YOUR
CELL. SO WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL
AFTER THE JUVENILE FACILITIES
GRANT. AND APPRECIATE THE
COMMENT FROM BOTH THE CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE ASKING A
LOT OF HARD QUESTIONS AND
PUSHING FOR A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN
AROUND- THE- JUVENILE DJJ SYSTEM
AND WE HOPE TO SEE THIS
COMMITTEE ALSO LOOKING AT GDPR
OUTLAY PLAN THERE SEEMS TO BE A
SIMILAR TREND HERE AROUND
REDUCING POPULATIONS THAT BOTH
THE YOUTH AND THE ADULT LEVEL.
WE NEED ACCURATE AND LONG TERM
POPULATION PROJECTIONS AND WE
NEED A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN AT
BOTH THE YOUTH LEVEL AND THE
ADULT PRISON LEVEL THAT CLOSES
HARMFUL SPACES THAT LOCK PEOPLE
UP AND MOVES TO MOVE THOSE
RESOURCES TO WHAT WE NEED HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. AND I BELIEVE
THIS COMMITTEE IS IN A STRONG
POSITION TO HELP THE FACT FIVE.
ROAD MAP FOR NOT ONLY CALIFORNIA
BUT FOR THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
WE HAVE A HISTORY OF EXPORTING
MASS INCARCERATION IN PRISON
BUILDING HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
IT'S OUR TIME TO REVERSE THAT
TREND AND WE HOPE THIS COMMITTEE
WILL WORK WITH THE ELEVATOR
CENTER AND ALL OF THE ADVOCATE
YOU CALLED IN TO CHART A NEW
COURSE. FOR CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
FOR. LINE SEVEN EIGHT. YOU ARE
WITH THE CENTRAL JUVENILE
CRIMINALS I'D LIKE TO SPEAK ON
ISSUE FIVE AND SIX ON ISSUE SIX
WE RECOMMEND KNOWN TO THE
HUNDRED MILLION PROPOSAL ISSUE
FIVE- COMMITTEE TO ADVOCATE FOR
EARLY RELEASES FOR YOU DR
HEATHER BOTH MENTION RESPONSIBLY
DOWNSIZING DJJ YET THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES FULLY
FUNDING INSTITUTIONS. AT NEARLY
TWO HUNDRED MILLION. IS NOT
WITH. DOWN BY. DIRECTED SAID
EDUCATION AND REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING WILL CONTINUE AS DJ
CLOSES. YEAH WE ARE HEARING FROM
YOU BYE BYE IS NOT OCCURRING THE
REALITY IS THERE HAVE BEEN THREE
COLD OUTBREAKS AND IN THE LATEST
MORE THAN 70% OF YOU FOR
INSPECTED. YOU COVER PART OF
HOURS EACH DAY OF ISOLATION
ABOUT ACCESS TO PROGRAMMING. YOU
HAVE ALERTED US OF STOCK
MISCONDUCT AND A LACK OF CLEAN
CLOTHES AND FOOD. IT IS NOT
BATES AND DJJ IN NOVEMBER STAFF
THEY CONFUSE RANGE FROM 25230%
WE MUST SERIOUSLY CONSIDER
EXERCISE IN THE BUDGET TO
DOWNSIZE BJJ MENTION THAT AND TO
ENACT EARLY RELEASE OF TO BRING
YOU. HOME SAFELY THANK YOU. WHY
AT. SEVENTY FIVE. HI GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS CALLED FOR
RESIDING IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I
AM THE POLICY ASSOCIATED PRESS
LIKE MARCH FOR YOU TO REPLY
THAT'S WHY WE SUPPORT YOU BOLTON
THE TOOTH OUT JUSTICE SYSTEM TO
PUT HEALTHY FREE AND PRODUCTIVE
LIVES WHILE WORKING TO REPLACE I
POINT FOR THEM WITH MEANINGFUL
OPPORTUNITIES FALL FOR YOU.
THAT'S WHY WE RECOMMEND NOTE
ISSUE NUMBER SIX THE PROPOSAL
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
DUMPING MONEY INTO A PUNITIVE
SYSTEM WITHOUT THE COUNT ABILITY
IS NOT CORRECT BROOCH
REALIGNMENT OF THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM GIVES YOU THE
CHANCE TO EMBRACE TRAUMA
INFORMED COMMUNITY BASED
APPROACHES THAT TRULY SUPPORT
YOUNG PEOPLE GIVING ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS BUT NO
ACCOUNTABILITY TO BUILD YOU
PRESIDENT OF THE LOCAL LEVEL
ONLY SHOP SHARE THE FUNDAMENTAL
NON REHABILITATED ISSUE THE DJJ
FROM THE STATE. LEVEL TO THE
LOCAL LEVEL. THANK YOU. LINE.
SEVEN SEVEN. THANK YOU JERRY
MEMBERS STAFFLINE MORNING YOU
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTY THE CALIFORNIAN RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA BAGGAGE CUT DURING
ISSUE 6% DJJ REALIGNMENT IN
JUVENILE COURT WILL DETERMINE
WHETHER YOU TO REQUIRES
PLACEMENT IN THE SECURE
TREATMENT FACILITY IN COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR DELIVERING THE
TREATMENT PLAN TO CARRY OUT THE
COURT'S DIRECTION. WITH THAT
SAID WHEN SUPPORT OF THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
JUVENILE FACILITIES TO HELP
COUNTY MEET THAT RESPONSIBILITY
WHERE YOU GOING WE ARE EAGER TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN
MINISTRY AND MINISTRATION AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO FINALIZE THE
PROPOSAL THAT DISTRIBUTES FUND
QUICKLY SO CAN YOU CAN REDESIGN
CHOCOLATE EVEN MORE CONDUCIVE TO
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING AND
CULTURALLY TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
ORDINANCE THE MODERNIZING
FACILITIES AND THE MANAGER THAT
REDUCES THE LIKELIHOOD OF YOU
BEING TRANSFERRED TO ADULT COURT
WHICH IS NOTED BY THE PANELISTS
IS A PRIORITY FOR ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. THANK. YOU AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS. WELL I. SEVEN
SIX. GOOD EVENING EVERYBODY- MY
NAME IS MARTY IS THAT EITHER
REPRESENTED AGENCIES BY THE NAME
OF COMMUNITY AGENCY FOR RESOURCE
APPLICATION SERVICES CHEERING
YOUR CALIFORNIA- WE RECOMMEND NO
TO THE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR-
PROPOSAL ON THE TABLE THERE'S NO
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN IN THIS IT'S
THROWING MONEY OUT. THAT MONEY
AWAY. THERE'S NO RESEARCH
THERE'S NO PLANNING. OPTIONS ARE
THE SERVER DELIVERED. AND THIS
IS JUST A WASTE OF RESOURCES.
MONEY CAN BE BETTER SPENT TO
PROVIDE YOU SERVICES FROM
INFORMED HEALTHCARE. COMMUNITY
CBO SET. UP INTERESTS ACCORDING
. THIS MONEY JUST A WHIRLPOOL
FOR COUNTIES IN AND CHAMBERS AND
ALSO GIVEN A WHOLE
THOUGHTLESSNESS HI MORE STAFF IN
THE- DEFAULT JUVENILE HALLS AT
THIS AS A STAND WE SHOULD KNOW
WE- RECOMMEND THAT YOU ALSO KNOW
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT THERE'S A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THIS. AND FIGURE THIS
OUT. RIGHT PLAN AND IT'S NOT THE
RIGHT PLAN SO. WE RECOMMEND THAT
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
AND WE HAVE NO MORE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. I WANT TO
THANK THE OPERATOR- FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE AND ALL THE- PUBLIC-
COMMENT THAT CAME THROUGH AND
THE COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD TO TURN. TO THIS MEETING
THANK YOU.